WELCOME YOU TO THE MAY TWENTY
FIRST EDITION OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE. WE APPRECIATE EVERYONE
HERE IN PERSON AND ON THE PHONE
FOR TUNING IN. WE WOULD LIKE TO
GET A COVER SOME QUICK
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS MAKING SURE
THAT ALL ARE IN THE LOOP NUMBER
ONE WE'RE GONNA HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL HEARING ON THURSDAY
MAY TWENTY EIGHTH AT EIGHT
THIRTY AM HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE. WILL BE A SECOND
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE MEETING NEXT WEEK
THURSDAY MAY TWENTY EIGHTH AT
EIGHT THIRTY AM PLEASE PLAN ON
A MINIMUM OF FOUR HOURS- WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO CALL THE
ROLL AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE
SAY GOOD MORNING TO MISTER NOW.
MORNING SUPERVISOR HERE. WATER
PRESENT SENATOR MORLOCK BECAUSE
IT. DIDN'T MOORLACH PRESENT
SENATOR BELL. CENTRE BELL
PRESENTS UNDER HERTZBERG.
CENTER TADO. SENATOR NIELSEN.
SENATE NIELSEN PRESENT SENATOR
WIENER YOU HAVE A QUORUM.
PLEASE IN GERMAN OF COMMITTEE A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
WITH ACTOR CONTINUE ON OUR
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON TODAY'S
DOCKET. WE HAVE MOVED ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SP TWELVE TWELVE TO
CONSENT THAT ITEM WILL JOIN
NUMBER NINE SP FOURTEEN SEVENTY
THREE ON OUR CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE'D LIKE TO TAKE THAT CALENDAR
UP AT THIS TIME TO BILLS IS
THERE A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. MISTER VICE
CHAIR HAS MOVED TO MISTER NOW
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE MCGUIRE HI ATER HI IT'S
AND MORE LUCK I. WILL LOG FIVE
CENTER BILL. WELL I CENTER
HERTZBERG. SENATOR D'AMATO
SENDER NIELSEN CENTER NIELSEN
HI SENATOR WINNER. FOUR VOTES
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
COMMITTEE THAT IS CURRENTLY A
FOUR ZERO VOTE WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP THE CONSENT CALENDAR OPEN
AND WILL ADD ON MEMBERS AS THEY
COME IN AS IT IS A BUSY MORNING
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL THERE'S
GOING TO BE THREE DIFFERENT
WAYS WORKING ASK FOLKS TO BE
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE
COMMITTEE TODAY FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. BUT WE'RE GOING TO GO
SLOW AND STEADY TODAY MAKING
SURE THAT WE ALL HAVE TIME TO
BE ABLE TO JOIN WHETHER IT WILL
BE IN PERSON OR ON THE PHONE
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
DETAILS THREE WAYS THAT FOLKS
CAN COMMUNICATE WITH THIS
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE IT IS
GOING TO BE VERY- OUR TELEPHONE
CONFERENCE LINE WE'RE GONNA BE
GIVING OUT THE NUMBER SEVERAL
TIMES ALONG WITH THE CODE WE
REALLY HOPE TO HEAR FROM YOU.
PLEASE STYLE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TAKE PART IN TWO DAYS COMMITTEE
IN SUPPORT OF ANY BILL PLEASE
DIAL. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN THREE
THREE SIX FOUR FOUR FOUR ONE.
PLEASE ENTER THE CODE. SIX
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE ZERO SIX NINE.
PLEASE DIAL EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
THREE THREE SIX FOUR FOUR FOUR
ONE ENTER THE CODE SIX SEVEN
SEVEN. FIVE ZERO SIX NINE. THIS
NUMBER WILL APPEAR ON YOUR
SCREEN AS WELL. PERIODICALLY
THROUGHOUT THE HEARING. THE
SECOND LADY YOU CAN COMMUNICATE
WITH THE COMMITTEE TODAY IS
RIGHT HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. WE'VE ALSO ESTABLISH A
REMOTE HEARING ROOM THAT ROOM
WILL BE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO BE ACTED
ENTER AND ONE OF THOSE TWO
ROOMS. AND OR ON THE PHONE.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING TO
OUR FIRST TO DEAL OF THE DAY.
THIS BILL IS SENATE BILL NINE
THIRTY FOUR. WE DO HAVE.
SENATOR I'M SORRY WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A QUICK PAUSE BUTTON.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU IF
YOU CAN PLEASE GIVE US A FEW
QUICK MOMENTS PLEASE. YES THEY
HAVE AN HOUR. MODERATOR OKAY.
LADIES IN GERMAN WORD IS GONNA
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES INTO A
QUICK TEST WERE ASKED THE
MODERATOR FIRST AND ALSO WE'RE
GONNA SAY GOOD MORNING TO THE
MODERATOR MISTER MODERATOR HOPE
YOU'RE WELL WE'RE GONNA DO A
QUICK AUDIO TESTS MISTER
MODERATOR WE WANT TO CONFIRM
THAT YOU WERE ABLE TO HEAR THE
VOICES ON THE LINE LOUD AND
CLEAR MISTER MODERATOR I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO YOU.
GIVE US A
FEW MOMENTS WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU. HI. YOUR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE'RE GONNA DO A
QUICK AUDIO TESTS WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE WE'RE GOING TO
TURN THIS OVER TO THE MODERATOR
RESTAURANT MODERATOR GOOD
MORNING WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE LOUD AND CLEAR ON THE
LINE MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU
CONFIRM. I CAN HEAR YOU I CAN
HEAR YOU HOWEVER IF THE VOLUME
IS ON THE LOW SIDE. THANK YOU
MISTER MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA BE
WORKING WITH OUR TECHNICAL TEAM
MISTER MODERATOR WE'LL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOU. ALL WE'LL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU. THE
MODERATOR GOOD MORNING RATED
THAT'S A CHECK IN MISTER
MODERATOR WE WANT TO CONFIRM
THAT THE VOLUME IS ADEQUATE ON
YOUR SIDE OF THE LINE TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO MISTER MODERATOR.
GIVES A FEW MOMENTS PLEASE.
YEAH I MEAN.
POLICY YEAH BY THE
EIGHTEENTH HE SAID YEAH I THINK
THAT. HAVE TO TRY TO CALL YOU
BACK I THAT. AT THE END OF.
WE'LL OF THE OTHER NIGHT. I'M
NOT REALLY. A LOT. THE THING IS
TO MAKE IS NOT TALK TO PEOPLE
AND WE'RE- OKAY. THIS YEAH YEAH
I PREVENT AWAITING.
LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN CANADIAN LAYS IN
GERMAN ON THE LINE IN HERE IN
PERSON WE'RE GONNA JUST
PERFORMANCE A COUPLE MINUTES OF
OUR TEST MAKING SURE WE'RE ALL
ON THE SAME PAGE ON THAT SO
WHATWE'RE GONNA DO NOW IS
WE'RE GONNA SAY GOOD MORNING
AGAIN TO MISTER MODERATOR
MISTER MODERATOR WE APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK WITH US TODAY WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE LOUD
AND CLEAR ON THE LINE I'M GONNA
TURN THE FLOOR. OVER TO THE
MODERATORS. YES YOU ARE HEARD
LOUD AND CLEAR NOW WE ARE
PRIVATE NOT WITH THE ATTORNEYS
ON THE PHONE LINES CURRENTLY.
SO YOU DON'T HAVE ANOTHER MIKE
YOU NEED TO CHECK WE CAN DO
THAT NOW. THANK YOU SO MUCH
PLEASE HOLD MISS MURDERED. GOOD
MORNING MR MODERATOR WE'RE NOW
CHECKING MIKE TO MIKE TO MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
CONFIRM. YES MIKE AIR I'D LIKE
TO ASK IF IT'S POSSIBLE FOR YOU
TO OPEN BOTH MIKE'S TO ENSURE
THAT WE NO LONGER HAV THE ECHO
EFFECT IN FOR THAT GIVE US ONE
MOMENT MISTER MODERATOR. THIS
MISTER MODERATOR WE NOW HAVE
THREE MICROPHONES LIFE CAN YOU
PLEASE CONFIRM. IS A TEST ON
AND I CAN CONFIRM LOUD AND
CLEAR. NO ECHO. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER MURDER WE PRE SHEET
WORK. THANK YOU WITH YOUR
PERMIT TRANSAMERICAN AND YOU
CAN RESUME. ALRIGHT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN HEY WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE TODAY
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU WE HAVE A
FANTASTIC TECHNICAL TEAM HERE-
IN PERSON AND ON THE PHONE AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR ALL THE
COOPERATION AGAIN TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THIS SLOW BUT
SURELY- IN WORK. THAT HAVE A
THINK TANK DIALOGUE TODAY NOT
WASTE INDIVIDUALS HERE IN THE
ROOM AS WELL AS ON THE LINE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
COMMITTEE ANDTHOSE WHO ARE
STANDING BY ON THE PHONE WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
THE FIRST ITEM ON THIS
MORNING'S AGENDA. THAT ITEM IS
SB NINE THIRTY FOUR BUT THAT'S
GONNA BE PRESENTED BY SENATOR
BATES SENATOR BATES IS COMING
TO US LIVE HER DISTRICT OFFICE
SHOULD BE PRESENT MOST GOOD
MORNING BATES OF THE WEBER IS A
REALLY NICE IN ORANGE COUNTY
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. YOUR LIFE
IN WE CAN HEAR YOU. THANK YOU
ARE GREAT TO SEE YOU ALL A GOOD
AFTERNOON IT'S GOOD MORNING.
BOB MISTER CHAIR- MISTER ON
SENATOR MCGUIRE IN MEMBERS AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU ARE
CERTAINLY FOR WHAT YOU'VE DONE
TO PREPARE FOR THIS ISSUE I
THANK STAFF AND CERTAINLY TO
YOU ARE. A SENATOR MCGUIRE SB
NINE THIRTY FOUR SIMPLY
ELIMINATES THE TWENTY FIVE
DOLLAR FILING FEE ON NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS FOR SUBMISSION OF
A STATE TAX EXEMPT APPLICATION.
AS A TEN DOLLAR INFORMATIONAL
RETURN FILING FEE AFFABLE TO
TAX EXEMPT ORGANIZATIONS
CURRENTLY THE PAYMENT OF THESE
FILING FEES CANNOT BE MADE
ONLINE LET'S BE ATTACHED TO THE
APPLICATION FORM AS A PHYSICAL
CHECK. IN THE MAIL TO THE
SPECIFIC POST OFFICE BOX THIRTY
INTO A FIELD OFFICE THESE
FILING FEES ARE NOT CAP. OR
COST EFFECTIVE TO BE ADDED TO
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
AUTOMATED ACCOUNTING SYSTEMS
AND MUST BE MANUALLY TRACKED AS
A RESULT THERE ISN'T ANOTHER.
INCREASE IN THE DEPARTMENT'S
WORKLOAD THE MANUAL TRACKING OF
THESE FEES IS INEFFICIENT AND
CONTRIBUTES LITTLE TO THE
GENERAL FUND ONLY A FEW DOLLARS
PER APPLICATION FEES
CONTRIBUTED FOR EACH
APPLICATION. THE CURRENT
TIMELINE PREVENT SMALLER
ORGANIZATIONS PURSUING THEIR
PURPOSE DURING THE PROCESSING
OF THE FEET WHICH CAN IMPACT
THEIR PERCEIVED GENEROUS. THE
REVIEW WILL THESE FILINGS BEES
AT ALL FOR YOUR THE FRENCH TAX
BOARD TO FOCUS THEIR IN A ON
WORDS MATTER SUCH AS PROCESSING
REACH FOR. AND ENSURING
CORPORATIONS PAY THEIR TAXES
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN THE
NET Z. FROM THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD. YES CONVENE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH SENATOR BATES WHAT WE
LIKE TO BE A TO DO IS UP OUR
MARK MISS MODERATOR WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL
BE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. EACH
INDIVIDUAL WILL HAVE THREE
MINUTES TO BE ABLE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT FIRST WE'RE GONNA BE
HEARING FROM AND IT CAN SEE SHE
TO THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD WE
ALSO GONNA BE HEARING FROM DAVE
WOLF. FROM THE HARBOR JAVERT
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE QUEUE UP THIS CONCEIT
AND MISTER WOLF E. TWELFTH
THREE MINUTES WE'LL START WITH
MS CAN SEE IF YOU COULD PLEASE
TO THEM UP. NOW WELCOME YOUR
LINE IS OPEN MISTER WOLF YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MISS
CAN SEE YOU ARE IN COMMITTEE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YELL
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
THE NET COULD BE REPRESENTING
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND I'M
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR. AS
MENTIONED BILL DOES A COUPLE
THINGS AND WANTED TO ELIMINATE
AN APPLICATION SHE AND THE
OTHERS TO ELIMINATE AND FILING
FEE. GENERALLY THE TYPE OF
THESE ORGAN OF ORGANIZATIONS
THAT BODIES APPLICATIONS ARE
SMALLER GROUPS AND LARGELY BY
TAKING. THE ENTITIES DO NOT
USUALLY HAVE HAD AT BUT YOU
CERTAINLY AVAILABLE AND WILL DO
THEIR BEST TO NAVIGATE THROUGH
THE PROCESS ON THEIR OWN FOR
EXAMPLE. AT THE SCARED LITTLE
LEAGUE YOUTH CENTER PGA THINGS
LIKE THAT SH SO WHILE NOT ALL
ORGANIZATIONS TO INCLUDE THE
APPLICATION FEE OF TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS FROM WHAT WE CAN TELL
THIS IS NOT. BE INTENTIONAL.
WHY NOTABLE BENEFIT OF THIS
CHANGE IS A MORE STREAMLINED
APPLICATION PROCESS DUE TO
AVOID IN THE MANUAL TASK. ANTI
COLLECTION ANALYZES TO PROVIDE.
MORE CONCENTRATION ON CUSTOMER
SERVICE AND OTHER CAT. THE
PROPOSAL ALSO REMOVES THE TEN
DOLLAR ANNUAL FILING FEE FOR
EXAMPLE AND ORGANIZATIONS WHAT
THIS DOES IS IT PUTS THE EXEMPT
ORGANIZATION FILING
REQUIREMENTS ON PARITY WITH
SIMILAR INFORMATION FORMS WHERE
THERE IS NO ASSOCIATED SHE- AND
AFTER. WE COULD EVEN ACROSS THE
CHANGES PART OF A NORMAL ANNUAL
STATE WE DON'T ANTICIPATE ANY
ADDITIONAL COSTS IMPLEMENT. WE
RESPECTFULLY YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION ON AGAIN WE
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU SENATOR
BAIT FOR CARRYING THE PROPOSAL
WHICH WE HOPE WILL HELP MANY
ORGANIZATIONS THANK YOU THIS
CAN SEE WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY WE HAVE A
SECOND PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE THIRTY FOUR.
ARE NOW GOING TO TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO DAVID WOLFF
REPRESENTING THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WOLF WE
WELCOME YOU COMMITTEE GIVE US
THREE MINUTES THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND ACCESS MY OWN TAKE
THAT LONG IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS BILL HAS SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES ALL BE BREACHED. AND
YOU KNOW I'M SIMPLY GOING TO
SAY WHAT STRUCK US AND LOOKING
AT THIS BILL AND WHY WE'RE
SUPPORTING IT IS. ASSERTION
THAT YOU KNOW COLLECTING NEEDS
FEES COSTS ALMOST AS MUCH AS.
THE RACIAL KEEPS PROPOSAL
ITSELF AND IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
ESPECIALLY IN THE MIDST OF A-
OF THE NINETEEN CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC- IT IT WOULD IT'S
BETTER FOR IT CAN BE TO STAND
THERE NO SOURCES CAN YOU. YES I
AND IF WAYS TO GENERATE RATHER
AND NOT JUST CHASE PAPERWORK
DOWN- WHITE YOU KEEP USED TO
WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
WHAT ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER WOEFULLY HOPE
YOU'VE BEEN DOING WELL AND WE
PRETTY SHE OR TESTIMONY. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF COMMITTEE
WE'RE GOING TO COMPLETE OUR-
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL VIA PHONE. WE'RE GOING TO
ASK MR MODERATOR TO PLEASE
PREPARE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE THIRTY FOUR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE PREPARE THEM NOW.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE. ZERO AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOUR LOW NUMBER
AND FURTHER INSTRUCTIONS. IF
YOU'RE USING A SPEAKER PHONE WE
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE PICK UP THE
HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS. PLEASE ALLOW US A FEW
MOMENTS TO PROVIDE LINE NUMBERS
AND I WILL TO THEM. MISTER
MODERATOR WE ARE CURRENTLY
LOOKING FOR INDIVIDUALS ON THE
PHONE NINE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE THREE FOUR. FOUR
GOING TO TAKE A MOMENT. MISTER
MODERATOR Q. EACH OF THOSE
SUPPORTERS HAVE. MISTER
MODERATOR ARE YOU PREPARED ARE
THERE ANY INDIVIDUALS PREPARED
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
NINE THREE FOUR. WE DO HAVE-
ONE WE HAVE LINE NUMBER THIRTY
THREE. FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD MORNING YOUR LIFE AND
COMMITTEE WE WELCOME YOU. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS LUCY SALCEDO
CARTER I AM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
CELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS A
CEDAR CARTER WE'RE GRATEFUL.
MISTER MODERATOR OR ANYONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB. NINE THREE FOUR.
THERE IS WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
THIRTY THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD MORNING YOUR LIFE AND
COMMITTEE IF YOU PLEASE PROVIDE
YOUR FIRST AND LAST NAME IN
YOUR ORGANIZATION YOU'RE NOW
LIVE. MR KERRY MEMBERS
MANTICORAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TAX REFORM ASSOCIATION JUST
WHEN I THINK THE OFFER. HER
STAFF AND- FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO WALK US
THROUGH THEIR INTENT HERE. I
AND ONE OF OUR OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. MISTER MODERATOR
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE THREE
FOUR IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUE. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME SIR
YOU MAY CONTINUE THANK YOU
MISTER MODERATOR WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE CHECKING FOR ANY IN
PERSON SUPPORT. WE'RE GOING TO
START RIGHT HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF.
CENTER BATES SB NINE THREE FOUR
CAN YOU PLEASE COME TO MY LEFT
TO THE MICROPHONE. ERIN SEEN NO
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE TO GO
TO A REMOTE HEARING TESTIMONY
ROOM. THAT'S ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
IS THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT
PEOPLE ARE BATTEN DOWN THE
HATCHES IN COMMON IN LATIN
PROUD THERE ALL RIGHT. SO WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND NOW WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO THE PHONE LINES NOW
WE'RE GOING TO ASK MR MODERATOR
TO SIR QUEUING UP. INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION.
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE THREE
FOUR MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE Q. INDIVIDUALSUP
ONE OPPOSITION OF SB NINE THREE
FOUR. THE FLOOR IS YOURS MISTER
MODERATOR ONE IN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. GONNA GIVE IT A QUICK
MOMENT. HE IS A MODERATOR THOSE
WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE THREE FOR ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE. SEVEN BEEN PROVIDED TO
Q. THERE'S NOT DOING UP AT THIS
TIME SIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
RESTAURANT MODERATOR NO ONE IS
IN OPPOSITION ON THE LINE OF SB
NINE THREE FOUR WE'RE NOW GOING
TO GO TO THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK PLEASE DO SO NOW BUT I'M
INTO THE MICROPHONE TO THE LEFT.
KAREN SENIOR ONE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO A REMOTE HEARING
ROOM ROOM TWENTY FORTY ANYONE
IN. OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD NOW. HEARING SEEN NO
ONE WE'RE GONNA BRING THIS BACK
TO COMMITTEE. WITH THAT TO BE
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE. FOR
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT. MMHM WE HAVE
A MOTION BY THE MAJORITY EADER
MAJORITY LEADER HERTZBERG. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS JUST OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ERIN SEEN IT NO QUESTIONS WE
HAVE A MOTION ON MOTION WHICH
IS A DO PASTOR PREPARATIONS
BEFORE WE GO TO THE VOTE. WE'RE
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR
BATES FOR ANY CLOSING COMMENTS
IN SENATOR BATES WE APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL NICE
WORK. FOR YOUR CLOSING COMMENT
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. I JUST
THANK YOU ARE FOR THE
CONVERSATION TODAY- AND I ASK
FOR YOUR IDOL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR BATES IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU THIS AS A DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS MOTION MISTER
NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR MCGUIRE HI WIRE
OUR EYES WERE LOCKED I. MORE
LOCK BY SENATOR BILL. BELL
SENATOR HERTZBERG BY. WHICH
BURGER FIVE SENATOR D'AMATO HI.
TITLE SENATE. RIGHT NIELSEN OUR
SENATOR WE- IF SIX VOTES
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX ZERO
VOTE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT
VOTE OPEN TO ALLOW CENTER
WIENER TO BE ABLE TO ADD ON
HERE WHEN YOU'RE RIGHT TO
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR BATES RENOWNED MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO ITEM
NUMBER TWO IS SENATE BILL NINE
FIFTY SIX THIS IS A SENATOR
JACKSONVILLE WE SAW HER IN THIS
COMMITTEE SHE WORKED. A LOT OF
PRESSURE ON THIS BILL WE WANT
TO SAY HOW MUCH WE APPRECIATED
HER WORK LAST YEAR ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL WE'RE GONNA GO
OVER TO SENATOR JACKSON TO
PRESENT IN PERSON HERE IN FORTY
TWO THREE ON SB NINETY SIX THE
FLOOR IS YOURS MA'AM. YOUR
CHAIR YES INDEED THE BILL COME
BEFORE YOU WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
A- YOUR COMMITTEE AND I
APPRECIATE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THEN. THE BILL DID GET TO THE
GOVERNOR. HE VETOED THE BILL WE
ARE WORKING WITH HIS DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NOW. TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS- I AM CONFIDENT
THAT WE WILL GET THERE. THIS IS
A GOOD GOVERNMENT BILL. IT WILL
HELP US IMPROVE OUR SYSTEM OF
TAX CREDITS TAX DEDUCTIONS AND
TAX EXEMPTIONS TO ENSURE WE ARE
MAKING THE BEST USE. OF OUR
EVER INCREASING LEAD LIMITED
PUBLIC. TAX DOLLARS. ARE DIRE
BUDGET SITUATION DUE TO THE
COLD IT NINETEEN EPIDEMIC
BRINGS THIS ISSUE TO THE FOR
EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY. THAN THE
LAST TIME WE MET- WE ARE.
SUFFERING NOW A AN UNEXPECTED-
PLUMMETING OF OUR RESOURCES AND
AS A RESULT A SEVERE REDUCTION
IN SERVICES AND ESPECIALLY IN
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM WHERE
WE'RE LOOKING AT AT LEAST A
PERHAPS A TEN BILLION DOLLAR
SHORTFALL IF NOT MORE
REMEMBERING THAT AFTER TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT WHEN WE TOOK
SO MUCH OUT OF THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM WE HAVE NOT EVEN GOTTEN
BACK TO WHERE WE WERE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. AND WE ARE
CONTINUING TO PLUMMET AS A
RESULT OF THIS EXPERIENCE OUT.
THIS IS BASED UPON THE FACT
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS ABOUT
EIGHTY TAX EXPENDITURES. THESE
ARE PROVISIONS IN THE TAX CODE
THAT INCLUDE TAX CREDITS TAX
DEDUCTIONS SALES TAX. AND
INCOME EXCLUSIONS THAT REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF TAX COLLECTED IN
EXCHANGE FOR IN INTENDED PUBLIC
POLICY OBJECTIVE A LEGITIMATE
CONCERN A LEGITIMATE GOAL. MANY
TAX EXPENDITURES LOWER CREATED
DECADES AGO WHICH CHIEF CERTAIN
GOALS AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS AT
THE TIME SEARCHERS IMPROVING
INDUSTRY COMPETITIVENESS
INCLUDING TAX PAYER BEHAVIOR
FOR SPURRING ECONOMIC GROWTH
ALL WERE GOALS. BUT THEY HAVE
SPENT ON THE BOOKS FOR DECADES
WITHOUT ANY SCRUTINY WITHOUT
ANY OVER RIGHT OR EVEN THE
NECESSARY DATA TO DEMONSTRATE
THE WRIST WATCH THAT WERE
SHOCKED. THIS TAX EXPENSE. A
SIGNIFICANT COST TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE SAME SPENDING
PROGRAMS THIS PAST YEAR FOR
EXAMPLE PAST YEARS NOT UP TO A
CHANGE IN THIRD THIS YEAR TAX
EXPENDITURES ALONE WITH THE
STATE REVENUE TO THE GENERAL
FUND BY SOME SIXTY SIX BILLION
DOLLARS. YOU AREN'T BUT GENERAL
FUND AND HAVE TOTAL. OUR FOR
THE RE MENTIONED THOSE GOALS
BUT WE DON'T KNOW THAT. EVERY
DOLLAR OF IT EXPENDITURES DOZEN
GENERATE SCOTT IN NEW WERE TAKE
PRIDE FOUR SAN. OUT OF
CALIFORNIA'S CLASSROOMS VIA
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT AND
REDUCES THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR CRITICAL PUBLIC
SERVICES SO THE QUESTION IS ARE
THESE TAX EXPENDITURES WORTH
THEIR COST. IT'S A
STRAIGHTFORWARD QUESTION IT
SHOULD BE A NON- POLITICAL
QUESTION. IT IS A QUESTION OF
WHETHER OR NOT TAXPAYERS ARE
GETTING THE BENEFIT OF THE-
VALUE OR IN THE VALUE OF THAT
THEY ANTICIPATED WHEN THESE TAX
CREDITS WERE MADE. THE
UNFORTUNATE FACT IS WE HAVE NO
IDEA. WE DON'T KNOW AND SO
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL ATTEMPTS
TO ANSWER A TWENTY FIFTEEN
AUDIT BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR REGARDING THE STATE'S
TAX EXPENDITURES CONCLUDED
QUOTE ADOPTING OVERSIGHT
METHODS WOULD IMPROVE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE STATE'S
CURRENT AND FUTURE TAX
EXPENDITURES PROVIDING THE
LEGISLATURE WITH MORE
INFORMATION AND A ACCOUNTING OF
THEIR EFFECTIVENESS IN IMPACT.
A TWENTY SEVENTEEN REPORT BY
THE PEW CHARITABLE TRUSTS
SCORED CALIFORNIA AS TRAILING
WITH TWENTY EIGHT STATES AHEAD
OF US IN EVALUATING THEIR TAX
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS AND
INFORMING LEGISLATURE'S AS TO
THE VALUE OF SUCH PROGRAMS.
BILL WILL BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
EXAMINING SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST TAX EXPENDITURES TO
EVALUATE WHETHER THEY'RE
ACHIEVING THEIR GOALS. AND THIS
BILL A CHOOSES AMONG THE
LARGEST OF THE TAX CREDITS AND
SALES TAX EXEMPTIONS THAT HAVE
NO METRICS OF EFFICACY
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM NO SUN
ETTING PROVISIONS AND RESULT
IN. REVENUE LOSSES OF GREATER
THAN A BILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR. AND THE BILL IS PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED REQUEST AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. ANALYZE
EACH TAX EXPENDITURES. TO
DETERMINE IF THEY ARE IN THE IN
FACT ACHIEVING THE GOALS
LEGISLATURE INTENDED. THE
FINDINGS ARE PRESENTED TO A NON
PARTISAN BOARD COMPRISED OF THE
STATE COMPTROLLER THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST THE STATE
AUDITOR THE DIRECTIVE OF
FINANCE OR THEIR DESIGNEES AND
A REPRESENTATIVE WITH THE STATE
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION.
THESE FINANCIAL EXPERTS WILL
TAKE A LOOK AT THE DATA AND
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE- GIVING THE
LEGISLATURE A CLEARER PICTURE
OF THE EFFICACY OF EACH OF
THESE TAX EXPENDITURES. THE
BOARD HAVING CONSIDERED THAT
INFORMATION MAKES THAT
RECOMMENDATION. THE I URGE THAT
THIS COMMITTEE. IN CONCERT WITH
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE DO
MEMBERS HERE TODAY UP HOLD A
PUBLIC HEARING TO CONSIDER THE
UC'S REPORT IN THE BOARD'S
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN THE
BOARD'S EXISTENCE WE'LL SUNSET
SIX MONTHS AFTER THIS HEARING.
IT'S MY HOPE THEN THAT FOR ANY
TAX EXPENDITURES FOUND TO OUT
LEAVE THE POOR STRAYED FROM ITS
PURPOSE THE LEGISLATURE WILL
THEN ULTIMATELY TAKE THE STEP-
TO VOTE ALTER OR TERMINATE. OUR
THESE ARE IN ON INEFFICIENT AND
FAILING IF YOU WILL TAX CREDITS.
I DON'T NEED TO SAY HOW-
SIGNIFICANT THIS DEFICIT IS
GOING TO BE FOR US THE FACT
THAT EDUCATION IS GETTING
HAMMERED THAT WE ARE GIVEN
WHERE WE SHOULD BE AND NOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SIGNIFICANT
CUTS IN EDUCATION. SO GIVE THE
DIRE BUDGETARY SITUATION AND
THE LIKELY CUTS TO THESE KINDS
OF SERVICES SERVICES TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS- MEDI CAL BENEFITS
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES CHILD
CARE THING SO WE ALL CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT. THIS MEASURE OUT
WILL. PROVIDE A RUBRIC N. A
METRIC GOING FORWARD SO THAT WE
KNOW WHERE OUR TAX DOLLARS ARE
GOING AND WHETHER OR NOT THEY
ARE BEING USED APPROPRIATELY.
LEGISLATORS DESERVE TO HAVE
THAT KNOWLEDGE AND- HAVE THE
INFORMATION THIS WILL PROVIDE
IN THEIR TOOL BOX. THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK OUR AYE VOTE
AND I HAVE I BELIEVE. THIS IS.
A BRAVE NEW WORLD I BELIEVE
AVAILABLE- AS WITNESSES ARCADY
HARTMAN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION KRISTI
PALMA REPRESENTING OUR STATE'S
FIREFIGHTERS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER JACKSON'S IN GERMAN
THERE'S GONNA BE THREE WAYS YOU
CAN PARTICIPATE AND PROVIDE
COMMENTS THIS BILL. FIRST AND
FOREMOST YOU CAN TALK TO US VIA
THE PHONE AT THIS TIME IF YOU
TO BE A COMMENT ON SB NINE FIVE
SIX PLEASE DIAL EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. THREE THREE SIX FOUR
FOUR FOUR ONE CODE. SIX SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE ZERO SIX NINE THEN
THE PHONE IN CODE IS ALSO ON
SCREEN. EVEN COMMON IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE OR ALSO IN A
REMOTE HEARING ROOM IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. HERE'S THE ORDER
WE'D LIKE TO BE A TO TAKE THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH OUR TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THE BILL
THAT'S GOING TO BE KATIE
HARTMAN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO TO CHRISTY BALMA
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS THEY WILL BE WITH
US ON THE PHONE MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
PREPARE MISS HARTMAN IN THIS
BOOK. FROM THE CALIFORNIA FOR
FIREFIGHTERS SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE FIVE SIX MISTER
MODERATOR. PART OF IT AND IT
MAY OMA YOUR LIFE ARE OPEN.
MORNING WE'RE GOING TO ASK MS
HARMAN FROM THE CAL TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF NINE FIVE SIX
IT'S HARD WHEN YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOUR
NOW LIVE IN COMMITTEE. GREAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS KATIE HARD AND A WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. I THINK HE IS A
PROUD CODE. AND ACT THE NINE
DAY AND WE WANT TO SENATOR
JACKSON'S- HER LEADERSHIP. AND
YOU ALL KNOW THE GOVERNOR
RECENTLY RELEASED THE MAYOR OF
BEIJING REVEALING- ABOUT A
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT YOU TO COME BUT
NINETEEN. INCLUDING NINETEEN
BILLION FOR HOLDING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND- BUT EVEN BEFORE
COPE IN. AND FUNDING FOR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
ADEQUATE. AND WHILE SCHOOL
THEY'RE COMPARING TO REOPEN AND
GRAPPLING WITH THESE HUGE
BUDGET CUTS THE DAY IS ALSO
GIVING AWAYBILLION. DOLLARS IN
TAX BREAKS WITHOUT REVIEW OR
OVERSIGHT. AND I SENATOR DR
MENTIONED AND THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET AND POLICY CENTER DINNER
AND DEAL- AND REVEALED THAT
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS- AND TAX BREAKS
IN AND TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY.
AT THIS IS FINDING THAT WOULD
HAVE OTHERWISE GONE TO THE
GENERAL FUND TO FIND YOU KNOW
VITAL PROGRAMS LIKE EDUCATION
AND- PUBLIC SAFETY AND OTHERS.
AND MANY OF THESE TAX CREDIT
HAD NEVER BEEN REVIEWED BY THE
STATE AND BOTH. IS STRONGLY AND
REPORT BACK THE NINE FIVE SIX.
IT WOULD CREATE AN INDEPENDENT
REVIEW BOARD AND TO REVIEW THE
MOST COSTLY TAX CREDIT. AND
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT THAT THE
IS PROVIDING THE NECESSARY
OVERSIGHT OVER ILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN LOST TAX REVENUE.
WITH THE DECLINING REVENUES DUE
TO COPE IN NINETEEN WE BELIEVE
THAT THE BALLOT EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT. I'M AND SO WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT AND THAT THE NINE
FIVE SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISS HARTMAN WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY LADIES AND ON
THE COMMITTEE WERE NOT GONNA GO
TO CHRISTINE BLOOMER. CAL
PROFESSIONAL PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IS WILLIAM THREE
MINUTES SO GIVE YOU THIRTY
SECONDS ON'T. YOU ARE RIGHT NOW
IN COMMITTEE YOUR- AND WE.
WELCOME YOU GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE. RECEIVED MISTAKE
TODAY AND HAVE TO CAL.
PROFESSIONALS STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THE- SB NINE FIVE SIX I'LL
TAKE TWO SECONDS OF THE
PERSONAL PRIVILEGES THANK YOU.
ALL ALL MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
TO DOING THE PEOPLE WHO WORK.
BUT ALSO PROVIDING SAFE OPTIONS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE
SO I'M GRATEFUL FOR THAT. OUR
FIREFIGHTERS COMMITTEE DETECT
PROJECT I AND PROPERTY INCLUDES
RESPONDING TO NINE ONE ONE
CALLS NOT JUST RESPOND FIRES
THE FLOODS EARTHQUAKES AND ALL
HAZARDS. AND TODAY AS YOU KNOW
HELP EMERGENCIES ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. A LITTLE NINETEEN
AND THEN I. WELL CALIFORNIA'S
GRAPPLING WITH A SUDDEN AND
STAGGERING BUDGET DEFICIT AND
STARTING WE ARE ALSO STARING
DOWN THE BARREL OF ANOTHER
DANGEROUS FIRE SEASON.
CALIFORNIA'S TAX POLICY HAS A
DIRECT RELATIONSHIP TO
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO STAND
UP AND FIRE FIGHTING RESOURCES.
AND ALLOW STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FIREFIGHTERS TO
EFFECTIVELY PROTECT THEIR
COMMUNITIES. SB NINE FIVE SIX
OF THE RIGHT TO REMOVE TAX
POLICY DECISIONS THE WAY FROM
JUST A HUNCH AND TOWARDS AN
EMPIRICAL QUANTITATIVE.
ANALYSIS BUT THE TAXES THAT
EXPENDITURE BUT SHE'S PLAN AND
THE- POLICY GOALS THAT SUNSHINE
AND TRANSPARENCY BROUGHT TO THE
CALIFORNIA'S TAX EXEMPTION
PROCESS. WILL BETTER INFORM ALL
OF YOU AND MAKING DECISIONS OF
GREAT CONSEQUENCE THAT WILL
IMPACT CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY. TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL FIRE FIGHTING
AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE SERVICES
NO MORE HUNTERS. DECISION
MAKING SURE TRANSPARENCY NO.
THAT WE AND YOUR STRAW SUPPORT.
OF SB NINE FIVE SIX. EMMA THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE AND THOSE WHO ARE ON
THE PHONE AS WELL AS HERE IN
PERSON WE'RE NOT GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT. WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE
MARK MADE HER TO PLEASE QUEUE
UP ALL OTHER INDIVIDUALS ON THE
PHONE LINE. THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE QUEUE UP THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF NINE FIVE
SIX. THANK YOU WE HAVE A FEW
THAT ARE PREEMPTIVELY- CUED UP
HOWEVER I WILL REMIND CHANNEL
LOOK LADIES AND GENTLEMAN ON
THE PHONE LINES TO QUEUE UP AND
SO. FORTH S. ONE. ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE WILL FIRST GO TO THE
LINE NUMBER FIFTY FOUR FIVE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
YOUR NOW LIVE IN COMMITTEE CAN
YOU PLEASE GIVE US YOUR FIRST
AND LAST NAME AND ORGANIZATION
YOUR NOW LIVE. BRIAN MICHAEL
ANY- WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S
SEVENTY THREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT. SMACK I
ANY THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR NEXT TESTIMONY PLEASE.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY
SEVEN THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD MORNING YOUR NOW LIVE
IN COMMITTEE IF YOU COULD
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME IN ORGANIZATION YOU
ARE NOW FIVE. YES THANK YOU
ELIZABETH ASK ABOUT WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISSUS CANAL. WE'RE
GONNA GO BACK TO THE MODERATOR
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP THE NEXT INDIVIDUAL IN
SUPPORT OF SB. NINE FIVE SIX.
THANK YOU WILL GO LINE NUMBER
THIRTY NINE THREE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GOOD MORNING IF
YOU COULD PLEASE PROVIDE A
FIRST AND LAST NAME AND
ORGANIZATION YOU ARE NOW LIVE.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JENNIFER
BAKER REPRESENTING THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING. AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WHERE STRONG RECORD
ENDING SENATOR JACKSON FOR HER
WORK ON THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU
MISS BAKER MISTER MODERATOR
WE'D LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION HOW
MANY FOLKS ARE IN THE QUEUE IN
SUPPORT OF NINE FIVE SIX. I
STILL HAVE THREE MORE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MISTER MODERATOR CAN CAN WE
PLEASE TAKE CONNECT INDIVIDUAL
IN SUPPORT. YES WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY EIGHT FOUR EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD MORNING
IF YOU COULD PLEASE PROVIDE
YOUR FIRST AND LAST NAME AND
ORGANIZATION YOU ARE NOW LIVE
IN COMMITTEE. THE MORNING JUST
CAN SOUND LIKE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU JUSTIN. MISTER
MODERATOR WE'RE NOW PREPARED TO
TAKE THE NEXT INDIVIDUAL IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIVE X.
WE'LL MEXICO THE LINE NUMBER
FIFTY THREE FIVE THREE YOUR
LINE OPEN GOOD MORNING CAN YOU
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME IN ORGANIZATION YOU
ARE LIVE IN COMMITTEE NOW.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING IT'S
ONLY LOWER WITH A CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
ALSO INSTRUCT THE COURT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. MISTER
MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR
NEXT INDIVIDUAL IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE FIVE SIX. THANK YOU AND
I ALSO LIKE TO SPEAK OUT TO
LINE NUMBER THIRTY YEAR MAYOR
AN ADVERT MANY PROMOTE YOURSELF
FROM THE QUEUE BY RE ENTERING
THE ONE ZERO PROMPT PLEASE
REENTER IF YOU WISH TO PLACE
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE AND THEIR
ICO. WILL GO TO LINE THIRTY
NOW. MORNING CAN YOU PLEASE
PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND LAST
NAME IN ORGANIZATION YOU ARE
NOW LIVE IN COMMITTEE. MEDICAL
TO CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION CROWD SUPPORTER OF-
CO SPONSOR OF THE MEASURE THIS
YEAR AS WELL AS BLASTERS
MEASURE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR. AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALL OF THEIR WORK ONE STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MISTER MODERATOR CHECKING
IN HOW ANY FOLKS WE HAVE IN
THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FIVE SIX. WE HAVE TWO MORE THAT
HAVE CUED UP. LET'S TAKE OUR
NEXT INDIVIDUAL INSTEAD PLEASE
ANSWER MODERATOR. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER FIFTY
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD MORNING YOU ARE NOW
LIVE. PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR FIRST
AND LAST NAME IN ORGANIZATION
YOUR LIVE IN COMMITTEE. BURGER
WITH SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION INCOME
SUPPORT. YOU SO MUCH FOR
HANGING ITH US IN FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WE APPRECIATED MISTER
MODERATOR NEXT INDIVIDUAL IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIVE SIX.
YES WILL GO TO LINE THEM SIXTY
THAT IS SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD MORNING CAN YOU
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR- ALREADY
HAD THANK YOU. BECAUSE. OF OUR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE PTA
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WE GREAT WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THAT. MISTER MODERATOR CAN WE
GET A COUNT OF THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT IN THE QUEUE. THERE ARE
NO FURTHER IN Q. AT THIS TIME
SIR. NICE JOB MISTER MODERATOR
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO- ROOM
TWENTY FORTY DO WE HAVE ANY
INDIVIDUAL IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO'D LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. HERE IN SEEN NINE WERE
NOT GOING TO GO HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIVE SIX.
XENON WE'RE NOT GONNA MOVE TO
OPPOSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF COMMITTEE WE'VE TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL BE THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WE'RE GONNA ASK AT
MADAME SENATOR- WE'RE GONNA
ALLOW I BELIEVE MISTER I'LL BE
ON A YOU'RE GOING TO BE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
PERSON CORRECT MISERABLY ANI.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WE'RE GONNA HAVE
MISTER I'LL BE ON A I BELIEVE
WE'RE LOOKING TO THE SERGEANTS
AT RIGHT OVER HERE- I'M SORRY
RIGHT THERE I APOLOGIZE THANK
YOU MISTER OF THE ANI. YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO DESTIN WEATHER
BE REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION. MR
WHETHER WE WILL BE ON OUR PHONE
LINE AFTER MISTER I'LL BE ON
THE SPEAKS IN OPPOSITION
MISERABLY ANI THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES.
THANK YOU FOR THIS AND I
APPRECIATED- DUSTIN FROM CAL
TAX IS GOING TO BE FIRST FLOOR
BILL RIGHT NOW. SO I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. AND
WE REPRESENT OF FAMILY BUSINESS
THE PRIVATELY HELD. ENTITIES
THAT HAD COURT ON CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION FAR REBUILT. FROM
A SMALL FOR. THESE TWO AS MANY
AS FOURTEEN VALVES SO THESE ARE
THE BEST. OF. CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. ONE OF THAT. ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES. TO SIX
THEN IT WOULD A FOR BUSINESS
AND MOVED TO THE NEXT. AND
GROWING BUSINESSES TAX. TAX
POLICY AND TAX PLANNING SKEWS
ME. UP SO AS WE MOVE ONE OF THE
WITNESSES THE SOME O THESE UP
ENTITIES ARE TAX GIVEAWAYS WE
ACTUALLY CONSIDER THEM TAX THE
STATE IS INVESTING. THEIR
INVESTING IN EMPLOYEE HEALTH
CARE WHICH IS CRITICAL AT THIS
TIME THEY'RE INVESTING IN
RESEARCH THEY'RE INVESTING IN%
JOBS AND SO THESE ARE TAX
CREDITS THAT ACTUALLY IN. US
TYPE AREA HOW MANY NOW I'D LIKE
TO LOOK AT THE END ALSO SINCE I
THE SECOND. IS THIS. THERE'S
LOTS OF SCRUTINY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES WE HAVE
THE BUDGET PROCESS WOULD BE ON.
IN FACT THE GOVERNOR HAS
VANISHED CERTAIN PROPOSALS TO
PACIFIC TAX CRADLES. CREDIT AND
THE OPERATING LOSS ADJUSTMENTS
TO THE TUNE OF FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS. PLEASE ARE GET SCREWED
ME WITIN THE GOVERNOR THE
MINISTRATION M. BUDGET PROCESS
BUT TELL A- DEAL TOWARDS
FINANCED REPORT THE AUDITOR
ALREADY DOES REPORTS AS THE
SENATOR- IDENTIFIED IN HER
TESTIMONY. THE HOST OF GEO
THINK TANKS ALSO DO THE REPORT
SO THERE'S PLENTY OF SCRUTINY
GOING ON IT IS THE NECESSARY WE.
AT THE END. AND THEN. WE
QUESTION WHY LOGIC WOULD.
DELEGATE THE A FULL THIS FULL
OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY YOU HAVE OF
THE INTEREST. TO A BALL WERE
FOR OF THE FIVE PEOPLE ARE
ADMINISTRATIVE. ENTITIES TO
CONTROL THE FINANCE OF THAT THE
ONLY LEGISLATIVE ENTITY IS THE
LA- ON THAT. SO WHY. DO THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE THE CONTROL
ALREADY IN YOUR PROCESSES BOB.
SO FROM THAT STANDPOINT WE
THINK THAT THIS IS DUPLICATIVE
OF THE OVERSIGHT THAT ALREADY
OCCURRING OVERSIGHT TO CURRENT
AND WE APPRECIATE THE- THE V.
THE THOUGHT TO THE FOLKS. AND
AT THIS TIME OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU OF ANY THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE TODAY IT'S GOOD TO SEE
SIR- WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
GOING TO OUR PHONE LINES. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FIVE
SIX PLEASE DIAL ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN THREE THREE SIX. FOUR
FOUR FOUR ONE YEAR AN INNER
CODE. SIX SEVEN SEVEN FIVE ZERO
SIX NINE THAT PHONE NUMBER IS%
ON YOUR SCREEN NOW. WE'RE GONNA
BE GOING TO DISCERN WHETHER BE
REFERENCING THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION. HE'S
GONNA BE OUR SECOND AND FINAL
PRIMARY OPPONENT AND WE'RE
GOING TO ASK FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
ALSO OPPOSED TO THE BILL AFTER
MR WEATHERBEE. MISTER MODERATOR
DO YOU HAVE MR WEATHERBEE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION READY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. MY APOLOGIES BUT I
DO NOT SHOW THAT HE DIALED IN
ON A KEY WITNESS LINE WITH YOUR
PERMISSION I WILL. GIVE
INSTRUCTIONS IN CASE HE DIALED
IN ON THE PUBLIC LINE YES
PLEASE SIR THAT WOULD BE GREAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
WHETHER YOU IF YOU ARE ON THE
CONFERENCE WE CANNOT. IF YOU
WOULD PRESS STAR. THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE KEY PAD AN
OPERATOR WILL RETRIEVE YOUR
LINE AND PLACE YOU CAME TO THE
KEY WITNESS Q. OUR SOME MOMENT
TO SEE IF ANYONE TEARS UP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MODERATOR. MODERATOR LET'S
CHECK IN ON MR WEATHERBEE. BUT
WE DO HAVE A FEW THAT HAVE CUED
UP FOR HELP REQUEST SIMON
GETTING MY OPERATOR HELP TO
THOSE LAWS ONE MOMENT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. GOOD HOUSEKEEPING ITEM
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING SB NINE
FIVE SIX WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
BILLS FROM SENATOR GLAZER.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE SB THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE FIRST AND THEN SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE SECOND-
THAT WILL BE COMING UP AFTER
SENATOR JACKSON. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA BE CHECKING IN WITH
THE MODERATOR FIRST AND
FOREMOST. DO WE HAVE MR WHETHER
BE ON THE LINE MISTER MODERATOR.
I DO NOT HAVE THEM AT THIS TIME
AND I DO HAVE THEM TO LINES
BEING ANSWERED AT THIS MOMENT I
AM. DOING MY HELP TO GET THOSE
LINES RETRIEVED ONE MOMENT
PLEASE THANK YOU SO MUCH
DESERVED. WHILE WE'RE WAITING
FOR THE MODERATOR WHAT WE'D
LIKE TO BE TO DO IS TAKE UP OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR- AND WE'RE
GOING TO ADD SENATOR WIENER ON
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. WE
COULD PLEASE HAVE CENTER WIENER
APPROACHED THE DICE. ALL RIGHT
BESIDE SO MISTER NOW IF YOU
COULD PLEASE GIVE THE CURRENT
VOTE FOR CONSENT CALENDAR AND
THEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MISTER FOR NOW ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR TWO ITEMS.
BIRD VOTE IS POOR TWO ZERO
CENTER HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG
BY SENATOR TACO. TIME RICARDO
HI SENATOR WIENER. WIENER HI.
SEVEN VOTES THANK YOU SO MUCH
THAT WAS SB TWELVE TWELVE SB
TWELVE TWELVE IN SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY THREE ON OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR THE CONSENT CALENDAR
HAS NOW BEEN APPROVED THOSE
BILLS ARE OUT AND WE'RE GOING
TO CLOSE THE ROLE THE SEVEN
ZERO VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. BUT IS IN GENERAL
COMMITTEE WERE NOW GOING TO BE
GOING BACK TO OUR MODERATOR
WE'RE GONNA FIRST ASK-
MODERATOR IF WE HAD MISTER
WHETHER BE ON THE LINE IF WE DO
HE WILL BE PROVIDED THREE
MINUTES TO BE TO PROVIDE
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY IF NOT
MISTER MODERATOR WILL TAKE
THOSE OTHER INDIVIDUALS.
WAITING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
MISTER MODERATOR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. DO NOT HAVE HIM AS OF
YET SO WHAT WITH YOUR
PERMISSION I WILL GO TO. ON THE
PHONE TO SEE WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
PORT AT THIS TIME WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION IS A
MODERATOR. GAME BUT ONE MOMENT
BUT THANK YOU FOR THOSE WHO ARE
ON THE PHONE LINES WERE LOOKING
FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE FIVE SIX REALLY THOSE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FIVE SIX
ON THE PHONE. THE OPERATOR LET
US KNOW WHEN YOU'RE PREPARED. I
AM PREPARED WE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FIFTY FIVE FIVE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD MORNING
IF YOU COULD PLEASE PROVIDE
YOUR FIRST AND LASTNAME YOUR
NOW LIVE IN YOUR ORGANIZATION
YOUR NOW LIVE IN CAN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JUSTIN HIGHER
IN THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND I'M
CALLING TO REGISTER OPPOSITION
TO SB NINE FIVE SIX THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH YES. DO YOU HAVE ANOTHER
LINE CUED UP. RELATED TO
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FIVE SIX.
I DO IT TO YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FIFTY TWO FIVE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GOOD MORNING IF
YOU COULD PLEASE GIVE US YOUR
FIRST AND LAST NAME IN
ORGANIZATION YOU ARE NOW
LIGHTING COMMITTEE. WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THE CALLER ON THE
LINE IN OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME AS WELL AS YOUR
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE NOW LIVE IN
COMMITTEE. ALRIGHT LET'S GO
BACK TO MISTER MODERATOR MISTER
MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA TAKE OUR
NEXT CALLER IF YOU COULD PLEASE
TO THEM UP AND PREPARE THEM TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SB NO FIVE
SIX. THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN FOUR SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CRAFTING YOUNG TO THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
APPRECIATE IT. WE'RE NOW GOING
TO ASK MR MODERATOR. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION. TO
SB NINE FIVE SIX. I HAVE ONE
IT'S FROM THE LINE NUMBER FIFTY
SIX FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD MORNING IF YOU COULD LOOK
PLEASE MORNING YOUR PERSON LAST
NAME AN ORGANIZATION YOUR
LIGHTING COMMITTEE. GOOD
MORNING CAMERA DIMITRI WITH
TECH THAT HERE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION AS BEING I COULD DO
TO. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE
MODERATOR MISTER MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
PREPARED TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB NINE FIVE SIX. I DO HAVE
ONE MORE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
FORTY THREE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS. CHAIR
GOOD MORNING THIS IS MISTER
WHETHER BEING. YEAH AS I'M
SORRY ABOUT THAT MISTER NO NO
NO I WAS IN LINE NO NO NO THIS
WEATHER BE NO REASON TO
APOLOGIZE WE'RE JUST GRATEFUL
THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE. THAT
MISTER V. AYE AYE AS YOU KNOW
MISTER OUR BONNIE. TESTIFIED IN
A POSITION HERE AT THE MINUTE
WE APPRECIATE YOU HANGING WITH
US MR WEATHERBEE. THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS. AS
WEATHERBEE YOU OF THREE MINUTES
THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOUR NOW
LIVE IN COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. A GOOD MORNING IS
FOR MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR JEFF. ABOUT THE WEATHER
BE LIKE HELP TAX ASSOCIATION.
HERE WITHIN OPPOSE LEAD AND THE
TESTING. FIVE ATTACKS IS
LEADING THE COLA OF MORE THAN
FIFTY. OPPOSED TO THE- SCARE
STATE RESOURCES CREATE ANOTHER
TAX EXPENDITURE REVIEW BOARD
WELL WE ALREADY HAVE A THOROUGH
REVIEW PROCESS IN PLACE.
EARLIER THIS YEAR THE COALITION
THE AUTHOR PLACE TO DISCUSS
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF OUR
COALITION PARTNERS AFTER THIS
NEARLY IDENTICAL A LIST. BY
GOVERNOR NEWS OVER. MAN MAN.
IMPORT COMING. UNDER THE
CURRENT BILL CERTAIN AND- WOULD
BE ABOUT A USED BIAS UNDER IT'S
CHECK THE- IT IS INCLUDE THE
BENEFITS DOWN MULTIPLY THE
INCENTIVES. SUCH AS ADDITIONAL
JOBS HIGHER PRODUCTIVITY OR
OTHER BENEFITS STERN SPEECH
OVERALL ECONOMY IN GENERAL FUND
ADDITIONALLY SEVERAL STATE
AGENCIES SUCH AS THE DEAL LAST
CITY CAFE ALEJO CAL. MISSION
YES THE AUDITOR ORDER YOU
ALREADY PRODUCED REPORTS ON
STATE TAX INCENTIVES CAN
PROVIDE SUGGESTIONS. EACH
INCENTIVE TO ME IT'S GOAL. AND
ANOTHER STATE
NECESSARY AT THE GOVERNOR NOTED
AS A MESSAGE LAST YEAR. WITH
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS IN THE
UNEMPLOYMENT LINE IN BUSINESS
IS STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE
THREATENING TO TAKE AWAY TAXES
AND MY GREAT VALUE TO OUR STATE
ECONOMY IS NOT THE RIGHT PUBLIC
POLICY. AS A MATTER OF DOLLARS
AND CENTS THE STATE IS FACING A
BUDGET CRISIS AND SIMPLY DOES
NOT HAVE THE READ. OKAY FOR THE
NEW DOCTORS. OKAY JUST. THE
TIME AND PLACE FOR TWO. CENTERS
IT'S TIME LIKE THESE WHEN
ECONOMY THE MOST. BUT TAX. AT
THE POWER THANK YOU THE BEST
THE STATE. I CAN EXPANSION
ENCOURAGE A HIGH. IN BUSINESS
REGAINED. WHAT RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF ENSURING. DOLLARS
BEST OF. WE DO NOT THINK THIS
IS THE BEST APPROACH. WE SHOULD
ALL BE COMING TOGETHER THE
FOCUS ON ECONOMIC RECOVERY JOB
GROWTH THE STATE WOULD HELP I.
INSTEAD CONSIDERING THE BILL.
IT COULD NOT HAVE HAS ALREADY
BE. SO PLEASE REASONS WE
RESPECT BUT- THE NOTE. THANK
YOU. THE WEATHER BE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
APPRECIATE YOU HANGING WITH AT.
EIGHT THAT WE'RE- A- CALL FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN OFFICE. OF
THIS BILL ALAS CALL THOSE WHO
ARE IN OFFICE. SB FIVE SIX ON
THE PHONES. MODERATOR ANY
DOUBTS. Q. IN OPPOSITE AT NINE
FIVE SIX. THERE IS NOT BUT IT
FOR MY YOU CAN PRESS ONE ZERO
TO VOICE YOUR ON THE PHONE
LINES AT THIS. LAST CALL MISTER
MODERATOR ANYONE ELSE OTHERWISE
YOU'RE GOING TO NOW GO TO IN
PERSON TESTIMONY. THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME SIR PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS MODERATOR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WERE
NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO
TESTIMONY HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. MISTER MCKINLEY
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS A
CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF
COUNTY OF THE COMPUTING
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. AND WE DO REMAIN
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED. BUT DO
WHICH SENATOR JACKSON A HAPPY
BIRTHDAY WEEK. HEY THERE WE GO
IF. SHE'D BEEN ADDED ON THE
BIRTHDAY WEEK THANK YOU SO MUCH
MR MCHALE LEA. WE'D LIKE TO BE
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
WHO IS IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OF THREE. KAREN
SEEN ONE. WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO GO TO OUR REMOTE HEARING
ROOM IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY THAT
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY PREPARED TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. KAREN
SEEN KNOWN WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BETTER BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE WE LIKE TO BACK TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY DISCUSSION
WITH COMMITTEE. WE HAVE- THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE HAVE THE
MAJORITY LEADER. THE VICE CHAIR
AND INTO MISS. AS HER TITLE. MR
MAJORITY LEADER. THANK VERY
MUCH MOISTURE. ONE OBSERVATION
AND ONE QUESTION ON IN THE
OCEAN I REMEMBER SITTING ON A
CAR A CONFERENCE COMMITTEE WITH
WALLY KNOX IF YOU REMEMBER THAT
NAME SOME YEARS AGO AND DIANE
WATSON DAN WATSON SOME YEARS
AGO DEALING WITH THESE ISSUES
HAVE BEEN GRAPPLING WITH THIS
FOR A LONG TIME. JUST FOR THE
RECORD IT'S IMPORTANT. THAT WE
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW THIS TAX
CREDIT THINGS ARE TOUGH AND YOU
KNOW I LIVE IN A COMMUNITY
WHERE THE MOTION PICTURE
BUSINESS IS PRETTY BIG. A LOT
OF GROUPS AND FOLKS THAT WORK
IN THE DAY TO DAY ARE THERE AND
A LOT OF BUSINESSES THAT ARE
IMPACTED WITH THEIR LOCKS
MISTER BAKERIES OR WHATEVER.
AND WE HAVE A AN INDUSTRY IN
THE MOTION PICTURE BUSINESS
THAT. GO TO GEORGIA LOUISIANA
OR CANADA. AND SO YOU KNOW THE
ARGUMENT ABOUT THESE TAX
CREDITS. ON THE HAVE DIFFERENT
DIMENSIONS TO THEM. WE LEARNED
THE HORRIBLE IMPACTS WHEN
SOMEBODY WHO WORKS AS AN
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR ON THE FILM.
HAS TO MOVE AWAY FROM THEIR
FAMILY FOR SIX WEEKS. WITH
THOSE ARE FACTORS THAT WE LOOK
TO AND ANNOUNCER IN THIS REGARD
SHEER DIAGNOSTIC IS CRITICAL I
DON'T DISAGREE. BUT I THINK
THAT THESE ARE SO COMPLEX
BECAUSE ON THE FACES ALWAYS
EASY TO SAY OR MY GONE YOU'RE
GIVING THESE TAX CREDITS WILL I
LOST THE HIT WILL HEAD QUARTERS
OF THE COMMITTEES ARE PRESENT
FROM MACY'S. BECAUSE THEY JUST
LEFT IN A WE LOST TO THE
COMPANY THAT PUT THE SPACE
SHUTTLE ON THE MOON FROM THE
COMMUNITY THE HENRY STERN
REPRESENTS. AND THERE'S A
COMPLEX SERIES OF FACTORS THAT
GO INTO THIS AND YOU MARIE THAT
WITH OTHER IMPACT TONIGHT WITH
WHICH CONCERNS ME AS WE MOVE
FORWARD I JUST THINK IT'S A-
PORTENT. IS ON THE- CLEAR THE
DIAGNOSTIC HAS TO BE MADE BUT-
BEING OF THESE PACKS MUST BE
CONSIDERED RATHER THAN JUST
THIS A YOU KNOW BALANCE SHEET
APPROACH BECAUSE THERE'S SO
MANY OTHER CONSEQUENCES IN THE
AREAS THAT WE CARE ABOUT SO.
IT'S EASY TO JUST JUMP ON IT
AND SAY OH MY GOD THIS HURTS
THE BUDGET NERVES ALL THESE
THINGS AND OFTEN THERE ARE
POLITICAL GROUPS THAT HAVE A
LOT OF POWER THAT ENGAGE DO.
YOU KNOW COULD SOME OF THE
WRONG AND IS POST SOME THAT ARE.
I CLEAN YOUR OPENING COMMENTS
MADAM CHAIR. THAT SHOULD SHOULD
BE CHANGED BECAUSE THE TIMES
HAVE CHANGED THERE'S REASONS. I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE. THAT IS
WE THINK THIS THROUGH- THAT WE
GET GUIDANCE TO LOOK AT IT IN
THE BROADEST CONTEXT AND THAT
OFTEN IT'S NOT JUST A BALLOT
SHE DIAGNOSTIC IT'S A MUCH
DEEPER DIAGNOSTIC. THE SECOND
COURT THE SECOND PART OF MY
ENQUIRIES A QUESTION. THE BILL
WAS VETOED LAST YEAR ABOARD FOR
IT WAS VETOED YOU ON PAGE EIGHT
OF THIS ANALYSIS THERE ARE. ONE
TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SIX SEVEN
EIGHT NINE CHANGES. BUT YOU
KNOW THE QUESTION IS ARE WE
WASTING TAXPAYER DOLLARS BY
GOING BACK AT THIS BOOK I'M NOT
SUGGESTING WE ARE BECAUSE IT
TOOK FORTY TWO TIMES TO PASS
THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT IN
CONGRESS. BUT IS THIS SOMETHING
WHERE THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
MAYBE IT'S IMPORTANT POINTS
LITTLE BILLION I DON'T CARE. IF
YOU COMMUNICATE WITH THEM WHAT
DOES THIS LOOK LIKE TO HAVE A
BETTER CHANCE AND IF WE DON'T
IT'S STILL A VALUABLE IDEA
DON'T TAKE IT AWAY I JUST
WANTED TO UNDERSTAND. AS YOU
ADDED UP THESE THINGS WHICH
PART TO ME. DOES IS SECOND IN A
THE ABILITY OF THIS BECOMING
THE LAW OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION OF
FOOD THE CHAIR PLEASE. TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU THERE WAS A
LITTLE BIT OF A
MISUNDERSTANDING LAST YEAR- AND
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING DIRECTLY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO CLARIFY WHAT EXACTLY THIS
BILL IS INTENDED TO DO AND AS
YOU POINT OUT THIS BILL DOESN'T
COME FROM A PLACE SAYS THESE
ARE AT TAX CREDITS. WE WANT TO
GET TO THEM AND YOU MENTION
CHILLI THE FILM COMMISSION THAT
IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF WHAT WE
NEED FOR THESE OTHER TAX
CREDITS BECAUSE SOME OF THEM
ARE INDEED QUITE VALUABLE. AND
WE'RE NOT TO THE THIS BILL
DOESN'T SAY HEY. X. Y. AND Z.
HAPPENS THEY'RE GOING TO THROW
THAT OUT WHAT IT DOES IS TO
CALL UPON THE UNIVERSITY TO DO
A FOR ALL NOW. THEN SEVEN HOURS.
VARIOUS ENTITIES THAT HAVE FISK
AND POLICY OUR RESPONSIBILITIES
TO THE STATE THEN IT COMES TO
THIS COMMITTEE WHERE IF THERE
IS A CONCERN THAT PERHAPS A
FAMILY BUSINESS FOR EXAMPLE IS
WAS LISTED- HAS CREATED
ENORMOUS BENEFITS TO THE STATE
AND THAT HASN'T BEEN CONSIDERED
IT CAN BE FACTORED IN AND THEN
IT CALLS FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
DO ITS OVERS OVER THIS SO THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF ACTIONS HERE.
THE QUESTION TWO CLICK WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH THESE TAX CREDITS
AND CONTRARY TO THE SUGGESTIONS
THAT WERE MADE ALL WE HAVE NOW
IS A LIST. THESE ARE THE TAX
EXPENDITURES IS THAT EXIST THIS
IS WHAT THE STATE BLOOM. THESE
TAX EXPENDITURES. MET US ISN'T
A DOG INTO WHAT THEY ARE. THE
WHAT WE KNOW NOW IS THERE SIXTY
SIX BILLION DOLLARS OR A YEAR
THAT WE LOSE BECAUSE OF THEM
PERIOD IT DOESN'T TELL YOU WHAT
THE BENEFITS ARE. IT DOESN'T
TELL YOU. HOW MUCH OF IF WE
GIVE A DOLLAR WE GET FIVE
DOLLARS BACK. THESE ARE THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO KNOW
THAT'S WHY THE AUDITOR SAID HEY
FOLKS. IT WOULD BE HELPFUL IF
WE HAD THIS INFORMATION THAT'S
WHY THE PEW. CHARITABLE TRUSTS
INDICATED THERE ARE TWENTY
EIGHT OTHER STATES THAT ARE
DOING WHAT THIS BILL IS ASKING
US TO DO THAT ARE WAY AHEAD OF
US INTO. RUNNING FOR NORTHEAST.
IS INCENTIVES MAKE ANY SENSE SO
I LOOK AT FILM ARE. THINK
THAT'S A PERFECT EXAMPLE CENTER
HERTZBERG. WHAT WOULD. PROMPTLY
SHE AND WE HAVE AND WE ARE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I'M
VERY OPTIMISTIC. THAT THIS TIME
AROUND YOU WILL GET THE MEASURE
SIGN THE GOV. GOOD YEAH I JUST
I AM. FOR MAKING IT FOR A
RECORD FOR THE DELIVERY IN THIS
BILL I JUST WOULD. SAY JUST TO
EAT YOU PRO NOT FAR HELD AS WE-
CANNOT CONVOLVULUS VERY A MAP.
OVER RESILIENCY. RIGHT IT MAY
BE CHEAPER TO BUY SOMETHING IN
INDONESIA VIETNAM OR SOMETHING
BUT YET THEY'RE STINGS WITH THE
SUPPLIES THAT WE NEED OR ALL
KINDS OF THINGS. THAT MAYBE
THERE'S VALUE TO BRING
MANUFACTURING IN ADDITION TO
THE JOBS. AND MAYBE YOU HAVE TO
DO A TAX CREDIT TO DO THAT BUT
YOU GET RESILIENCY OUT OF IT
SO. I WAS TALKING TO THE FOLKS
AT INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
WERE THERE MAKING A TRANSFORMER
XIN THEIR PIPES IN THE WIRES
OVERSEAS. CAN SAVE A FEW BUCKS.
BUT THERE'S A VALUE TO HAVE IT
HERE YOU KNOW. AND SO WHEN YOU
DO THE DIAGNOSTIC IT'S JUST TO
ME IN MAKING THIS RECORD WE
WANT TO THINK THROUGH ALL OF
THOSE THINGS. SHE TO REIMAGINE.
AS WE SEEK TO BUILD AND I WHAT
I DON'T WANT TO SEE IS THAT
THIS TOOL BECOME SOMETHING THAT
IS JUST A BALANCE SHEET
ANALYSIS WITH. YOU CORRECTLY
NOTE I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT.
IS THE PORT HAVE THE RIGHT I
APPRECIATE YOUR- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
RESEARCH LATER AT LAZY GENERAL
CAN WE'RE GONNA GO THE VICE
CHAIR AND SENATOR HER TANTO.
THANK YOU MS CHAIR OF. CENTER
JACKSON I THINK THIS IS. YOUR
GOAL IS RIGHTEOUS AND I. JUST
KIND OF MAKES YOU WONDER WHAT
WHAT'S THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND WAS TO LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WHAT ARE THEY
DOING AND WHY HAVEN'T THEY BEEN
DOING IT AND IT'S SORT OF AN
INDICTMENT AND I'M- CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
RINGING THE BELL. AGAIN. WE
HAVE ANOTHER BILL IT'S BEFORE'S
LATER TODAY BUT IT DID IT WOULD
REQUIRE THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
TO DO A STUDY AND I AND I
WONDER IF WHY WE'RE NOT
REQUIRING OUR EXISTING AGENCIES
TO DO THE HEAVY LIFTING TO SEE
WHAT'S GOING ON SO I'M A LITTLE
CONCERNED. ABOUT SETTING UP A
WHOLE NEW BOARD- AT THIS TIME I
JUST I'M JUST UNCOMFORTABLE
JUST IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S A GOOD
PROJECT FOR OUR FELLOWS PROGRAM
IS TO DIG IN AND- DO THIS AND
FIGURE IT OUT. SO. I'M THE
THING THAT MAKES ME EVEN. THE
MORE UNCOMFORTABLE IS THE FACT
THAT EVEN AFTER WE DO ALL THIS
YOU STILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. AND I WATCHED THE
MOVIE CREDIT BUILD TWO YEARS
AGO. I CAME HERE SAYING I DON'T
WANT TO DO ANY MORE CREDITS
BECAUSE I NEED MONEY TO PAY
DOWN THESE PENSIONS. AND SO I
THINK I WAS THE ONLY ABSTENTION
ON THAT BILL EVERY OTHER
SENATOR VOTED FOR THE CREDIT IT
WAS JUST IT WAS JUST A MOMENT
HELLO WAS NOT. NECESSARILY A
BILL YOU KNOW WE DID READ THE
ARMY HAVE ANY DISCUSSION IT
JUST KIND OF FLEW RIGHT THROUGH
SO. SO IT'S KINDA CAPRICES EVEN
AFTER WE DO ALL THIS WORK FOR
STILL GONNA FIND AN EMOTIONAL.
HOOK AND THEN IT'LL BE IGNORED
AND- SO THEREFORE I AT THIS
TIME BECAUSE OF. THE CURRENT
CLIMATE I WILL FIND MYSELF OF
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND I JUST
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
RINGING THE BELL IT'S GREAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU. MR MORE LIKE WE LIKE TO GO
TO CENTER TITLED IN SENATOR
BELL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
JUST LIKE TO ASK A QUICK
QUESTION- FOLLOWED WITH A
COUPLE COMMENT FOLLOWED BY A
QUESTION- PLEASE CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG I NOTICED THAT IN AND
OF THE STATE OF THE BILL. IT
INCLUDES ABOUT WHAT IS TO BE
ASSESSED AND THAT INCLUDES THE
FARM EQUIPMENT OUR MACHINERY.
ESERVER IT REASON OR PURPOSE
FOR HAVING THAT IN THERE OR- HI
YES IT'S A GOOD QUESTION. OF
THAT FORM TAX CREDIT I THINK
GOES BACK TO THE FORTIES
THROUGH THE FIFTIES- IT MAY BE
THAT WE SHOULD PROBABLY THERE
OR NOT PROBABLY IT MAYBE WE
SHOULD INCREASE IT. IT MAY BE
THAT WE SHOULD DECREASE IT IT
MAY BE THAT WE SHOULD JUST KEEP
IT AS IT IS THERE MAY BE A-
FARM MACHINERY MAYBE THERE'S A
TYPE OF FARM MACHINERY THAT WE
SHOULD INCENTIVIZE OVER ANOTHER
BECAUSE OF THE KIND OF PRODUCTS
THAT ARE BEING DEVELOPED WE
JUST HAVE NEVER LOOKED AT IT IT
DOES GENERATE TO I BELIEVE WE
LOOK AT THINGS THAT ARE- CREATE
A BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY. OF
A TAX CREDITS TO THESE
DIFFERENT ENTITIES IT'S A LOOK
THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS THAT
PRESUMES ONE WAY OR THE OTHER
WHAT IT DOES IS WHAT WE DID IS
WE LOOKED AT THE VARIOUS
TACTICS PICTURES CREDITS THAT
WE'VE HAD IN PLACE FOR A PERIOD
OF TIME THAT CREATED WHAT AT
LEAST A ONE BILLION DOLLAR A
YEAR OR MORE. EXTRA AND THAT
THESE WERE THE FOR. I THINK
ELEVEN OR TWELVE THAT WE
OBSERVED WHERE WE HAD NEVER
DONE ANY OF THIS ANALYSIS. SO
THE NOTION THAT BY DOING THE
ANALYSIS WE'RE GOING TO REMOVE
THE CREDIT. I THINK IS NOT WHAT
THIS BILL. WILL DO OR IS
DESIGNED TO DO. IT IS JUST
SIMPLY DESIGNED TO LOOK AT
THESE. CREDITS THAT HAVE
RESULTED IN THE SIGNIFICANT-
TAX EXPENDITURES- AND TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
HAD A HAVE DONE WHAT IT IS THEY
WERE SUPPOSED TO DO. BE ARE
STILL RELEVANT AND SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO EITHER TO. ADJUST THEM
TO BE MORE REFLECTIVE OF THE
TIME IS SENATOR HERTZBERG SAID
RESILIENCE. IS NOW POTENTIALLY
A CRITERIA MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
TEN YEARS AGO. BUT THE BEAUTY I
THINK OF THIS MEASURE IS THAT
IT CALLS FOR THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA. WHICH IS A RESEARCH
INSTITUTION PROBABLY THE FINEST
IN THE WORLD IS WILLING TO DO
WITH THIS STUDY WITHIN PUT BY
THE WAY ON A VARIETY OF
CRITERIA. YEAH AND POTENTIALLY
INCLUDING THOSE THAT WERE
SUGGESTED IN THE- OPPOSE BUT IT
MEANT. I DON'T WANT TO BE
STANDING HERE I'M NOT A
FINANCIAL EXPERT TELLING THEM
WHAT THAT HAS TO INCLUDE I WANT
THEM TO DETERMINE BASED UPON
WHAT THE INTENT IS OF THIS
LEGISLATION. WHICH IS TO
ANALYZE AND SEE WHETHER OR NOT
THESE TAX EXPENDITURES DID WHAT
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO ARE YOU
STILL DOING ITS OF THEY SHOULD
BE CONTINUED. SO WE HAVE THEM
DOING THE DATA AND THE FACT
FINDING WE THEN TAKE IT TO THE
FINANCIAL EXPERTS THE STATE TO
DO THE ANALYSIS. THEY DO THE
ANALYSIS THEN THE PUBLIC A
CHANCE TO HAVE INPUT AND THEN
COMES TO. AS POLICY MAY. THE
SITE WE WANT WITH THE XIN.
WHERE WANT TO. THERE'S A PAUL.
I MEAN THAT'S THE NATURE WE ARE
WHERE THE MACHINE. AND A
BROUGHT HAVE BROKE THIS. THIS
ALL IS. FINE THAT'S WHAT I
WOULD FOR HERE WE DO. CHARGE.
IT'S A TOTALLY AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED NEUTRAL PROCESS IT IS
NOT A- HAS ANY IDEOLOGY TO IT
IS WHAT IS IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF THE TAXPAYERS OF THE STATE
GOING FORWARD AND THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL ATTEMPTS
TO ACHIEVE AND I BELIEVE. WITH
THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AND
ALL THAT THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON I THINK IT WILL
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE I JUST
WANT TO KIND OF GIVE A BRIEF
EXAMPLE I KNOW THAT YOU
MENTIONED YOU YOU SEE WOULD BE
PART OF THE RESEARCH CRIED THEY
WILL BE DOING THE RESEARCH
RIGHT AND STOLE MY CONCERN IS
THAT IN MY SCHOOL DISTRICT IT'S
HAVE A LOOK YOU HAVE. THAT
RIPPLE. KHAN RIGHTS. WE HAVE-
BUT WE DON'T HAVE A YOU SEE IN
OUR IN IN OUR IN OUR REGION SO-
OR AT LEAST IN THE SENATE
DISTRICT OF THE SOUTHERN
CENTRAL VALLEY SO WE EAT YOU
KNOW I'M JUST. BRING IN AND
RAISING THE CONCERNED THAT IT
WE'VE- I FIND IT DIFFICULT TO
HAVE SOMEONE. YOU KNOW I KNOW
THAT THEIR EXPERTS AND- BUT IF
YOU'RE NOT FROM THE REGION AND
IF. AND IF YOU'RE NOT REALLY
FAMILIAR WITH IT MAKES IT A
LITTLE BIT MORE CHALLENGING TO
COMPREHEND AND SO. I JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS MY CONCERNS
OF- THAT HAPPENED WITH YOUR
LEGISLATION AND- AND WANTED TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE UP BUT AT THIS
MOMENT I CANNOT SUPPORT IT
TODAY. WELL I APPRECIATE THAT
WHAT I WILL TELL YOU IS THAT WE
ARE CALLING UPON. EXPERTS WHO
ARE AMONG THE FINEST FINANCIAL
MINDS. IN THE WORLD. TO DO THIS
RESEARCH SO. I DON'T THAT ONE
NEEDS TO LIVE IN A IN A
PARTICULAR. WAY TO UNDERSTAND
THE ECONOMICS OF THAT AREA. I
EXPECT. THE THIS IS TO BE. LATE
OUR- THEIR SON TRYING TO ALL OF
THIS THERE WILL BE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THE
DOCUMENTS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE ALL THE DIFFERENT
STATE AGENCIES WHERE I SUSPECT
THERE ARE INDEED PEOPLE. COME
THIS. AS WELL BUT WE'RE GONNA
LOOK AT THIS FROM THE POINT OF
VIEW OF THE EXPERTS IN
ECONOMICS. THEY ARE GOING TO
PROVIDE THAT BASELINE FOR US
THEN WE ARE GOING TO THAT THERE
THERE WILL BE THE LAYERS.
BECAUSE IT COMES BACK THE
LEGISLATURE IS THE OF THE
SECTIONS WHICH TELL
RESPONSIBILITY. FOR THAT IN
POOR. A FROM THE POT.
TERMINATION THE POLITICS OF
DIFFERENT. SO I EXPECT THE
CENTER FOR TAUGHT ARE THAT IF
YOU FELT THAT THE INFORMATION
HAD NOT BEEN PROPERLY. OBTAINED
TO THAT THERE WERE
CONSIDERATIONS THAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN INCLUDED THAT WARRANT.
THAT YOU WILL HAVE THAT VOICE
AND FRANKLY I THINK THAT BOYS
WITH OUR WILL BE HEARD IN THE
PRIOR TO THAT. BECAUSE WE KNOW
AGRICULTURE LIVE A LOT OF
AGRICULTURE MY DISTRICT TO. IS
THE NUMBER ONE ECONOMIC ENGINE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GIVE SHORT
SHRIFT. IT'S THE GOAL TO THE
VIBE. THE STATE ARE. THINKING
THANK YOU. CENTER TANTO
THINKING TENER JACKSON WE LIKE
TO GO TO SENATOR BELL AND I
BELIEVE THAT'S GOING TO BE OUR
FINAL COMMENT. HE WOULD ALSO
WILL COME A MOTION AT ANY TIME.
PROMOTION BOTTOM LEADER. MISTER
BELL YOUR COMMENTS FOR YEAH
SUPPORT I HAVE SUPPORTED THIS-
HOWEVER HAVE A PARTICULAR.
TWIST TO MY VIEW ON THIS
SUBJECT BECAUSE I THINK THAT.
OF THE ECONOMIC PLACE THAT
WE'RE CREATING WITH TAX
CREDITS. WHAT I CALL ECONOMIC
PLACE LIKE THE CENTER OF
TECHNOLOGY- THERE'S BEEN
CREATED- WAS THE RESULT OF
THINGS LIKE THE TAX CREDIT THE
REAL THE- FOR RD TAX CREDITS-
THE- THE IN CITY ON THE SIDE
THAT CALIFORNIA. SUPPORTED
RESEARCH INTO MINE. THE
INVESTMENT THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE IN OUR
UNIVERSITY AND COLLEGE SYSTEM.
IN THE END THE DIRECT-
CONNECTION BETWEEN R. AND D. OF
AND- THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND STANFORD
UNIVERSITY ANY OTHER
UNIVERSITIES. THAT HAVE YOU
KNOW DONE A GREAT JOB AND-
SUPPORTING- THE NEW IDEAS AND
NEW TECHNOLOGIES. AND NEW- OF
THE ECONOMY THAT WE NOW HAVE SO
I THINK WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS. THEY ARE INDEED UM
TAX CREDIT. IS A PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE THAT IS REALLY
BENEFITTED CALIFORNIA.
IMMENSELY BEYOND WHAT WE CAN
IMAGINE FROM- LIKE A NARROW
ECONOMIC VIEW POINT OF THE OF
THE OF THE TAX CREDIT WE HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE HAVE
DECIDED TO LOCATE THEIR
BUSINESS YEAR WHY. WE HAVE
CREATED A POOR ECONOMIC PLACE
SILICON VALLEY WHICH- I THINK-
I WOULD QUESTION THE
AGRICULTURAL BE THE NUMBER ONE
THING TO THE CAR I THINK
TECHNOLOGY IS. PROBABLY A
LITTLE BIGGER IN TERMS OF THE-
REVENUE THAT WE GET IN TERMS OF
THE JOBS AND SO FORTH SO I JUST
WANT TO ARGUE THAT TECHNOLOGY.
IN CALIFORNIA BEEN A MAINSTAY
OF OUR ECONOMY. AND THE RD TAX
CREDIT HAS REALLY. HELP CREATE-
VERSUS OTHER STATES THAT HAVE.
DIRECTLY EVERY SINGLE DAY EVERY
SINGLE MINUTE HAVE BEEN
COMPETING AGAINST US. AND
THEY'RE STILL DOING IT AND THEY
STILL WILL DO IT BUT WE HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE OF THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE THIS. THIS
PIECE. TOGETHER BENEFIT FOR
PEOPLE TO LOCATE BUSINESSES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND THE RD
TAX CREDIT IS A BIG PART OF
THAT SO I JUST WANT TO POINT
THAT OUT OF FOR MY AREA A LOT
OF THE JOBS DEPEND ON THAT AND
NOW A LOT OF OUR BIG COMPANIES.
AND SMALL COMPANIES AND NEW
COMPANIES UTILIZE THE RD TAX
CREDIT FOR THE BENEFIT OF
CALIFORNIA. AND IF I MAY MISTER
CHAIR PLEASE I SUSPECT THAT
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS
ANALYSIS WILL SHOW THERE'S
NOTHING TO SUGGEST THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE ANY- RECOMMENDATION
TO REDUCE IT IN FACT THE FAX IT
THE UNIVERSITY WILL COME UP
WITH WILL PROBABLY SHOW THE
EXTENT TO. OF THESE VERY TAX
CREDITS HAVE BENEFITTED THE
STATE- N. IN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT SIGNIFICANT WAYS THAT
WE MAY NOT HAVE EVEN CONSIDERED
PREVIOUSLY SO. THIS GET A
NEUTRAL THIS IS A FACT FINDING
EFFORT. ARE THAT- IS JUST
SIMPLY GOING TO PROVIDE US WITH
INFORMATION GOING FORWARD.
ABOUT WHAT WORKS. WHAT DOESN'T
WORK WHAT WE CAN DO TO IMPROVE
WHATEVER THE GOALS ARE THAT WE
THE LEGISLATURE TERMINATE TO BE
APPROPRIATE FOR WORK WHETHER
WOULD LOOKING PERSONALLY SEE
OVER. THING ELSE BUT AT THIS
POINT TIME WE CHOSE THIS IS
GOING TO GIVE US ADDED WE NEED
A OF THOSE DISCUSS. FOR ARE.
AND CAPTURE RIGHTS SENATOR BILL
PERHAPS TECHNOLOGY HAS TAKEN
OVER FROM MAC BUT LET ME PUT IT
THIS WAY BOTH ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT STATE OF OUR WITH.
APPLE SO. HEY HOW. ALL RIGHT.
LAYS ENGINE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR THE ROBUST CONVERSATION AND
I ALSO WANT TO REMIND COMMITTEE
THE ORIGINAL FORM THIS BILL
LAST YEAR WAS LOOKING AT A
STREET REPEAL- MANY TAX CREDITS
IN WHAT. CENTER JACKSON HAS
DONE OVER THEPAST MANY MONTHS-
IN WORKING IN COORDINATION IN
IN COLLABORATION WITH HIS
COMMITTEE IS DEVELOPING A DATA
DRIVEN APPROACH A DATA DRIVEN
APPROACH. WITH FINANCIAL
EXPERTS AT THE TABLE- WHO COME
FROM DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS AND WE
DO APPRECIATE TRULY AT CENTER
JACKSON WORKING WITH US. LAST
YEAR AND NOW THIS YEAR AGAIN
SENATE JACKSON WE'RE GONNA GO
TO FOR YOUR CLOTHES PLEASE VERY
BRIEFLY I IT I APPRECIATE THAT
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS A DATA
DRIVEN APPROACH. WITH FINANCIAL
EXPERTS DOING THE INITIAL.
DIAGNOSIS IF YOU WILL WITH
INPUT FROM INDUSTRY THAT THERE
THERE'S NO LIMIT HERE AS TO
WHAT CAN BE CONSIDERED OR
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED. IT WILL
THEN MOVE ON TO BE REVIEWED
FROM THE LANDS OF WHAT THE
PRIORITIES ARE OF THE STATE.
WILL KNOW WHETHER. I THOSE ARE
IS BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS DATA.
IN FACT. DOING BEAUTIFULLY THE
WAY THEY ARE A MAYBE WHAT WE
DID IN THE NINETEEN FORTIES IS
STILL RELEVANT TODAY BUT WE
DON'T KNOW THAT WITHOUT A BILL
LIKE THIS IN ORDER TO GIVE US
THAT INFORMATION AND WITH THAT
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH AT
MADAME SENATOR THIS IT HAS A
MOTION BY THE MAJORITY LEADER
EIGHT TO DO PASSED YOU
APPROPRIATIONS MISTER GRENADE.
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THERE ARE A SENATOR MORE. NO OR
LAW KNOWS. BILL THE BILL HI
SENATE HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT
HERTZBERG HI SENATOR D'AMATO.
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN NARROW
SENATOR WIENER ALL RIGHT SEVEN
WIENER FIVE. FOUR TWO TWO
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
THAT IS A FOUR TO VOTE A FOUR
TO VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT WE'RE
GONNA BE CLOSER ROLE CENTER
JACKSON. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
BE WELL AND HOW BIRTHDAY BY THE
WAY A LITTLE EARLY HIDING. OUR
LAYS IN GENERAL COMMITTEE WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING UP TO ITEMS TO
IDENTIFY SENATOR GLAZIER THE
FIRST ITEM WILL BE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE THE SP THIRTEEN FORTY NINE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS P. THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE WILL THEN TAKE A HIS
SECOND BILL THAT'S ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE
ITEM NUMBER HSP FOURTEEN THIRTY
ONE. GOING TO ASK YOU TO GIVE A
HEADS UP TO OUR MODERATOR. A
HEADS UP TO OUR MODERATOR THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING FOR
CONTRA COSTA SUPERVISOR JOHN
JULIA. IN THE CONCORD CITY OF
CONCORD MAYOR TâM GALLEON HERE
IN A- FEW MOMENTS TO BEGIN Q.
THEM UP FOR LOOKING FOR
SUPERVISOR JULIA IN MAYOR
MEDALLION. ON THE LOT. BUT IN
FOR MOST WE'RE GONNA BE GOING
TO SENATOR GLACIER TO PRESENT
SB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS AND- GOOD
MORNING SIR. IF YOU ARE TAKING
CARE OF A HIGHER. PAYING
MEMBERS AT THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. WITH
VOTER APPROVAL. TO RAISE COUNTY
SALES TAXES ABOUT THE 2%
THRESHOLD CURRENTLY IN PLACE.
CITIES AND COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING
THEIR CONSTIUENTS. WITH A
NUMBER OF SUPPORT SERVICES TO
ADDRESS LOCAL NEEDS THESE
INCLUDE OF COURSE POLICE AND
FIRE. HOMELESS SERVICES AND
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES. HE'S A
SEARCH IS OUR POLITICALLY
IMPORTANT DURING TIMES OF
CRISIS. I DO COVE IT NINETEEN
CITIES IN CONTRA COSTA
ESTIMATING LOSSES IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. THE COUNTY
ESTIMATES AND NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
REDUCTION IN ESTIMATED REVENUE.
AT THE NEED FOR PUBLIC SERVICE
IS LIKELY TO RISE IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THIS PANDEMIC.
THIS BILL IS A REASONABLE
MEASURE TO POTENTIALLY ADDRESS
FUNDING NEEDS IN THE COUNTY.
AND AGAIN WOULD STILL REQUIRE
VOTER APPROVAL TO ACTUALLY
INCREASE SALES TAXES IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY. THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PASSED SIMILAR MEASURES IN
RECENT YEARS FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY
CINEMA COUNTY AMONG OTHERS.
SPEAK ON THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
MEASURE I HAVE WITH ME CONTRA
COSTA SUPERVISOR JOHN JULIA AND
CONCRETE CITY MAYOR TIM A
GALLEON WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
SENATOR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE WERE NOW GOING TO ASK
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IT'S A- FORTY NINE PLEASE CALL
OUR TOLL FREE NUMBER. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE SIX
FORTY FOUR FORTY ONE THAT CODE
IS. SIX SEVEN SEVEN FIVE ZERO
SIX NINE THE PHONE LINE IS ON
YOUR SCREEN NOW PLEASE CALL IN
LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE WE
HAVE TO LEAD WITNESSES ON THIS
BILL WE'RE GOING TO FIRST GO TO
PROVIDER JOHN JULIA EN ROUTE TO
GO TO THE MAYOR OF GREAT CITY
PARKER CONCERT TâM. IN THIS
FOR BIRDIE WITH GREATER TO
MODERATOR TO WHISPER VISORED
JOY ON THE LINE. WE DO YEAH I'M
HERE ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU
SO MUCH IS ALREADY MISTER
MODERATOR GOOD MORNING MISTER
SUPERVISOR WE SO APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME KNOW HOW BUSY YOU
ARE. YOU WERE LIGHTING
COMMITTEE YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND
pSUPERVISOR. GREAT THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING TERM ACQUIRED MANY
MEMBERS- I'M SUPERVISOR JOHN
JOY YET AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
FAVORITE THE BILL. AND I WANT
TO PERSONALLY THANK BETTER
GLAZER FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT BUILT DURING
THESE CHALLENGING TIME. I KNOW
SEVERAL OF YOU WEREN'T COUNTY
GOVERNMENT AND YOU APPRECIATE
THE MAJOR PUBLIC HEALTH ROLE
COUNTY PLAY IN RESPONDING TO
THIS AND THAT. AND THE FINANCE
PRESSURE. EIGHT AND I WILL
THANK YOU ALL. YEAH AT THE
STATE LEVEL HELP IN THAT LOCAL
BE. AT THIRTEEN FOURTEEN WILL A
STATURE TO WAY OF HE CURRENT
TRANSACTION THEN YOU'DPACK IS
LEVIED WITHIN CONTRA COSTA IN
ORDER TO ALLOW THE COUNTY TO
LET THE VOTERS DECIDE WHETHER
TO RAISE ADDITIONAL REVENUE
COULD WITHOUT TAX. CURRENTLY
SIX EIGHTY THAT ARE COUNTY ARE
AT THE LOCAL BELL TAX CAP.
PRIMARILY DUE TO REGIONAL TAX
IS LIKE PART AND CONTRA COSTA
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND
THAT PREVENT US AT THE COUNTY
FROM PLACING A COUNTY MEASURE
ON THE BALLOT AND THAT'S WHY WE
ARE SPEAKING THIS WAIVER. MANY
STATES HAVE A LOT. ACCOUNT
SERVICES A STRAT CONTRA COSTA
DOES NOT CURRENTLY HAVE A LOCAL
SALES TAX REVENUE SOURCE.
CONTRA COSTA HAD RESPONSIBLY
MANAGE THE FUNDING WE DO GET TO
MEET VITAL NEED AS DEMONSTRATED
BY THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A
TRIPLE A CREDIT RATING. OVER
THE PAST YEAR WE'VE HAD A
PUBLIC PROCESS WHERE MANY LABOR
UNIONS AND COMMUNITY GROUPS
HAVE DEVELOPED A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT FOR COUNTY SERVICES.
AND RECOMMEND THAT WE PLAYED A
SALES TAX MEASURE ON THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT TO MEET THOSE
NEEDS. WE CANNOT DO THAT
WITHOUT THE PATH TO GET THIS
BILL. IF YOU'RE ALL AWARE THAT
BECOME EVEN GREATER DURING ITS
PANDEMIC AND WILL BE FACING
SUBSTANTIALLY DECREASED REVENUE
IN THE FUTURE. ESPECIALLY
LOCKED THE DOOR COUNTY HEALTH
SYSTEM OUR CLINIC OR HOSPITAL
OUR STATE BEING AT THAT TIME.
SO THE NEED FOR THIS REVENUE
MEASURE IN EVEN GREATER. THE
MEASURE THAT WE ARE HOPING TO
PLACE ON THE BALLOT THIS
NOVEMBER WOULD GENERATE MUCH
NEEDED FUNDING FOR LOCAL
SERVICES BUDGET MAINTAINING
PUBLIC SAFETY AND EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS. HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AND CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES. MEET COUNTY
OPERATIONS HAVE BEEN CRITICAL
IN OUR RESPONSE TO COPE AT
NINETEEN SO WE'RE ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE SO WE CAN LET VOTERS
DECIDE. IF THEY WANT TO ENHANCE
LOCAL READ THE YOU IN THE SAME
WAY THAT OTHER BAY AREA COUNTY
HAVE DONE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR GREAT SUPPORT AND LOOK
UP LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AS OUR
NICE WORKING AT WE TRULY
APPRECIATE YOUR LONG TIME
SERVICE NOT JUST TO THE COUNTY
BUT TO THE ENTIRE CENSUS GO BAY
AREA WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL. FOR
NOW GOING TO BE TURNING OVER TO
THE DARK IT WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH A GROUP OF
SUPERVISORS. AT THE TURN IT
OVER TO THE MAYOR OF CONCORD
WERE HONORED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
MAYOR MEDALLION THE LINE MAYOR
MCGOWAN YOUR NOW LIVE IN CAN
MAKE. YOU AT THE MINUTE IT WILL
GIVE YOU SECOND PROMPT SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE MISTER MAKER THE DOORS.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON
MCGUIRE AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE GOVERNMENT FINANCE
COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE. MY NAME IS TO
MEDALLION I'M MAYOR AND CITY OF
CONCORD. THE CITY OF CONCORD IS
THE CO SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND I WANT TO THANK
CENTER GLAZER. LEADERSHIP ON
THIS BILL AT. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA CHECKING TO SEE IF WE
STILL HAVE THE MAYOR- ON THE
LINE. IF NOT WHAT WE'LL DO IS
WE'LL GO THROUGH OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BE ON THE
LINE SUPPORT AND WE'LL GET THE
MAYOR BACK ON THE LINE I'M
GOING TO CHECK IN WITH THE
MODERATE MISTER MODERATOR. DO
WE- DO WE MAY HAVE HAD A BAD
SIGNAL FOR THE MAYOR'S FOUND
DID WE LOSE THE MAYOR. OFF ALL
RIGHT. LADIES IN GERMAN WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE GONNA
TAKE A QUICK FIVE MINUTE PAS
BURGER ALLOW SOME FOLKS TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A BY ALL BREAK AND
BE ABLE TO GET SOME COFFEE
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A QUICK FIVE
MINUTE TODD NUMBERS AND HAVE
YOU HAD HI. I'M SOME COFFEE
WILL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU.
RIGHT.
ALRIGHT LADIES IN GERMAN
GIVE US A FEW MORE MINUTES.
THIS ONE BILL WE'RE GONNA ASK
THAT ALL OF OUR WE STILL HAVE
THE MAYOR CONCORD ON THE LINE
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE MAYOR TO
BE ABLE TO HANG TIGHT WE'RE
REALLY GRATEFUL. WE'RE GONNA BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU IN ABOUT
THIRTY SECONDS IN WE'RE GOING
TO DO IS WE'RE GONNA DO A QUICK
MIKE CHECK WE'RE DO A QUICK
CHECK IN ABOUT. CAN NEVER GONNA
GET OUR HEARING STARTED AGAIN
JUST GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS
PLEASE. THIS IS RICHARD
MODERATOR IF I CAN DO SOUND
CHECK WITH YOU. ALL RIGHT GOOD
MORNING AGAIN MR MODERATOR IT
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
COMING OVER THE LINE SO LOUD
AND CLEAR CAN YOU PLEASE
CONFIRM MISTER MODERATOR. THIS
IS COMING THROUGH LOUD AND
CLEAR DO WE WANT TO TEST THE
OTHER MICROPHONES. YES PLEASE
GIVE US AT THREE JUST GIVE US A
QUICK SECOND WE'RE GONNA TEST
MIKE NUMBER TWO. ALL RIGHT THIS
IS A TEST FOR MY TO. TEST FOR
MY TO. BOB CLEAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
SENATOR GLAZERS DO A QUICK MY
CHECK PLEASE MR MODERATOR. HAS
BEEN A GLACIER PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO THIS IS A- OF A- FRONT
PODIUM IN THE HEARING ROOM. ONE
HAS A LITTLE BIT LOW VOLUME. I
THINK IT MAY BE BECAUSE OF THE
MASK MISTER MODERATOR. ALL
RIGHT HAVE IT. THAT COULD BE
AGO ALL RIGHT. THAT'S BETTER
YET THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO WHAT
I'M GOING TO DO. IS I'M GOING
TO PLACE THIS LINE BACK INTO
THE MAIN MEETING AND I'LL GIVE
YOU A KEY. THAT YOU ARE NOW
AGAIN LIVE CHAIRPERSON THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER MODERATOR
MISTER MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO BE ABLE TO PULL BACK UP
THE MAYOR OF CONCORD TEN
MEGABYTE MEDALLION PLEASE. SHE
STILL HAS A LIFE MIGHT BRING
CONFERENCE JUST GIVE ME A
MOMENT TO AFFECT THE TRANSFER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE GONNA GENERATION
YOU ARE BACK LIVE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER MODERATOR THANK YOU
SO MUCH EVERYONE WE'RE GOING TO
CHECK IN. BUT MISTER MAYOR GOOD
MORNING AGAIN. AND. VOTERS WILL
MISTER MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO
CHECK IN TO SEE IF WE HAVE TEN
MEDALLION MAYOR OF CONCORD ON
THE LINE. I AM HERE TO MAKE ON
YOUR LINE IS OPEN ALL RIGHT
WILL GOOD MORNING MISTER MAYOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THANKS FOR HANGING
WITH US. MR MAYOR YOU'RE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE MISTER MAYOR WHAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE YOU DO IS TO START
FROM THE BEGINNING THE FLOOR IS
YOUR SISTER MARY THREE. AND
AGAIN. YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
WITH US TODAY. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME AND- THANK YOU
CHAIRPERSON MCGUIRE AND MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE GOVERNMENTS THANK
YOU MAY JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME OKAY.
WE'RE COMING THROUGH LOUD AND
RESERVE YOUR SOUNDING GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT
EXACTLY GO GET MY NAME'S TIM
YOUNG AND I MAYOR OF THE CITY
OF KHAN. CONQUERED IT BONTA BUT
DESPITE. BETTER GLAZER FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL AT
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE WILL CREATE
A STATUTORY WAIVER OF THE
CURRENT TRANSACTION USE TAXES
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE COUNTY
WILL INCLUDE THE CITY CONCORD
THIS WILL PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT LOCAL. LOCAL
REVENUE. THIS MEASURE APPROVED
BY THE VOTERS WILL GENERATE
MUCH NEEDED FUNDING THAT WILL
BE USED FOR LOCAL SERVICES
INCLUDING MAINTAINING PUBLIC
SAFETY AND EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS- ARE GETTING
RICHER AND DRESS TWENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS AND LOCAL
ROADS. DE AND REPAIR NEED AND
QUALITY OF LIFE PROGRAMS FOR
FAMILY IN YEARS YOU. LOCAL
SUPPORT AND ROAD TO ECONOMIC
RECOVERY- AMONG OTHER SIR. WELL
WE NEED LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY
TO INCREASE TO INCREASE TO THE
CURRENT TRANSACTION USE TAXES%
AND SB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE WILL
CREATE THAT WAIVER SIMILAR TO
WHAT WAS LATER. DID OR ALAMEDA
COUNTY LAST YEAR. WE ARE ASKING
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE OUR
SALES TAX WE'RE- WE ASKING FOR
STATUTORY WAIVER OF THE SALES
TAX CAP SHE THAT WE CAN LET THE
VOTERS DECIDE IF THEY WANT TO
DANCE RATHER. CLOTHING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THIS MAYOR THAT WAS FANTASTIC
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY THE MAYOR IS
GOING TO BE HANGING OUT WITH US
HERE JUST FOR A BIT LONGER AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH SB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. LADIES CAN
AND CAN'T BE IT DOES RUN THE
PHONE LINES WE ARE NOW GOING TO
ASK THE MADRE TO PLEASE THANK
YOU THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
PREPARED TO PROVIDE. BONY IN
SUPPORT OF SAID OKAY. THIRTY
FOURTEEN. PLEASE PREPARE.
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
CERTAINLY FOR THOSE ON PHONE
LINES IF YOU WISH TO VOICE
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
THIS TIME IF YOU HAVE NOT
ALREADY DONE SO. WE DO HAVE A
FEW THAT ARE ORDERED UP A BOOK
BOOK START WITH LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY FOUR SEVEN FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GOOD MORNING LINE
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LIGHTING
COMMITTEE WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU TO PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR
FIRST AND LAST NAME. IS A YOUR
FIVE. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS CHRISTY BELMONT BE AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE BAMA IS AS IMPORTANT TO
TODAY SHE'S HANGING WITH US FOR
MULTIPLE BILLS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MISS BROWN MY WE'RE NOT
GOING T BE GOING TO THE NEXT
LINE IN SUPPORT MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP. YES WILL GROW OLDER LINE
SIXTY FOUR SIX FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE SIXTY FOUR GOOD
MORNING YOUR LIGHTING COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME IN ORDER. YOU'RE NOW
LIVE. THANK YOU MY NAME IS JOSH
AMADOR ANI J. ARM WITH THE
CONTRA COSTA CENTRAL LABOR
COUNCIL AND WE STAND IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY YOU MUCH
MISTER- HOW MANY FOLKS DO WE
HAVE ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT IN
THE QUEUE. IN SUPPORT IN THE
QUEUE. BUT CAN YOU PLEASE
REPEAT THAT MISTER MODERATOR.
YES WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO MORE
IN THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THAT'S GO TO THE
NEXT LINE MISTER MODERATOR. YES
THE LINE NUMBER SEVENTY NINE
SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
NINE SEVENTY NINE GOOD MORNING
YOU WERE IN COMMITTEE CAN YOU
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME IN ORGANIZATION YOU
ARE NOW LIVE. THE MORNING
REALLY READ PLACE INTERNATIONAL
UNION STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
MS ROSENBERGER WE'RE GONNA BE
GOING TO OUR NEXT LIVE LINE
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE.
YES LINE NUMBER SEVENTY TWO
SEVEN TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN THE
MORNING LINE SEVENTY TWO YOU'RE
NOW IN COMMITTEE IF YOU COULD
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME IN ORGANIZATION YOUR-
FIVE. CHAIRPERSON ECOLO DELUCA
ON BEHALF OF DANVILLE SAN RAMON
LAFAYETTE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK THE SENATOR FOR THIS
BILL. WE ALWAYS TO HEAR FROM MR
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR. MISTER
MODERATOR HOW MANY FOLKS ARE ON
THE LINE IN IN THE QUEUE. THEIR
CAR ZERO MORE IN Q. AT THIS
TIME SIR THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATOR MISTER MODERATOR
WE'RE NOW GOING TO TRANSITION
TO IN PERSON SUPPORT WE'RE
GONNA GO HERE TO ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE. WE'D LIKE TO SEE IF
IN ROOM FORTY TWO THREE LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
HEARING AND SEEING NO ONE WE
NOW WOULD NOT. GO TO OUR REMOTE
HEARING ROOM ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
IS THERE ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. HEARING AND
SEEING NO ONE HEARS IT WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO NOW.
WE'RE GONNA START WITH THE
PHONES DIDN'T. TWO FORTY THREE
AND THEN TWENTY THREE FOR THOSE
WHO MAY. NOT POSITION OF
THIRTEEN. NINE ASK ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
TO THE COMMITTEE IN OPPOSITION
TO PLEASE DIAL. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN THREE THREE SIX FOUR FOUR
FOUR ONE AND ENTER CODE SIX
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE ZERO SIX NINE
THAT. NUMBER IN CODE IS
CURRENTLY ON YOUR SCREEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE MOVING TO THOSE WHO
ARE OPPOSED FOR GOING TO BE
CHECKING IN ON OUR LIVE LINE.
LET'S CHECK IT THE MODERATE
MISTER. OKAY HE'S PREPARE ANY.
CAN SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
THEM NOW. ANY EURO WISHING TO
VOICE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
MAY DO SO AT THIS TIME BY
PRESSING ONE AND THEN ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD. THAT'S
ONE THEN ZERO. RASKIN ON YOUR
MOVE TO DAVID WOLF WITH OUR
JERVIS HEARING HEY GOOD MORNING
MISTER WOLF WE WELCOME YOU BACK
YOU ARE LIVE IN COMMITTEE AT
MISTER WOLF YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES YOU'RE GOING TO BE OUR
PRIMARY TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. MR
WALLS FLOORS YOU PURSUE A DREAM
IT'S- MISTER CHAIRMAN YEAH I
JUST STAYED ON THE MAIN LINE I
HOPE THAT'S OKAY- MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING DAVID WALKED AGAIN WITH
THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. UNFORTUNATELY
THOSE STEPS BE THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE AND UNDER GLAZER I THINK
THIS IS THE FIRST BILL OF YOURS
THAT WE NEVER OPPOSED AND- YOU
ABOUT ABOUT THAT BUT
UNFORTUNATELY- OPPOSED TO THIS
YEAR. WHEN A PRECEDENT WE USEA
STARKLY OPPOSED THESE TAX
AUTHORIZATION BILLS. DOZENS OF
TIMES OVER THE LAST DECADE OR
SO. AND UNFORTUNATELY AFTER. A
MISSED ONE AS WELL- THE SALES
TAXES ARE ESPECIALLY REGRESSIVE
AS WE ALL KNOW. YOU AND TO
DISCOURAGE. INCREASE. THEY
SHOULDN'T BAIL- SHOULD VOTERS
APPROVE THAT WOULD OF COURSE
ADD TO THAT. AND CONSIDERING
THAT 70% OF THE NATION'S
ECONOMIC OUTPUT HINGES ON
BUYING AND SELLING OF CONSUMER
GOODS. DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
CONSUMER COMMUNITIES SHOULD
CONTINUE TO REMIND PUT ECONOMIC
IMPACT- I'M ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO AUTHORIZE STILL
MORE AGGRESSIVE SALES TAX OF
THE MACHINE- SPECIALLY TRUE OF
COURSE. IN LIGHT OF THE
NINETEEN IN THE CURRENT AND AN
EQUITABLE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS YOU SHOULDN'T
DRASTIC DECLINES. SALES TAX
REVENUE- FINALLY JUST FROM A-
COMPLIANCE POINT INCREASING
TAXES ACROSS MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS. MAKE IT MORE.
FOR RETAILERS AND OTHERS TO BE
IN COMPLIANCE WITH DIFFERENT
SALES TAX THRESHOLD TO CROSS
COMMUNITIES AND IT DOES
INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. THE BRADLEY
BYRNE PERCENT TAILS STRAIGHT
FOR GOVERNMENT REMAIN. THANK
YOU FOR FIVE AND THAT'S FOR
READ BECAUSE ARE BY. ECONOMIC
CONSISTENT. THERE'S NO REASON
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE
TO EXEMPTS MUNICIPALITIES FROM
THE- ACTUAL WHICH IS WHAT THIS
BILL DOES AND WHY WE ASK FOR A
NO VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER WILL OF THE OFFICE
MR WILL FROM THE HOWARD JARVIS
SAID TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE INTO OUR
MODERATOR MISTER MODERATOR WERE
LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED TO SB THIRTY. FORTY
NINE CAN YOU PLEASE TWO EIGHT
IN ALL CALL INTO WORK ON IN
ADDITION SB THIRTY. NINE TO
MODERATE. ONCE AGAIN ON THE
PHONE LINES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSITION MAY DO SO PRESSING.
ROW AT THIS TIME. PLEASE ALLOW.
ANYBODY QUEUE UP THE FIRST AND-
PLEASE IN GENERAL COMMITTEE
WERE GONNA AND DO A QUICK HOLD
AND WAIT TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION WILL
BE TAKING GLAZERS SP FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE NEXT. ALL RIGHT
MISTER MODERATOR ANYONE IN THE
KEY TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. NOT AT
THIS TIME SIR PLEASE CONTENT
YEAH. THANK YOU SO MUCH LAYS IN
GERMAN WERE OF COMMITTEE WERE
NOW GOING TO TRANSITION TO OR
IN PERSON TESTIMONY WE'RE GOING
TO ASK IF THERE IS ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. LAST CALL.
WE'RE NOT GONNA TRANSITION TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THOSE WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. IS NO ONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WILL ALSO TAKE A
MOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR BELL DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. MISTER VICE CHAIR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZER. I AM. IDEA DECIDED LAST
YEAR TO. SUPPORT A COUPLE OF
BILLS. IN THIS VEIN- BUT BY A
VOTE OF YES BUT I DIDN'T VOTE
NO IN IT WAS A- TWO BILLS AB
SIX ONE EIGHT INMATES IN AB
SEVEN TWO THREE. ABSTAINED IN
THIS COMMITTEE HAVE STAND ON
THE FLOOR I JUST DIDN'T. GO IN
OPPOSITION. A BECAUSE I FEEL
THE PAIN OF ALL THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND THEIR FINANCIAL
STRUGGLES AND IT WAS A REAL
HONOR TO HAVE JOHN JULIA. IF
YOU'RE- Q. SAYS HE HAD A LOT OF
FUN WERE TOGETHER. ON THE X.
COMMITTEE FOR C. SECOND. IS A
REAL CONSUMMATE PROFESSIONAL. A
BOTTOM. THIS YEAR I AM I'M
GETTING A LITTLE MORE
FRUSTRATED NOW THAT WE'RE
REALLY DEALING WITH SOME
CRITICAL FINANCIAL ISSUES AGAIN
AND I SORT OF FEEL THAT CITIES
AND COUNTIES NEED TO START
REALLY ADDRESSING THE SYSTEMIC
PROBLEMS THAT REALLY ARE
CAUSING THE NEED FOR THE SALES
TAX AND OTHER TAX INCREASES AND
THAT'S THEIR PENSION PLANS AND
YOU AND I. YOUR THAT COMES. I'M
OF THE MIND NOW. THAT WE SHOULD
BE ASKING EVERYONE TO TAKE CARE
OF THAT PROBLEM FIRST FIX THE
PENSIONS EITHER GO DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION WE TRY TO DO OR
LOOK AT SHARED RISK PLAN WHICH
THE STATE OF WISCONSIN IS
ADOPTED IS DOING REAL WELL
WITH. SO WITH THAT I ARE ARE
ARE NOT GOING TO BE NICE TO
SURE- I'M GOING TO VOTE NO-
BECAUSE- BEING NICE. THE
GOVERNOR VETOED THOSE TWO BILLS.
AND I JUST KIND OF THOUGHT WHY
DID I TAKE ALL THAT POLITICAL.
PRESSURE AND ALL THAT WHY DID I
DO THAT ONLY TO HAVE THE
GOVERNOR VETO. SB SIX ONE EIGHT
AND AB SEVEN TWO THREE AND I
DON'T KNOW WHERE IT'S GOING TO
BE THIS YEAR. A CERTAIN HE'S
CREATED THE STATE WE'RE ALL
LOOKING. THANKS TO SHUTTING
DOWN THE ECONOMY FOR AS LONG AS
IT'S BEEN SHUT DOWN. BUT YOU
MAY BE DIFFERENT THIS TIME BUT
I I'M JUST GOING TO SAY HEY NOW
THERE WERE HERE WE'VE GOT TO
START FIXING THE REAL PROBLEMS
AND CONSEQUENTLY I. OPPOSED
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND MISTER
VICE CHAIR RELATE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM CAN. THIS CALL
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FOR THE MOTION IS A DO
PASSED FLOOR IN SB THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE BEFORE WE GO TO. OUR
CALL FOR INTERPERSONAL GLACIER
FOR CLOSING COMMENTS. THANK YOU
FOR THE CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
PROVIDE. TO ATTEST. THEIR
LEADERS IN THEIR LOCAL. WITH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH ONCE
AGAIN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE FLOOR THAT MOTION WAS MADE
BY SENATOR BAIL MISTER NOW CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE MCGUIRE BY. FIRE HI. THE
MORE LOOK. MORE LIKE NO SENATOR
BILL. WELL ONLINE SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR D'AMATO.
SENATOR NIELSEN SENATE NIELSEN
NO SENATOR WIENER WIENER HI.
THREE TWO TWO BUT IS IN GERMAN
NOW WE GOT A HORSE RACE AS A
THREE TWO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THAT BILL OPEN AND ALLOW THE
MAJORITY LEADER TO BE ABLE TO
ADD ON AND WHEN HE GETS BACK
FROM HIS MEETING THANK YOU SO
MUCH. PLEASE IN GERMAN WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A QUICK MOMENT TO DO
SOME HOUSEKEEPING ON SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE BUT WE'RE
GOING TO ASK- ON THE MODERATOR
JUST TO MEET UP INDIVIDUALS WHO
MAY BE ON THE LINE WE'RE GONNA
ASK THE MODERATOR TO SIR Q.
INDIVIDUALS MAY BE ON THE- WHO.
WILL BE SPEAKING AS OUR PRIME
WE- BY IN SUPPORT AS WELL AS IN
OPPOSITION WE LIKE TO GIVE A
QUICK HEADS UP. WE'RE CURRENTLY
LOOKING FOR BRAD MARSH ENDEAVOR
CARLTON BROWN. ENDEAVOR CARLTON
IN SUPPORT. AND WE'RE LOOKING
FOR- MISTER NEAL. AND MR GALE
KEY MISTER NEAL AND MISTER
GILKEY IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE HAVE FOLKS WHO ARE
IN- IN THE AUDIENCE HERE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO ITEM SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
ONE. CENTER GLAZER OR YOURS.
THANK YOU ARE CARE MCGUIRE AND
MEMBERS. THIS BILL WILL EXPAND
THE ELIGIBILITY FOR DISASTER
REASSESSMENT FOR MULTI FAMILY
PROPERTIES AFFECTED BY THE CODE
WITH NINETEEN AND THAT MAKE. BY
EXPANDING THE ELIGIBILITY. MID
YEAR PROPERTY TAX RELIEF UNTIL
A PROPERTY RECOVERS ITS VALUE.
IN RESPONSE TO THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE ENACTED STAY
AT HOME ORDERS AS WERE ALL VERY
FAMILIAR WITH. ALL THE BEEN
PROVEN EFFECTIVE FLAT IN THE
CURVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THEY
HAVE UNFORTUNATELY TO MEDI
EMPLOYEES BEING LAID OFF.
RAISING CONCERNS ABOUT THEIR
ABILITY TO FOR TENANTS TO PAY
FOR THEIR MONTHLY RENTS IN
RESPONSE GOVERNMENTS HAVE
INSTITUTED MUCH NEEDED
PROTECTIONS TO RENTERS. THIS
RELIEF HOWEVER DOES NOT EXTEND
THE MULTI FAMILY PROPERTY
OWNERS WHO ARE STILL
RESPONSIBLE FOR MORTGAGE
PAYMENT. TAXES INSURANCE MAY IN
SAN UTILITIES. MEMBERS I HAVE A
DEEP APPRECIATION FOR THE
IMPACT THIS MEASURE COULD
POTENTIALLY HAVE ON OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. BUT THE HEART OF
THIS MATTER. IS FAIRNESS. THERE
IS TO IT. TO A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP THOSE IN
DISTRESS. FISCAL IMPACT. IS NOT
A SUBSTITUTE FOR FAIR AND
BALANCED RELIEF. FISCAL IMPACT
IS NOT A SUBSTITUTE FOR FAIR
AND BALANCED RELIEF FOR THOSE
IN NEED. I WANT TO NOTE THAT TO
APPRECIATED THE WORK OF SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND SENATOR WIENER.
ON THIS LEGISLATION THEY HAVE
SUGGESTED I PREPARED TO ACCEPT
A NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS. TO THE
BILL. IF IT MOVES FORWARD TODAY
AND LET ME SPEAK SPECIFICALLY
TO THOSE AMENDMENTS IF I MAY
MISTER CHAIR. THE LIMITED VERY.
TO IN NINETEEN WITH DECLARATORY
LANGUAGE THE COVERT NINETEEN IS
UNIQUE AS A HIGHLY CONTAGIOUS
GLOBAL PANDEMIC AND THAT THE
SHALL NOT BE A PRECEDENT FOR
ANYTHING ELSE. FOR TWO WOULD
SPECIFY THAT A PROPERTY OWNER
CANNOT MAKE THIS REQUEST. IF
YOU'RE RECEIVING OTHER TAX
BENEFITS. POLITICAL THE
NINETEEN. INCLUDING THE
PROPOSED TAX CREDIT. TO THE PRO
TENNIS TAX CREDIT RELIEF
PROGRAM. NUMBER THREE GUARANTEE
THAT THE REDUCTION
AUTOMATICALLY ENDS WHEN THE
CURRENT STATE OF EMERGENCY
ENDS. AT THAT POINT THE
ASSESSMENT IMMEDIATELY REVERTS
WITHOUT ANY ACTION BY ANYONE TO
THE ORIGINAL TAX ASSESSMENT.
AND FINALLY SOMEONE CHANGES
THAT MAKES IT CLEAR THAT. HE'S
A SINCE THE POLICIES NAY-
NEGATIVELY IMPACT PROPERTY
VALUES DURING THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY ISSUED BY GOVERNOR
NEW SO ON SO THERE'S CLARITY
AND SPECIFICITY. THAT REGARD
THIS BILL AND AIMS TO STRIKE A
BALANCE BETWEEN PROVIDING MULTI
FAMILY PROPERTY OWNERS WITH
RELIEF. FROM IMMEDIATE
FINANCIAL STRESS WHICH IF LEFT
UNADDRESSED. THREATENS TO
DESTABILIZE THE HOUSING MARKET
AND REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER HIGH VOTE I HAVE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN FAVOR. CARLTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT SO
SHE- AND BRAD MARTIAN EXPERT
PROPERTY TAX ATTORNEY THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS A
TNCS TO MUCH MRS INNER GREAT
FOR WANNA MAKE IT CLEAR TO THE
YOU WERE THERE ARE NO
AMENDMENTS IN FRONT OF THIS CAN.
EIGHT THERE ARE NO. CAN BE.
THIS WOULD TAKE IN AN
ALTERNATIVE PROPER. IN THE
FUTURE. SO WE ARE NOW GOING TO
BE TURNED OVER TO DEBORAH
CARLTON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION. YEAH SHE
IS HERE LIVE WITH US WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
CURRENT AND IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
THREE MINUTES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS DIFFICULTY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT-
PROBABLY FIFTY THOUSAND RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS AND MANAGERS
WHO RATE THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
BUT TO BE TWO YEARS. SEVEN
MEMBER. PHONE TEN MINUTES OR
LESS. THOSE ARE THE OWNERS THAT
HAVE BEEN HIT THE HARDEST. BY
IS PAN MAKE. IT'S QUE QUE. AND
THEY WERE. PLACED OWNERS HAVE
NO RELIEF. ARE THERE ARE A
MORTGAGE PAYMENT. TAX PAYMENTS
UTILITIES AND THE LIKE. YOU
KNOW WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH ASSESSORS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND THOSE WHO ARE OF
FRIENDLY- AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO-
HAVE TOLD US THAT THEY BELIEVE
THAT THE SMALL OWNERS AND- THE-
OWNERS WERE PURCHASED IN.
TENURE WILL BE THOSE THAT SEE.
ARE POTENTIALLY. UNDER BILL YOU
KNOW NOT WITHSTANDING THIS
LEGISLATION THE REQUEST FOR
REASSESSMENT WILL COME.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF THESE
SMALLER OWNERS CAN'T WAIT TO
TWO OR THREE YEARS THAT IT
OFTEN TAKES- UNDER THE EXISTING
STATUTE. AS THE SENATOR-
POINTED OUT THIS WILL ALLOW FOR
REASSESSMENT SOONER RATHER THAN
RATHER THAN LATER. I'M GONNA
LEAVE THE- TWO ARE EXPERT
MISTER BRAD OF MARCH TO PROVIDE
YOU THE REMAINDER OF THE
TESTIMONY THANK YOU MUCH. CAN
WE PLEASE BEING HERE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR NOT EARN THE OVER
TO MISTER MARK. MARSH WITH IN
TORY SIR MARSHY YOU HAVE
MINUTES WE PREACH YOUR TEST
TODAY FLOORS SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THE BOARD THANK YOU. I WAS.
PROVIDED TO YOU TODAY BY THE
CALVET. SOCIAL CLEARLY STAY.
THAT ARE NOT BEING BY OR ANYONE
ELSE I OWN RENTAL PROP. I AM
SIMPLY TO TURN. PRE TAX TWENTY
YEARS I'M A PROFESSOR I AM A
TEACHER TAX IN CALIFORNIA IS
ONLY THAT I KNOW OF PROPERTY
TAX PROGRAM THAT'S THAT'S
ENTIRELY OUR CLASS BUT THE
PROPERTY TAX- ALSO THE FORMER
CHAIR OF THE STATE BAR OF
CALIFORNIA. THE FORMER CAPITAL
IN. LARKSPUR MORE LET ME START
BY ANSWERING ONE OF THE PRIMARY
HERE WHICH IS THE COST. IT'S.
QUITE WELL BUT THE LEGISLATURE
TO DO THIS. CONSTITUTION
PERMITS THE LETTER TO PROVIDE
CALL RELIEF QUOTE. TO TAXABLE
PROPERTY PHYSICALLY DAMAGED OR
DESTROYED. AND THE LEGISLATIVE
HISTORY WHICH WE'VE
EXHAUSTIVELY REVIEWED. NOT
SPECIFY ANY SPECIFIC TYPE OF
PHYSICAL DAMAGE WHAT WE HAVE
HERE TODAY THE REASON WHY I'M
STANDING HERE WITH A MASK
BEHIND A PIECEOF GLASS IS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL CONTAMINANTS
CALLED CO EIGHTEEN. THE
POSSIBILITY THAT AN
ENVIRONMENTAL BATTLE COULD BE
CONTAMINATED- IT COULD AFFECT
THE PROPERTY TAX VALUE IS WELL
ESTABLISHED- THERE'S A LINE OF
CASES- AND IT'S AN OBVIOUS
CONTEMPT LEADS TO THE LOSS IN
VALUE OF PROPERTY. LEGISLATORS
LATERS FUNCTION WITH RESPECT TO
THE CONSTITUTION IS CLEAR WELL-
IT'S THE LEGISLATURE'S PRAGUE
TO INTERPRET IT. IN ADDITION TO
THAT BUT THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
NEW TO THIS LEGISLATURE BUT
JUST A FEW YEARS AGOSENATE
BILL THIRTEEN OH FOUR AUTHORED
BY HUFF. PASSED THIS COMMITTEE
PASSED THE ENTIRE AT
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE RELIEF
FOR DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTAMINANTS. WAS IMPORTER
RANCH FOR A MATH IN LEAGUE OF
IN THERE AGAIN I DON'T THINK
ANYONE WOULD SAY THAT THOSE
HOUSES WERE NECESSARILY HIT
WITH A FLOOD OR FIRE. BUT ALL
THE SAME. COOL DAMAGE. THE
ANALYSIS REFERENCES THE CASE
SLOCUM VERSUS STATE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION BUT WE DON'T THINK
THAT THAT CASE I DON'T THINK
THAT CASES ON POINT BUT THE
CASE IS ABOUT A REGULATION
CREATED BY THE STATE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION BUT THERE WAS NO
SURE OF ANY PHYSICAL DE. YOUR
OF. BUT WE HAVE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL CONTAMINANTS
THAT'S AFFECTED OUR WHOLE WORLD
REALLY- AND THE LEGISLATURE
AGAIN HAS THE ABILITY TO MAKE
THAT INTERPRETATION. ANOTHER
LARGE ISSUE RACES HOW TO HOW TO
HOW TO ASSESSORS DETERMINE THE
VALUE HOW DO WE DETERMINE THE
VALUE. BOB AND I DON'T ACTUALLY
THINK THAT THAT IS A SERIOUS
QUESTION THAT REQUIRES A LOT OF
THOUGHT THIS BILL EASILY
ADMINISTERED USING STANDARD
APPRAISAL TECHNOLOGY- AND
TECHNIQUES. BUT THIS IS THESE
ARE ISSUES THAT THE ASSESSORS
ARE FREQUENTLY USING TODAY THEY
ALREADY KNOW HOW TO USE THE
CALAMITY PROVISION THAT'S ABOUT
FORTY FIVE YEARS. THE OTHER
PIECE OF THIS IS WHAT WE DO
ABOUT THE GOVERNMENTAL
RESTRICTION PIECE OF THERE IS
A- OF A WELL ESTABLISHED AND
WELL USE CODE- TREVIN TAX. FOR
OVER TWO POINT ONE. ALREADY
INSTRUCTS THE ASSESSORS ON HOW
TO HANDLE IT FORCIBLE
GOVERNMENT RESTRICTIONS. AND
THOSE RESTRICTIONS ARE THE TYPE
THAT ARE ADDRESSED HERE IN THIS
BILL. THE INTENT OF THIS BILL.
TEMPORARY RELIEF TO THE SEGMENT
OF THE ECONOMY THAT HAS BEEN
REQUIRED BY STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO SHOULDER THE
HEAVY BURDEN. IN FIGHTING THIS
COVERED NINE PANDEMIC I REMAIN
AT YOUR SERVICE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. SOMERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR VERY GREAT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE AND THOSE
ON THE LINE WE'RE NOW GOING TO
BE GOING TO OUR LIVE LINE OUR
TELEPHONE LINES. IN CHECK IN
WITH THE MODERATOR MISTER
MODERATE IF WE CAN PLEASE
PREPARE ANY AND ALL INDIVIDUALS
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT.
SENATE FOURTEEN MISTER. IT WAS
A THE PHONE ONE IF YOU WISH TO
VOICE SUPPORT. YOU MAY DO SO AT
THIS TIME BUT PRESS ONE AMENDED
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
THAT'S ONE. ZERO IN A FEW
MOMENTS SO THAT THE MODERATOR
CAN GET THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE ON THE
LINE. FOR THOSE WHO ARE GOING
TO BE ON THE LINE. WE'RE GOING
TO TALK TO ME TO COMMITTEE
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME AND- IS IT. I THINK
THIRTY IN NUMBER GONNA. BE
PROVIDER. MISTER MODERATOR. DO
WE HAVE. IN THE QUEUE THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN THE ONE.
WE DO HAVE ONE WILL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY TWO EIGHT TWO. THE
MORNING LINE AT T. MORNING
MISTER CHAIR. GOOD MORNING SIR
THIS MARKET PRAYER GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- WE
WANT TO THANK SENATOR GLAZER
FOR- INTRODUCING THIS MEASURE
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF A EACH. AND WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE. THIS IS
CERTAINLY A CALAMITOUS TIME AND
WORTHY OF YOUR CONSIDERED
FAVORABLE CONSIDERATION OF
SPEECH. ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRAYER. WE'RE GONNA GO
BACK TO OUR MODERATOR MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE. NOT AT
THIS TIME SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING
INTO OUR TO- ROOMS IN CHECKING
IN IN PERSON SUPPORT WE'RE
GOING TO CHECK IN ONE MORE TIME
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE WITH
ANYONE ELSE AND THIRTY TWO OR
THREE WHO WOULD BE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF. IN IN. NO ONE.
GONNA MOVED ROOM. OUR REMOTE
HEARING ROOM IT'S PACKED IN
FOLKS ARE RUNNING THE MICHAEL
WE'RE NOW GOING TO CONCLUDE
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT. THERE
YOU GO WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT
BACK IN NOW LOOK TO THOSE WHO
ARE IN OPPOSITION LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE HAVEN'T WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES IN A
POSITION TO THE BILL. FIRST
INFORMED THE SENATE FOR ANY
TESTER DOT AND GARY COLE HE'S
ALSO PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SISTERS ASSOCIATION
WILL BE JOINING US SHORTLY ALSO
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
pWE'RE GOING TO JEFF KNEE ON THE
LINE. FIRST AND FOREMOST GONNA
OVER MISSED. PRES THE
CALIFORNIA SAYS THIS. MISTER
MODERATE TO HAVE. DA GET A CALL
THE LINE. THE LINE IS OPEN GOOD
MORNING MR SAID DO MORNING
CURRENT LAW REMEMBER OF THE MAN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS
MORNING- I WANT TO SAY FIRST
AND FOREMOST SISTERS ACROSS THE
STATE. ECONOMIC AND IS FACING
BUSINESS OWNERS AND HERE CAN
BE. AND THE THAT THEY NEED HELP
NOW. SO WE UNDERSTAND SENATOR
GLAZERS DESIRE TO PROVIDE
RELIEF TO THE YOUNG TO THOSE
OWNERS HOWEVER WE BELIEVE. THE
PROPOSED CHANGES TO REVENUE AND
TAXATION CODE SECTION ONE
SEVENTY ARE IN CONFLICT WITH
ARTICLE THIRTEEN SECTION
FIFTEEN OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION WHICH AUTHORIZES
THE LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDES
AFTER LEAVING CASES. HOLDING
OUT. YEAH WE ALSO BELIEVE THE
CASE A SLOGAN BOARDED.
PUBLISHED DECEMBER NINTH TWO
THOUSAND FIVE- COURT OF APPEAL
NUMBER ONE. IS A RELEVANT AND
REJECTED THAT AS A BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION TAPPED TO RULE ONE
THIRTY NINE TO PROVIDE DISASTER
RELIEF FOR ECONOMIC LOSS.
ABSENT PHYSICAL DAMAGE. AS
BEING CONFLICT WITH THE CAP
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENT. THE
SENSORS THEY HAVE BEEN PROPERLY
IMPLEMENTING AN EXISTING
PROVISIONS OF ONE SEVENTY AS
THEY RESPONDED RAPIDLY AND
EFFICIENTLY TO PHYSICAL DAMAGE
AND DEVASTATION CAUSED BY
WILDFIRES THAT RAVAGED THE
STATE OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS. ABLE TO DO SO AS IN AS
THE PHYSICAL DAMAGE
CONTEMPLATED BY THE
CONSTITUTION AND SECTION ONE
SEVENTY IS READILY DETERMINED.
BY INSPECTION AND THE SENATE
JUST IMAGE CAN BE DIRECTLY TO
AND JUST WHEN ASSESSED VALUES.
THE RELIEF FROM POTENTIAL
ECONOMIC LOSSES THIS BILL
CONTEMPLATES. IT WOULD BE
ANYTHING BUT STRAIGHTFORWARD
GERMAN THE POTENTIAL LOSSES-
WOULD BE TIME CONSUMING TO
DETERMINE AND DISCUSSION WITH
PROPERTY OWNERS. AND IN THE
ABSENCE OF ANYTHING OF PHYSICAL
DAMAGE ASSESSORS WOULD NEED A
LOT BEING FORMED MARKET VALUE.
PROPERTY DETERMINE WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THE VALUE WOULD
BE AFFECTED AND THEN APPLY THAT
PERCENTAGE TO THE ASSESSED
VALUE THIS IS A TIME WHEN THERE
IS NO RELIABLE CURRENT MARKET
STILL INTO. CORD CHANGES IN THE
MARKET. THIS WILL BE TRIMMING
CUMBERSOME AND TIME CONSUMING
AND INEFFICIENT WAY TO PROVIDE
RELIEF TO BUSINESSES THAT NEED
ASSISTANCE NOW NOT MONTHS FROM
NOW WHEN THE ANY ALLERGIES OF
BE COMPLETED. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT FOLLOWING PASSAGE
OF PROPOSITION THIRTEEN THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA ALREADY
PROVIDED THE ABILITY FOR
ASSESSORS TO ADDRESS ECONOMIC
MARKET CHANGES AND WHICH WAS
IMPLEMENTED BY THE LEGISLATURE
IS SECTION FIFTY ONE OF THE
REVENUE TAXATION CODE. AND
ALLOW THE SEARCHERS SELECT
DECLINES IN VALUE WHERE THE
MARKET VALUE OF PROPERTY HAS
DECLINED BELOW ITS PROP
THIRTEEN BASE VALUE AS IN THE
PAST ASSESSORS ARE WELL
EQUIPPED TO PROACTIVELY ADDRESS
REAL ESTATE MARKET CHANGES FOR
THE- FIRST LADY. HAS RELIABLE.
ALL DATA. I WAS A BIT ONE
COMING MONTHS IN SUMMARY THIS
IS BELIEVES A CHANGE IS GONNA
PLAY BY ASK FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE
NOT WITH TO SHOW. LOCAL
PROPERTY IN WOULD BE A VERY
EFFICIENT MATH. OF PROVIDING
THE REAL NEEDED NOW. AND WE CAN
SIGNIFICANT. TO LOCAL PROPERTY
TAX SYSTEM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SISTERS ASSOCIATION
I US MEMBERS FOR A NOTEBOOK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT WAS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
SAYS HIS ASSOCIATION DON YOU
GET A CALL THE A SAP INSTEAD BY
COUNTY. WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
TALK WITH MISTER JEFF NEAL HE'S
OF THE CALIFORNIA'S TOSHIBA
COUNTIES HE'S GOING TO BE YEARS
CAN IN FINE. PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES TO BE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN.
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. MOST
OF THE- JEFF NEAL REPRESENTING
THE CAL STATE ASSOCIATION
ACCOUNT MISTER NEAL YOU OF
THREE MAY YOU'RE NOW IN CAN.
THANK YOU MISTER. BIRTH AS ALL
OF YOU KNOW A COUNTIES AND
OTHER LOCAL AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
DIRECTLY RESPONDING TO THE
COLBERT NINETEEN CRISIS.
THROUGH RESERVES TO DIRECTLY
TREAT THAT THE HEALTH EMERGENCY
AS WELL AS THE ECONOMIC EFFECTS
ON INDIVIDUALS AND BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
INDIRECTLY. WITH PARTNERED WITH
THE STATE WELL ABOUT PROCESS
AND THAT THE VALUABLE BECAUSE
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
IT. BILL SEEKS TO IMMEDIATELY
EXCITEMENT. ADD FUNDING FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AT THE WORST
POSSIBLE. IT WOULD REQUIRE
LOCAL AGENCIES TO ESSENTIALLY
COMPENSATE LAND LOWER AGAIN THE
FACTS OF. A GUN REGULATIONS
DESIGNED SELECT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AN ACCESS TO HEALTHY. IF
THE ARGUMENT IS THAT THE-
KOREAN REDUCES THE VALUE OF ALL
RENTAL PROPERTY. GENERALLY IN
THE BILL WOULD. LOCALLY
PROPERTY REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
PARTICULAR. ANY ECONOMIC OKAY
FROM THE RIGHT OF ALL THE
ARGUMENT IS THE IT WOULD ABOUT
OF PARTICULAR USED TEN WHO HAVE
A GRAY BUT AND THERE'S NO TO
THEM VALUE OF THE PROPERTY AND
I DON'T PROPERTY WITH. THE
DIFFERENT. AND NOT. IT WOULD
TAKE PLACE WILL GO OF WHAT THAT
THE ORDER CONTAMINANT WAS AT
PRESIDENT IN THAT BOB. SUCH
GENERALLY SPEAKING. REQUIRING
GOVERNMENT IT WHETHER CONTRACT
PAYMENT YOUR TARGETED TAX TO A
PRIVATE BUSINESSES BEGIN
EFFECTS OF GOVERNMENT
REGULATION IS WE THINK THAT
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE IT. AS I
MENTIONED IN THIS CASE THE
REGULATION PUBLIC HEALTH AND I.
EDUCATION PUBLICLY ARE WORKING
OTHER GOOD. WORSE IN ARGUE IN
THIS TO LOOK THE COMP TO COME
FROM LOCAL ARE YOU GOING TO
REGULAR QUITE WITH ME THAT
STATE. YEAH WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THINK ABOUT WHAT IS
IT CONTAINS TO ASSIST. TO DO
BUSINESS IN THE STATE WE WOULD
URGE POLICYMAKERS TO FOCUS ON
USING FEDERAL FUNDS TO DO SO
AND AVOID RESPOND LIKE THAT HE
QUICKLY THIRTY ONE. WHICH WOULD
HAVE NEGATIVE LONG TERM IMPACT
ON THE SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT
FUNDING TOWERS COUNTY SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. AND SCHOOLS AS WELL
AS BE SIGNIFICANT
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN. PUT ON
SECTORS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AT MISTER NEAL THERE'S
MISTER NEAL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
PLATES IN GERMAN WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE PHONE LINES SPEAK TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION.
ASK EACH INTO THE I WOULD LIKE
TO BE IN OPPOSITION SP FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE. TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THE MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA
ASK YOU YOUR FIRST AND LAST
NAME THE ORGANIZATION WE'RE
GONNA SAY YOUR LIGHTING
COMMITTEE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN ON CANDOR PLEASE TELL
EIGHT. SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
ZERO SIX NOT. THAT PHONE NUMBER
IN CODE IS ALSO ON YOUR SCREEN.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE MODERATOR
NOW TO BE ABLE TO. PREPARE
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SEE. IN
OPPOSITION OF FOURTEEN THIRTY
ONE. MISTER MARK CAN YOU PLEASE
PREPARE ALL THOSE IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU YOU. IN OPPOSITION OF
BILLION MAY PRESS ONE THEN IF
YOU AFTER TIME IF YOU NOT A-
THE DA TELL THAT'S ONE BAND
ZERO. WE HAVE A COUPLE THAT
ALREADY PRE QUEUED SEVERAL MORE
THAT ARE NOW KILLING SPEAK WITH
A NUMBER THIRTY FOR. IT IS OPEN
LINE THIRTY GOOD MORNING YOU
OUR CAN MEDIA GONNA HAVE
PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND LAST
NAME IN ORGANIZATION YOU ARE
NOW LIVE PLEASE PERCENT. THE
CORPORATE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TAX REFORM ASSOCIATION FOR THE
REASONS MENTIONED BY THE COUNTY
THE QUALITY OF FACTORS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WE'RE GONNA GO
BACK TO OUR MODERATOR MISTER
MODERATOR NEXT LINE PLEASE. SIX
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY THREE. THREE
AIRLINE SO BUT- GOOD MORNING
NINE EIGHTY THREE YOU ARE IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR
FIRST AND LAST NAME IN
ORGANIZATION YOU ARE NOW LIVE
PLEASE PROCEED. THE MORNING
AFTER TERM MEMBERS THERE BRIDGE
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
MR MY ORDER LET'S PROCEED WITH
OUR NEXT INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION. OUR NEXT INDIVIDUAL
IS LYING SEVENTY FIVE THAT
SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING NINE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME IN ORGANIZATION YOUR
NOW LIVE IN COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROCEED. REMEMBER THAT GRANDMA
WE HAPPILY GO CALIFORNIA THIRTY
ASKING OPPOSITIONTODAY. FOR
THE DAY AFTER THANK YEAH HIS
ATTENTION ALIGNING OUR COMMENTS
WITH WHICH EXACT HELP THE WE
CAN ALL WORK TOGETHER PINE A
YOU WAY TO SUPPORT OUR WHO ARE
IN NEED. IN THIS ROOM. MISTER
THE ADVANCE THE NEXT INDIVIDUAL
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OUR NEXT INDIVIDUAL
IN Q. IS LINE NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN TWO SEVEN ONE IS OPEN
GOOD MORNING LINE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR IN COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND LAST
NAME IN ORGANIZATION YOU ARE
NOW LIVE PLEASE FIRST. THANK
YOU LARRY STONE COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
IN STRONG OPPOSITION I WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THIS BILL IS NOT
JUST LIMITED TO MULTI FAMILY
APARTMENTS. IT WOULD PROVIDE
PROPERTY TAX REFUNDS TO
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY OWNERS
ALREADY- INTO OVERWHELMING AND
ALREADY SERIOUS FIFTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET DEFICIT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER SENSOR A TRUE LEGEND IN
THE COMMUNITY WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE.
GOING BACK TO THE MODERATOR
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
HAVE OUR NEXT INDIVIDUAL
PROCEED WITH THEIR OPPOSITION.
WELL NOW MOVES ALONG TO LINE
NUMBER THIRTY FIVE THREE FIVE
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN THE
MORNING LINE THIRTY FIVE YOU
ARE IN COMMITTEE PLEASE PROVIDE
YOUR FIRST AND LAST NAME
ORGANIZATION YOUR LIFE PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING MR SURE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
COMPANY PANEL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION. TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE OTHER OPPONENTS
AND ONLINE BUYING WITH SHE SACK
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH HE
SOME. L. MISTER MODERATOR LET'S
MOVE FOR WITH HER NECK
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF.
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE. YOUR NEXT
IN THE QUEUE IS WILL NOT EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHT- LINE IS OPEN GOOD
MORNING LINE EIGHTY EIGHT WE
HEAR THE DOGS IN THE
BACKGROUND. WE'RE GONNA HAVE
YOU PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND LAST
NAME ALONG WITH YOUR
ORGANIZATION YOUR LIFE PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS GERRY BRADLEY ON THE DEPUTY
COUNTY COUNSEL WITH THE COUNTY
OF KERN. I WILL TO OUT THAT
THIS BILL STATE THAT IT IS NOT
A CREE. A STATE MANDATE. WHICH
WOULD MAKE IT. TO REIMBURSE THE
COUNTY. I DISAGREE WITH THAT
CONCLUSION BECAUSE THE ONLY
CRIME MENTIONED IN THE STATUTE
ALREADY EXISTS IN THE EXISTING
LANGUAGE OF THE STATUTE. SO THE
BILL WOULD NOT QUALIFY UNDER
THE DEFINITION. BUT FOR SECTION
TWO BE EFFECTIVE FOR THE COUNTY
OF KERN IS STRONGLY I
OPPOSITION THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISS BRADLEE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME AND THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US I'M GONNA DO A CHECK IN WITH
THE MODERATOR MISTER MODERATOR
HOW MANY FOLKS WE HAVE IN THE
QUEUE. I CURRENTLY HAVE TWO OR
IN THE QUEUE SIR ALRIGHT LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER MISTER
MODERATOR. OUR NEXT CALLER IS
FROM LINE EIGHTY NINE THAT IS
EIGHT NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THE MORNING LINE EIGHTY NINE
YOUR IN CAN MORNING PLEASE
PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND LAST
NAME ORGANIZATION YOUR LIFE
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD EVENING
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. AUDIBLE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
GOVERNMENT CAN FINANCE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS ROBERT
NOT COMBINE AND I'M A DEPUTY
COUNTY COUNSEL FOR THE COUNTY
OF SANTA CLARA. REPRESENTED OUR
COUNTY ASSESSORS AND- SIX. I
OPPOSE SB FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE
BE IT IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL. THE
LOST ARTS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION THE LEAD. POWER TO
TAX PROPERTY IN CALIFORNIA IS
CONSTITUTIONALLY. FOR CALAMITY.
TO BE SURE WE THE COLD CAN L.
YOU CONSIDER THIS BILL TO KEEP
THE LANGUAGE OF ARTICLE
THIRTEEN SECTION FIFTEEN IN
FRONT OF YOU. IN ITS MAY SIXTH
TWENTY TWENTY LEGISLATIVE BILL
ANALYSIS THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION STAFF CAME TO THE
SAME CONCLUSION ON PAGE FOUR I
QUOTE IT THIS BILL EXTENT
DISASTER RELIEF TO PROPER NO
PHYSICAL DAMAGE CARMEN IS ON
CONSTITUTIONAL. WE WANT TO BUT
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT SECTION
SEVEN IS NOT LIMITED TO MORE
FAMILY RESIDENTIAL BUILDING.
THAT SUFFERED LAND LOSS DUE TO
A COLBERT NINETEEN THERE FOR
EVERY COMMERCIAL AND RETAIL
TAXPAYER WALL FOR THIS SHAPE
REDUCTION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
GRATEFUL WE WANT TO REMIND ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ON THE LINE
ALL CALLERS THAT WE'VE- TWO
PRIMARY. SOME IN SUPPORT
OPPOSITE. TO WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO ADD OUR FOR ENDED WERE. ON
ALL TO PLEASE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME YOUR- IN YOUR- ON THE
BILL WE TRULY APPRECIATE AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR WITH US
TODAY. GO BACK TO THE LIVE FIND
MISTER MARKETER- OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. OUR NEXT CALLER
IS FROM NINETY NINE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN LINE NINETY GOOD
MORNING YOUR IN COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE NOW LIVE PLEASE PROCEED.
MAIN MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THIS IS JEAN HEARST- CALLING IN
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE. MUCH RESEARCH IT'S
GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE WE
APPRECIATE IT MISTER MODERATOR
HOW MANY FOLKS WE HAVE IN THE
QUEUE. YOU HAVE. TO THE QUEUE
IF THIS TIME SIR PLEASE
CONTINUE. I THANK YOU SO MUCH
LAZY GERMAN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
TURNING TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSE IF YOU ARE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR- IN YOUR POSITION CAN
YOU PLEASE PROCEED TO THE
MICROPHONE. SEE NO ONE WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. IF YOU'RE AN
OPPOSITION ROOM TWENTY FORTY
PLEASE PROCEED TO THE
MICROPHONE. HEARING SEEN NO
INDIVIDUAL TO COMMENT WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BETTER BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. THAT THE
BILL TO OPEN UP SOONER TITLE IN
INTO WIENER AND THEN MISTER
VICE CHAIR CENTER TITLE GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR JUST WANTED TO.
EXPRESS THAT I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS AT WITH YOUR BILL I
CAN KEEP YOU MEAN WELL- BUT IT
YOU KNOW. AS YOU'VE HEARD TODAY
THERE'S SOME- PEOPLE FOR MY
DISTRICT ARE ARE- ORGANIZATIONS
ARE JUST- ALSO CONCERNED AS
WELL SO I JUST WANT TO EXPRESS
THAT CONCERN BUT- WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOU TODAY AND
HELPING YOU MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD. GOLDEN SO MUCH MADAM
AT SENATOR WERE NOW GOING TO BE
GOING TO SENATOR WIENER PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AS A FIVE THE AUTHOR
INDICATED AT THE BEGINNING- HE
HAS BEEN WORKING WITH ME AND
ALSO CENTER HERTZBERG- TO
ADDRESS OUR CONSUMER CONCERNS
ABOUT THE- REALLY THE BREATH OF
THIS BILL. UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE IS A REAL ISSUE HERE-
AND- BUT YOU KNOW I'M MY
INITIAL. TAKE ON THE BILL AND I
THINK I WANNA SPEAKERS CENTER
HERTZBERG BUT I THINK YOU MAY
HAVE HAD THE SAME REACTION
THAT. TO FIGHTING COULD HAVE
SOME. CONCERT AND SO WE WERE TO
A WITH THE AUTHOR AND PROPOSED
A SERIES OF NOT AMENDMENTS TO
TAKEN BY THE MAMMON SO WORK ON
AFTER COMMITTEE IF THE BILL
GETS OUT- TO SIGNIFICANTLY
NARROW AND FOCUS THE BUILT ON
SENATOR GLAZER DID- BRIEFLY GO
OVER THEM I DO JUST WANT TO
MENTION WHAT THEY ARE. ONE IS
BEING THIS BILL IS SPECIFIC TO
COPE WITH THE THOUGHT OCCURRED
BUT AS AN EXAMPLE THIS IS A
PURE. 101% COVERT ONLY BILL AND
THERE WILL BE THAN LANGUAGE
INCLUDED IN THE BILL-
EXPLICITLY SAYING THAT THIS IS
NOT INTENDED BY THE LEGISLATURE
AS PRESIDENT FOR ANYTHING ELSE
TO SAY WE- HOPEFULLY ONCE IN A
CENTURY IT'S BEEN HUNDRED TWO
YEARS SINCE THIS HAPPENED.
WE'LL BE ANOTHER HUNDRED TWO
YEARS OR MORE BEFORE IT HAPPENS
AGAIN BUT THIS IS A UNIQUE
DISASTER AFFECTING- THINGS SO
BROADLY. FRIENDLY THAN- YOU
KNOW PROJECT WHILE FIRE THIS IS
JUST BECAUSE BROAD AND DEEP AND
SOCIETIES ABOUT WILL GO AND-
CUT NOT NEXT- MENTIONS. TAKING
A OF OTHER TÁI SPENT. I'M IN.
IF IT ENDS UP NEAR PASS WHAT
THE PRO IN THAT SOME HERTZ
INCENTIVE ARE PROPOSING.
WOODLAND TAX CREDITS CAN'T TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS. SO NO DOUBLE
DIPPING- IN ADDITION THIS IS A
REAL CONCERN FOR ME WHAT I
DON'T WANT IS YOU HAVE A
REDUCTION. AND THIS ENDS IN
ANOTHER FIGHT BETWEEN THE
PROPERTY ON IN THE ASSESSORS.
WHETHER TO REFER TO THE PRE
EXISTING- ASSESSMENT VALUE. AND
SO THEY'LL BE AN AMENDMENT THAT
SAID. THAT SAYS ONE THE STATE
EMERGENCY. DIET REASSESSMENT
AUTOMATICALLY BY CREATION OF
LAW NO ACTION BY ANYONE THIS IS
A FALSE. THE AUTOMATICALLY
RIVER. THE PRIOR TAXES SO WE
WON'T PUTTING UP ON THE
ASSESSOR TO PICK A FIGHT TO GET
THE RIVER AND ALL HAVE BY UPPER
OF LAW IN ADDITION- THERE'LL
REMOVES SPECIFIC REFERENCE TO
THE LANDLORD TENANT ISSUE WE
DON'T WANT TO THIS IS NOT- WE
DON'T WANT TO BE THE FOCUS OF
THIS- AND THE POTENTIALLY SET
PRECEDENTS. AND SO IT'LL BE
MORE JUST ALL ABOUT. INSOFAR ON
UNTIL PROPERTY RESPONSE TO
COVER NINETEEN AND WE HAVE SOME
LANGUAGE WE WORKING ON WITH THE
AUTHOR. IN ADDITION I BELIEVE
THE AMENDMENT WILL MAKE CLEAR
AND I UNDERSTAND THIS TO BE THE
INTENT OF THE AUTHOR. THAT
THIS. BILL WILL ONLY APPLY TO
RESIDENTIAL THAT IT WILL NOT
APPLY TO COMMERCIAL I'M
INCIDENTS- A COMMENT THAT THE
SERVER FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AND THIRD DEPUTY COUNTY CAL
STATE ABOUT COMMERCIAL I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT TO BE THE TIME.
I BELIEVE THE TO WORKING ON
DAUGHTER WILL MAKE CHRIS CLEAR
THAT THE IS LIMITED TO A- AND
SO THE ARE. THE MOMENTS WE
WORKED OUT THAT I THINK
DRAMATICALLY NARROW IN FOCUS-
THIS BILL- I WOULD STRUGGLE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL IN THE CURRENT
FORM. WITH THESE AMENDMENTS-
I'M HAPPY TO- SUPPORT IT- AND I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER WIENER
AND GO TO SENATOR GLAZER THAN
TO THE VICE CHAIR AND THEN
CENTER NIELSEN- INCIDENT. ANY
EVEN HAVE. I WOULD LIKE TO
CONFIRM THE TESTIMONY THE
CENTER FROM SAN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOU'RE VERY GRATEFUL LET'S
GO TO THE VICE CHAIR ADVICE
MORE LAW. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. I GUESS I WOULD START BY
SAYING THAT I'M A FORMER COUNTY
SUPERVISOR WAS FORMER CHAIR OF
THE URBAN COUNTY CAUCUS AND
ALSO ON THE. BORDER FIFTH ACT.
SO I SORT OF COME FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE A LITTLE BIT HERE
SO I'M WATCHING CURRENT EVENTS
AND I WATCHED SACRAMENTO FORCE
A LOCKDOWN. CREATOR ECONOMIC
DEPRESSION IMPACT SO MANY
PEOPLE. NICE COUNTY IS THAT
RELY ON PROPERTY TAXES WE WENT
THROUGH PLENTY OF BATTLES.
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO WITH TRIPLE
FLIP AND ALL KINDS OF FUN STUFF
WHEN ARNOLD. WAS GOVERNOR. AND
SO NOW WITH THE COUNTY RELIES
ALMOST ENTIRELY ON. PROPERTY
TAX REVENUES 92% FOR THE COUNTY
OF ORANGE. AND NOW.
SACRAMENTO'S DOING A BILL THAT
ONCE OUNTIES TO SUBSIDIZE THE
ECONOMIC LOSSES THAT THE STATE
CREATED. AND I'M HAVING A.
HONEST PULL THAT INVESTED IN
REAL NEVER RON AND HOW TO
IMPORT PEOPLE I EIGHT I GET GET
IT BUT I JUST SEE THAT THIS THE
ANSWER THERE'S GOT TO BE A
BETTER AND SO I MISTER MARSHALL.
FORTY OH THREE FOURTEEN A PORCH
MEET OUR NOT IN MY NOTES SO I
LOOKED AT A- AND I DID NOT TO
BY HOW FOR PORTER. IT'S
CERTAINLY DID REAL WELL IN THE
LEAD. BUT IT WAS THE- SO WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW IF IT WAS.
GOING TO BE ABLE TO HELD UP YOU
KNOW OF COST IN THE COURTS IT
WAS NEVER TESTED BUT CERTAINLY
HAS. AS A SOME OF PRESS BUT-
THIRTEEN A POOR DID NOT HAVE A
MID YEAR REAL. PROVISION BUT I
DIDN'T IT IF IT I MISS. A BARE
SPOT IS PLACES GRAY G.
COMFORTABLE WITH YOUR WITNESS.
MARCIA MATURE ENOUGH THANK YOU
VERY. PLEASE SIR PERCY. THAT
WAS ALSO AT RELIEF BILL OF THE
SAME TYPE THIS THESE ARE ALL
THE SECTION ONCE A IS TOP
RELIEF AND SOON AS THE MARKET
VALUE GOES GOES UP AND AS I
HEARD THESE MEN TODAY THAT
WOULD ONCE ORDER ARE THEN THEY
WOULD BACK TO THE STANDARD
PARTY TAX BASE YOUR- IT OR- IT
MAY BE A- THANK. INTERVIEW BUT
NOT OUT. I CUT MY INTEREST IN
ONE OF THE LEAST CHECK IN IT SO
BUT WE MOVED REALLY IT BEFORE
IT OFFICIALLY THAT GET THROUGH
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK YEAH THE
LEGISLATURE IT BY THE BUT THE
GOVERNOR TO DETERMINE. I
CERTAINLY RESPECT- APARTMENT
OWNERS. AND TODAY RETURN MY
PRACTICE DAYS HAD PLENTY OF
THEM AS CLIENTS- BUT I'M I'M
HAVING REAL DIFFICULTY WITH
THIS APPROACH WE'VE GOT TO FIND
SOMETHING THAT- IS A LITTLE
MORE FAIR TO THE- IT I GUESS-
WOULD DRIVE WITH IT. COMPARED
TO SAY THE TAMPON TAX WHERE WE
DO A BILL WORDS KINDA NICE THAT
WE REDUCE THE SALES TAX BUT THE
STATE DIDN'T. LOSE ANY MONEY.
IT WAS THE LOCALS THAT LOST THE
MONEY AND I JUST FIND IT.
INAPPROPRIATE FOR SACRAMENTO.
LOWERED TAX REVENUES TO LOCAL
AGENCIES BECAUSE OF THE TOPIC
OF THE DAY. AND FOR THAT.
REASON FOR THAT RANT I- WILL BE
OPPOSED TO YOUR BILL. THANK YOU
SENATE BUDGET THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
VICE CHAIR WE'RE GONNA GO TO
SENATOR NEEDS IN THE MORNING.
THE FOLLOWING. YOU KNOW I WAS.
YEAH IN MY HISTORY THE
RELUCTANT OR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS. BUT I THE LONG TIME. THAT
COUNTY I THINK. THIS IS OF ALL
GOV LEADING AGENCIES AND
ENTITIES THAT WE DEAL WITH. AND
SO THAT IS MY REAL. BUT ON THE
OTHER HAND I. THE OWNERS OR
FACE REFLECTIONS NOW AS WELL.
IN THE SERVICE. WE LANGUAGE
THAT THE AND WE DON'T KNOW THE
LAW JEFF BUT AUTHOR HAS
COMPLETE ABSOLUTELY FOR. WELL
I'M SURE THE THEY- HAVE WILL BE
MORE. IN THAT I FIND FIRST THAT
IS THE DOESN'T WE WILL NOT BE
THAT AFFECTS THE COUNTIES
RATHER. AND I CAN HAVE HOPE.
THAT THAT WILL THE CASE OF MY
TRUST. IN THE OFFICE. AGAIN
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT I THINK
SENSE MEANS HAVING SAY. AND THE
CALIFORNIANS DID NOT INVITE
THIS. THE LADIES BUT MALADY
DISASTER THAT HAS COME TO VISIT
US. WE HAVE THE OPTION TO GO
WITH IT. IN DIFFERENT GOING TO
THIS IS AN AREA WHERE I CAN SEE
MARYLAND VALUE. ASSESSORS BUT
SOMETIMES HAVE IN THE PAST
RECESSED SOMETIMES THEY HAVE
THERE BEEN ORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES THIS ONE IS
PROBABLY THE MOST EXTRAORDINARY
OF MY LIFETIME. AND I EXPECT.
AND THAT THEREFORE DISPOSES ME
TO SEE THIS KIND OF RELIEF AND
THE FACT IT DOES RELATE TO THE
HOUSING CRISIS. BEST VENTURE
CAPITAL OF OR INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE SOME RESOURCES AVAILABLE
HISTORICALLY. HAVE INVESTING.
AND THAT. NOT SO LIMóN ON.
THANK YOU IT'LL HAPPEN DOWN THE
WAY BUT AS- HAMMOND WHAT THEY I
WILL BE A YES WELL I THINK SO
MUCH CENTER NIELSEN WE
ACTIVATED TO ALASKA FOR COM ARE
QUITE LAW CALL COMMITTEE COMMON
ARE. AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHTS
IN A CITY YOU REMARKS TO BE I
IS THERE A MOTION TO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY THE MAJORITY LEADER
THIS IS A DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS A I. WAS ABLE TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION AND- VERY
VERY GRATEFUL TO SENATOR
GLACIER UP FOR HIS WORK ON SO
MANY ISSUES AND OUR OUR
CONVERSATION WAS THAT I HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL I
THINK. IT IS AN INTER
CONSTITUTIONAL CHALLENGES I DO
BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO
ULTIMATELY BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
AND ARE. REALLY CHALLENGING FOR
LOCALS AT TO BE ABLE TO
COMPREHEND AND IMPLEMENT THAT
SAID UNDER. THAT THERE ARE
POLICE AS THE I AM IT TO
SUPPORT THE CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE AND WHAT. THE HERE
COMEDIAN. BRING VIEWS ON THIS
BILL AND I ENCOURAGE ALL TO
VOTE ON VETO ON THIS BILL.
THERE WERE CHAIR ACTION MAY BE.
TO FOR POST CON. AT THE THANK
YOU MCGUIRE THANK YOU TO
SENATOR WINNER IN CENTER FOR
YOUR WORK ON THE BILL. YOU KNOW
IT'S KIND OF IRONIC FOR ME TO
COME IN AND ALLOWED THE BILL WE
HEARD PREVIOUSLY IN THIS BILL
BECAUSE AS PEOPLE NOW ON. I AM
TAX DIVERSE AND THEN LOOK AT
THE LIFE PRESENTED A MOMENT AGO
AND PEOPLE KNOW THAT I'M A
STRONG LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ADVOCATE COMING FROM THAT
SPACE. THE BILL THAT. T. WOULD
NOT OFFICE. OUR BUT I THINK
THAT THE THERE'S GO GOING TO BE
A SCHOOL BUT THE STATE AND THE
LOCALS AND I KNOW THAT THOSE
ONGOING THINGS BUT HERE'S THE
THING THE MEMBERS. THAT SHOULD
BE ABOUT FAIRNESS REALLY AT THE
END OF THE DAY IS NOW WE ONCE
NO MATTER WHERE THE FINGER
POINTS. WHERE THE BLAME IS LAID.
WE DIDN'T BECAUSE THE PANDEMIC.
BUT WE ALL KNOW THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE EXTRAORDINARY
AT EVERY LEVEL AND WE'RE TRYING
TO FIND OUR BEST PASSED THROUGH
THAT. AND WE KNOW HOW HARD AND
HOW HURT OUR TENANT COMMUNITY
HAD BEEN SO YOU COULD SAY THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. STATE PLEASE
RENTS TO THE DATE THE DATE.
PREVENT FORECLOSURES YOU CAN
SEE IS THE WRONG THING BUT WITH
THE BUT IT HAS HAPPENED. AND
THE QUESTION IS IT IS IT WE
TALK ABOUT OUR VALUES AS A
STATEWE KNOW THAT HOUSING IS
ONE OF OUR BIGGEST CRISIS
BEFORE THE PAN IT WILL BE AFTER
THE- DO ONE. FOR THOSE WHO WANT
TO. HOUSE THE CAPTAIN IS THAT
WE'RE GOING BE FAIR. TO BE FAIR
ABOUT HOW WE- DO OUR OUR WORK
GOING FORWARD AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT NARROWLY
CRAFTED MULTI FAMILY NARROW
COVERT NINETEEN NARROWED.
SOMETHING THAT NONE OF US COULD
EVER IMAGINE. QUESTIONS ABOUT
PHYSICAL DAMAGE AND WHETHER
IT'S CONSTITUTIONAL DOES
ANYBODY DOUBT THE DAMAGE TO.
OUR STATE AT SO MANY LEVELS
INCLUDING A RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY HUNDREDS ANYONE DOUBT
THE DAMAGE SO THOSE THINGS WILL
GET. DEBATED AND FOUGHT OVER
PERHAPS IN THE COURT OF THIS
BILL MOVES AHEAD. IT IS ABOUT
HAVING A BALANCED RESPONSE.
FOCUSED ON FAIRNESS BUT I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL FIVE.
INCLUDES AS IT'S POSSIBLE FOR
PURPOSE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT OF
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
GLACIER APPRECIATE THAT AND A
GROUP OF YOUR TIME IN COMMITTEE
TODAY. AGAIN THE- IN BY SENATOR
HURTS IS TO PASS YOUR- CHINS.
MR NOW PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
BETTER MCGUIRE NO WHO ARE NOW
FOUR O'CLOCK MOORLACH KNOWS
SENATOR WELL. NO CENTER
HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG AYE
SENATOR TACO AYE RICARDO CINDER
NIELSEN. NIELSEN ARI SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER HI ALRIGHT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT DISCUSSION IN
THAT PARTY DEBATE THAT IS A
FOUR THREE VOTE THE BILL IS OUT
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLE
SENATE LEISURE THANK YOU SO
MUCH INTO THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITE WERE FOR TO
NINETY. SIX SIX HEALTHY WAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE
ON TO OUR IN DAY WELL THIS BILL
BY SENATOR OF. GIVE US A WOMAN
HERE USE QUICK KEEPING. IN A
CAREER IS GONNA BE RICH ON
SENATE BILL FOR OH NINE. WE
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE TERRY
OVERLY WHO IS THE ECONOMIC
SECURITY PROJECT ACTION SHE'S
GOING TO BE THE LEAD- WITNESS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL MISS
HOLLY WILL BE A TEST IN BY
PHONE SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK OUR
MODERATOR. GOODS THERE IS BE
TEST NASCAR MODERATOR TO BRING
TERRY AWFULLY IN ECONOMIC
PROJECT WILL BE OUR LEAD
WITNESS IN SUPPORT TESTIFYING
TO SIGN OUT FOR. THIS CALL
FLORA YOURS GOOD AFTER GOOD YES
I THINK IT'S THE MORNING
MORNING TO MEMBERS- THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRINT SB
FORTY NINE WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
THE FOR TECH BY THIS HE IS A
PLAN TO IN. A NEW TAX RETURN
FILING BUYER. I WOULD PROGRAM
WITH A OF BEING CLAIMS FOR THE
EARN INCOME CREDIT OR CAL YEAH.
THE I. T. C. IS ONE SIX FULL.
POVERTY IN OUR- THE REDUCE.
ELDRIN WHO'S BEEN POVERTY TO
CLAIM THE CAL E. I. T. C. AN
INDIVIDUAL MUST FILE A TAX
RETURN MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST ECONOMICALLY FRAGILE
HOUSEHOLDS DO NOT FILE A TAX
RETURN BECAUSE EARNED LITTLE DO
NOT RECEIVE THE CAL THE ATC
BECAUSE THEY ARE UNAWARE THAT
THEY QUALIFY FOR THE CREDIT.
SINCE THE BY THE CAP POLICY LAB
CONCLUDED OUT REACH ALONE IS
INSUFFICIENT TO INCREASE CLAIM
TO THE CAL E. I. T. C. AMONG
NON FILERS. AND QUITE FRANKLY
WE'VE SPENT TEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE PAST TWO BUDGET CYCLES
TO GET THE WORD OUT IN THIS
YEAR THE THAT NEW BUDGET
RECOMMENDS FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
SO WITHIN THAT IF IT BACK I WAS
THROUGH ITS SIX SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF MONEY. TO TRY TO GET
PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY BE FILING A
CLAIM THE CREDIT WHEN THEY
DON'T. SB FORTINO NINE GET US
CLOSER BY DELIVERING ON THE
PROMISE. OF HELPING FAMILIES TO
MAKE ENDS MEET AND OF COURSE
GIVEN THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. PRESIDENT EIGHT
FINANCIAL CRISIS FAMILIES
STRUGGLING MORE THAN EVER. ON A
NO RETURN TAX FUNDING MEANS AN
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUAL NOT WILL
NOT HAVE TO FILE A TAX RETURN
TO. TO RECEIVE THE CREDIT
INSTEAD THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
WOULD BE ABLE TO USE THE
INFORMATION ALREADY IN THE
STATE'S DATABASE DESCEND THE
CREDIT TO THOSE FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS THAT QUALIFY AS A
FOOTNOTE THIS IS THE CASE THE
I. T. C. IS REALLY STE. AFTER
THE FEDERAL CAL- YET BUT YET-
FEDERAL EITC PROGRAM. WHICH HAS
BEEN IN PLACE SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AND QUITE FRANKLY
THE LONG TERM- RESEARCH THAT'S
BEEN DONE ON THIS IS THAT THE
FAMILIES RECEIVE. THE FEDERAL
EITC SHOW THAT THEIR CHILDREN
DO BETTER. ECONOMICALLY DOWN
THE ROAD WHICH HELPS US TO-
REDUCE THE CYCLE OF POVERTY AND
TO GET PEOPLE INTO HIGHER
PAYING JOBS A REAL SMALL THING
REALLY IMPORTANT. IS IN THESE
TOUGH ECONOMIC TIMES HARD HARD
WORKING FAMILIES NEED ECONOMIC
SUPPORT AS EFFICIENTLY AND
RAPIDLY AS POSSIBLE THIS IS A
GOOD GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT
EFFICIENCY BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I VOTE
AND AS YOU. INDICATED MISTER
CHAIR- TERRIBLE IS NOT- IS ON
THE PHONE IN A CAREER NICE JOB
WITH THE BILL VERY GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS SO WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THREE PHASES A
TESTIMONY WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH. LOW ITEM TOP. NUMBER
GONNA LOOK. MONIQUE. THREE
REMOTE ROOM TWENTY FORTY IF YOU
TO TESTIFY IN SO OF THE BILL
PLEASE DIAL 887-336-4441 ENTER
CODE. SIX SEVEN SEVEN FIVE ZERO
SIX NINE THAT TOLL FREE NUMBER
IS ON YOUR SCREEN NOW PLEASE
DIAL IN WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
GOING TO OUR LIVE LINES WE'RE
GOING TO CHECK IN WITH THE
MODERATOR TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE TERRY OLEY EITHER WHICH IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN OH NINE
ON THE LINE MISTER MODERATOR
GOOD MORNING AGAIN. THANK YOU
TERRY EARLY MINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN CHOIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS TERRY
ONLY WITH ECONOMIC SECURITY
PROJECT ACTION AS A CO SPONSOR
OF THE BILL AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF OUR FELLOW CO SPONSOR AND
CHILD POVERTY CALIFORNIA GREAT
THANK BUT I THINK SENATOR
CAFIERO FOR INTRODUCING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL TODAY. CAPTION
JUST TWO POINTS BRIEFLY FIRST
WHY THIS BILL AND SECOND WHY
NOW. FIRST SB FORTINO NINE
WOULD BE SMART PUBLIC POLICY
AND A GOOD GOVERNMENT PROPOSAL
IN ANY LEGISLATIVE SESSION. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS RECOGNIZED HOW
IMPACTFUL EITC IS AS A HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE ANTI POVERTY TOOL BY
INVESTING IN IT EVERY YEAR
SINCE IT WAS CREATED IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY FIFTEEN.
AND ESPECIALLY MOST
DRAMATICALLY LAST YEAR WHEN IT
WAS EXPANDED TO GO FARTHER UP
THE INCOME SCALE AND ALSO BY
CREATING THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT IT TARGETS HOUSEHOLDS
WITH YOUNG CHILDREN TO BE IN
THE BEST. POVERTY IN OUR STATE.
THIS BILL WOULD ACTUALLY IT
MIGHT BE THE BEST BY MAKING
SURE THAT THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN DESIGNED TO HELP ARE
ACTUALLY GETTING CREDIT. FOR
HEARING OUT HOW TO AUTOMATE
MODERNIZE STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS IN ORDER TO INCREASE
ACCESS. IS A SMART INVESTMENT
TO WILL MAKE SURE THAT THE
PROGRAM IS AS SUCCESSFUL AS I
KNOW WE ALL WANT TO BE. CHECK
IT WHY NOW. I'D SAY THAT
EVERYTHING I JUST SAID TIMES A
THOUSAND. YEAH HE'S HE IS ABOUT
BOOSTING THE LOWER EARNINGS AND
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT IT WAS
DESIGNED TO DO. IS PUT CASH
INTO PEOPLE'S POCKETS. SUPPORT
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND TO GENERATE ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
IT TRULY IS OFTEN MADE THE
SITUATION WE'RE IN AN ACTUAL
SITUATION WE'RE GOING TO BE IN
FOR SOME TIME. IT WILL JUST
TAKE A SECOND ENGAGE IN A HOT
EXPERIMENT IN A MATCH. WHAT
THINGS WOULD BE LIKE RIGHT NOW
IF WE ACTUALLY HAD AUTOMATIC
FILING IN PLACE RIGHT THIS
MINUTE. IF WE DID WE CAN REST
ASSURED THAT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WOULD BE RECEIVING
POTENTIALLY THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS EACH YEAR. TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES
IN A CHALLENGING ECONOMY. VERY
OCCASIONALLY TO. BUT JUST
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE IT NOW
DOESN'T MEAN WE SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD WITH IT WE'RE NOT OUT
OF TIME. IN THE COMING YEARS
WE'RE GOING TO NEED EVERY TOOL
WE HAVE TO SUPPORT THOSE HIT
HARDEST BY THE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN. AND SO IT'S MORE
CRITICAL THAN EVER GET THE
CREDITS ARE GOING TO EVERYONE
WHO'S ELIGIBLE. FINALLY I WANT
TO ADDRESS THE CONNECTION WITH
THE FEDERAL CREDIT WHICH WAS
REYES ANALYSIS. WELL THIS IS
THE BILL AND SO DOES NOT
PRESUPPOSE AN OUTCOME I DO HOPE
THAT WE CAN THINK CREATIVELY
INEXPENSIVELY HERE ABOUT
CONNECTING ACROSS SYSTEMS AND
PROGRAMS FOR EFFECTIVENESS AND
EFFICIENCY. AND MANY OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
THOUGHT ABOUT THIS IN OTHER
AREAS OF SUPPORT AS WELL.
PEOPLE IN HARD TIMES YOU WERE
BARRIERS TO GETTING HELP AND
THIS CRISIS PRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TRULY BE THINK
HOW WE DO THINGS. ESPECIALLY
GIVEN HOW MANY PEOPLE WILL BE
IN NEED AND SEEKING FINANCIAL
HELP IN THE COMING YEARS. BOTH
PEOPLE AND OUR STATE PROGRAMS
WOULD REALLY STAND TO BENEFIT
GREATLY PEOPLE CAN TELL THEIR
STORY ONCE AND RECEIVE ALL OF
THE SUPPORT THEY NEED AND FOR
WHICH THEY ARE ELIGIBLE. WITH
THAT I WOULD URGE YOUR IPHONE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
TOTALLY NICE JOB THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT
YOU WERE WITH US ON OUR LIVE
LINE TO THE. THANK YOU SOME.
WE'RE GONNA BE GOING TO THE
BOTTOM. MISS DO IN ANY OTHER IN
THE- WHO ON THE LINE WE- TO
SPEAK IN SO. OF SB. NINE AS A
REMINDER YOU CAN KILL OPEN
SUPPORT IF YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY
DONE SO BY PRESSING ONE ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD WE DO
HAVE SOME THAT ARE ALREADY CUED
UP. WE WILL BEGIN WITH LINE
NUMBER SIXTY FIVE SIX FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THE MORNING LINE
SIXTY FIVE HI GOOD MORNING. GO
RIGHT AHEAD HI GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR THE SUBJECT BY
FELLOW AT THE LECTERN AND I'M
I'M POVERTY. AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THIS PARCEL
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD TO HEAR
YOUR VOICE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY. SEPARATOR BE GOING
TOWARD NEXT CALLER IN SUPPORT
OF FORTINO NINE. YES THAT WOULD
BE LINE NUMBER NINETY ONE NOT.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THE MORNING
LINE NINETY ONE YOU'RE IN MY
OWN. GEARING COMMITTEE YOUR NOW
LIFE. I REBEKAH GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ALSO
A PROUD MEMBER OF THE KELLY I
KEEP THE GAG COALITION AND THE
END CHILD POVERTY CAMPAIGN IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THIS GONZALEZ
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO CHECK IN
WITH THE MODERATOR MISTER
MODERATOR HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS
WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE. CURRENTLY
HAVE THREE OR IN Q. WONDERFUL
MISTER MODERATOR LET'S TAKE OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OUR NEXT
CALLER IS ONLINE NUMBER SIXTY
EIGHT SIX EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THE MORNING LINE SIXTY
EIGHT YOU RIGHT GOOD MORNING.
ALREADY HAD. SORRY ABOUT THAT
GOOD MORNING THIS IS DONNA
CALLING IN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM THE
ASIAN AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WE'RE GRATEFUL WE'RE NOT GOING
TO BE GOING TO OUR NEXT CALLER
MISTER MAHER RAIDER WE COULD
PLEASE BRING. UP YES ALTHOUGH I
NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD MORNING.
MORNING CHAIRMAN WHY THIS IS
JACKIE LONG AND CHECK HIGH RANK
AND TING CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN
MANY FAMILIES LIVING IN POVERTY
ARE WORKING HARD TO STAY
HEALTHY THE FED INTO A HOUSE
AND A LITTLE LONG WAY IN THEIR
SUPPORT. HOW DO A CO SPONSORED
WITH THE SECURITY. AFTER THIS
ONE IS GOOD YOUR VOICE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR NEXT
CALLER IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN
OH NINE MISTER MODERATOR. YES I
WOULD BE LYING NUMBER NINETY
TWO NINE. FINE IS OPEN GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
KEVIN IN SCOPE FROM THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SRONG SUPPORT OF
SB FORTINO NINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE WITH US
MISTER MODERATOR TO HAVE ANY
OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. IN
THE QUEUE. LAST ONE IN Q. SIR
YOU MAY CONTAIN CONTENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS A MODERATOR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
WERE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO IN
PERSON SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL PLEASE STAND AND COME
TO THE MICROPHONE. HEARING AND
SEEING NO ONE WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE GOING TO REMOTE HEARING ROOM
THAT'S ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
PLEASE COME FORWARD NOW. THERE
IS NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WERE NOT GONNA BRING IT BACK.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO START WITH
OUR ROUNDS OF OPPOSITION. IF
YOU ARE WANTING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO SENATE BILL
FORTINO NINE PLEASE DIAL EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. THREE THREE SIX
FOUR FOUR FOUR ONE. ENTER THE
CODE SIX SEVEN SEVEN FIVE ZERO
SIX NINE. THAT PHONE NUMBER IS
ON YOUR SCREEN NOW WE'RE GONNA
ASK THE MODERATOR. TO BE ABLE
TO PREPARE ANY CALLERS TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF FOURTEEN OH
NINE. CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP
THE COLORS THIS ORDER.
CERTAINLY IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
A POSITION TODAY. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THERE AND ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THAT'S ONE.
ZERO WE'RE GONNA GIVE UP THE
CALLERS A FEW BRIEF MOMENTS TO
BE ABLE TO GET INTO THE QUEUE
AND SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE. IN
OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN OH NINE.
GENERAL MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH WITH THE MOTION ON THE
FLOOR THAT MOTION IS A DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO PURPOSE ASIAN BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG. MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE. ON
THE LINE YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THEY'RE NOT. AT
THIS TIME SIR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOU MISTER MODERATOR
RIGGAN TRANSITION TO THOSE WHO
WERE IN OPPOSITION IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. IF YOU
COULD PLEASE STAND. HERRON
SCENE NO ONE WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO A REMOTE HEARING ROOM
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
HARIAN SCENE NO ONE WE DO HAVE
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR WE'RE
GONNA OPEN UP FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OUT FROM THE MISTER
VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU I'M-
COMING WITH CPA HAD I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET MY ARMS AROUND
THIS PARTICULAR BILL BUT- AFTER
LAST RECESSION WE'VE KIND OF
BEEN TOLD EVERYONE SHOULD BE AN
EMPLOYEE. AS OPPOSED TO AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR. SO
EMPLOYEES RECEIVE W. TWOS AND
HAVE PAYROLL TAXES WITHHELD SO
THEY SHOULD. THEY SHOULD BE
FILING JUST TO GET A REFUND IF
THEY HAVE NO TAX TO BUT THEY
STILL HAD SOMETHING WITH HELD-
SO I'M- TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
WHY SOMEONE WOULDN'T FILE MUST
PERHAPS THEY WERE. AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR WERE
SELF EMPLOYED. BUT THEN THEY
WOULD HAVE TO FILE A TAX RETURN
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO. PAY SELF
EMPLOYMENT TAX TO THE- US
TREASURY SO EVEN IF THEY DIDN'T
HAVE A LOT OF PROFIT THEY WOULD
STILL HAVE TO DO. A TAX RETURN
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO HAVE
SOME PROFIT SO THEY WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO PAY FOR RENT AND- FOOD
AND ALL THE REST. TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT. YOU KNOW WHICH
PARENTS ARE LEFT THE HOW YOU
DID HOW WOULD YOU WHY WOULD YOU
NOT FILE A TAX RETURN A AND I'M
I'M TRYING TO GET. A
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS NON
FILERS STATUS AND SORT OF MAYBE
IN THE BACK OF MY MIND. YOU
KNOW A WONDERING WHY TO USE THE
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WERE USING TO ENFORCE AB FIVE
OF POINT. AND USE SOME OF THOSE
RESOURCES INSTEAD TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE. TO FILE BUT I SUPPORTED
THE BILL. THAT WOULD- ALLOW
SELF EMPLOYED INDIVIDUALS TO.
BE ARTICLE QUALIFYING FOR THE
EITC. AND SO ON NOW I'M JUST A
LITTLE CONFUSED ON AND HOW HOW
DOES SOMEONE GET SO. TO PULL
PLACE WHERE THEY HAVE NO WITH
HOLDINGS. BUT BUT THEY HAVE
KIDS AND HOW HOW THE HOW THEY-
HOW DOES IT WORK SENATOR MORE
LOCKED UP THROUGH THE CHAIR IF
I MAY PLEASE THE CHALLENGE WITH
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT QUALIFY
FOR THE CALLIE T. I. T. C. IS%
THAT THEIR INCOME IS SO LOW
THAT THEY DON'T GET ANY MONEY
BACK THEY JUST DON'T GET ANY
MONEY AND SO THEY DON'T END UP.
FILING A AN INCOME TAX RETURN
AND BECAUSE OF THAT THEY THEY
HAVE NO IDEA THAT THERE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS CAL CAL
YANKEES PROGRAM IN THE AND THE
PROGRAM DESIGN THE BILL. OF
THEIR INCOME SO THAT THEY GET
INTO THE GET OUT OF THE DEEP
POVERTY CATEGORY IT INTO THAT
JUST PLAIN POOR CATEGORY
FRANKLY IT'S NOT ENOUGH BUT IT
IS A REAL STEP IN THE DIRECTION
OF A PUTTING REAL CASH INTO
PEOPLE'S POCKETS AND WHAT ENDS
UP HAPPENING IS THAT THE
EXPERIENCE SHOWS THAT THESE
PEOPLE ARE. OUR AND I DO DON'T
BROUGHT ON MY HEAD THAT I'M
THERE THE INCOME LEVELS ARE
BUT- THE POVERTY LEVEL IS ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR AND- AND IT'S I THINK THE
RANGE IS BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE. A
DAY ANYBODY UNDER THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR AND SO-
WHEN THEY GET THERE EITC CHECK.
A MAJORITY OF THE MONEY PAYS
FOR THE BILLS THAT ARE
OUTSTANDING INTERFACE FOR
NECESSARY NECESSARY ITEMS AND
SO IT'S GOOD FOR THE ECONOMY
AND IT'S GOOD FOR. FAMILY
BECAUSE THEY DON'T END UP ON.
IT IT HELPS THEM TO PAY OFF
THINGS THAT THEY NEED. THANK
YOU SO MUCH CABALLERO- ANY
LESS- COMMENTS MISTER MEISTER
BEFORE CHRISTMAS HURTS. YEAH WE
HAD SOME. THIS POOR PERSON
BATES IS BUILT OUT FROM THE-
REST BOARD AND SO I WILL TO
PICK ON. EVERY SO I'M JUST
CURIOUS. DO WE HAVE ANY. DATA
THAT SHOWS. HOW MANY PEOPLE
WERE TALKING ABOUT THAT ARE.
SOMEHOW ABLE TO PAY RENT AND
GAS AND FOOD IN. AND STILL NOT
HAVE A I HAVE A JOB AND TAKE
CARE OF IT ALL BUT NOT HAVE ANY
WITHHOLDING SO WHAT. WHAT KIND
OF DATA ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
HOW. HIS I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
20% OF OUR POPULATION IS UNDER
THE POVERTY LINE SO I I'M I
WANT TO BE RESPECTFUL BUT I'M
I'M TRYING TO SEE. HOW THIS ALL.
YOU KNOW FITS IN IN A IN IN
DOES IT MAKE SENSE. TO DO IN
AND SO THAT'S WHAT I'M
GRAPPLING LET I CAN ANSWER THEM
BUT I'D BE I'D LOVE TO HEAR
SOME DINNERS FOR THANK YOU. A
LOT OF POOR PEOPLE. I SPENT. AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF ENERGY
AND EFFORT AND MONEY AND TIME.
TO TRY TO GET PEOPLE IN WHO AND
DISTRESSED COMMUNITIES. TO FILE
FOR THE V. I. T. C. BECAUSE I
FIVE SAW THE- JUST THINKS THAT
UNBELIEVABLE PROGRAM. BUT
THERE'S JUST A LOT OF PEOPLE.
EVEN THOUGH THEY PAID A SMALL
AMOUNT OF TAX AND THEY HAVE A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE LIVING IN OUR
HOMES. MY A- TOTAL EXAMPLES
NORTHEAST VALLEY. APPOINTMENTS
IN LOS ANGELES THAT THE
COMMUNITIES THAT I REPRESENT.
SOME ATTACKS RETURNS I AM FROM
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE I KNOW THE
JUST EVEN IF THEY CAN GET MONEY
BACK DON'T FILE TAX RETURNS.
BECAUSE THEY THINK IT'S SUCH A
LITTLE AMOUNT THEY DON'T
PARTICIPATE AND- YOU KNOW. ON
THE LITERALLY DON'T FILED AS A
WHOLE I DON'T KNOW THE DATE IS
BUT IT'S A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF PEOPLE INVOLVED. IN
THE NOTION BEHIND THIS WHICH
GRABBED MY ATTENTION THE REASON
WHY IT OVER THE BILL. IS THAT
BY BEING THIS IN ANY WAY POSH
TO PEOPLE'S ATTENTION THE
UNDERLYING ISSUE BEHIND. THE I
USED TO GET MONEY TO. POP
THEY'RE NOT. YOU KNOW. THE A
MYSTERY COMMA MINUTES REALLY
WHAT IS. LR I DO CAN'T TELL YOU.
HOW MUCH. THEM WE CAN IS SO YOU
PEOPLE WHO ARE. BECAUSE THEY
DON'T THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
GET MUCH BACK THEY DON'T DEAL
WITH THE PAPERWORK THEY DON'T
HAVE AN ACCOUNT. AND NOW LIVE
IN IF WE CAN FORM THEN THAT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY GET A CHECK
BACK. MAYBE THIS COULD BE AN
INCENTIVE BUT I DON'T HAVE THE
SPECIFICS AS TO THE STATE
NUMBERS. BUT I CERTAINLY COULD
TELL YOU OF THE- REPRESENT. I
SPENT A YEAR WORKING ON THIS
PROJECT AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
WORTH THE WORK. TO STUDY IT-
BECAUSE SO MANY PEOPLE DON'T
FILE AT THE LOWER LEVELS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG GETS A I WOULD THINK
THAT IF THEY HAD A FEW HUNDRED
BUCKS WITH HELP THAT WOULD BE A
LOT OF MONEY. WOULD BE A LOT OF
MY EVEN TO GO TO SOMEWHERE
WHERE YOU GET YOUR TAX RETURNS
DONE FOR FREE WHEN. WE HAVE
LOTS OF FREE SERVICES AT THAT
THE STEP UP SO. I'M JUST TRYING
TO GET MY ARMS AROUND
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR- ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
EIGHT THANK YOU SAM THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIR THANK YOU
CENTER HERTZBERG LADIES IN
GENERAL COMMITTEE WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE A MOTION ON THE TABLE
HERE TO DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THAT WAS MADE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG. TO DO A LAST
CALL FOR COMMITTEE COMMENTS
QUESTIONS CONVERSATION LAST
CALL. IN NINETEEN NINE WE'RE
GONNA TURN OVER THE CENTER
CUBBY ON THE CLOTHES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
WROTE AND ARE YOU FOR THE
CONVERSATION TODAY AND I WAS
GOING TO REFER TO THE EXPERT ON
ON THE PHONE BUT I THINK THAT
THE I WANT TO THINK CENTER
HERTZBERG FOR HIS. IS
COMMENTERS INSTEAD IN THE IN
THE REPORT THAT TALK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT LEVELS AND IT REALLY
DEPENDS ON WHETHER- WHETHER
YOU'RE SINGLE INDIVIDUAL AND
THEN YOUR AGE AND WHETHER YOU
HAVE CHILDREN AND SO IT BECOMES
A- IT'S A GRID. BUT IT MASTER
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CALDERON HURDLES AND THANK YOU
SEE THE COVER US IN A COVER OF
THIS IS A MINOR ITEM BUT I
WANNA MAKE SURE YOU'RE GONNA
TAKE THAT. OF TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILLS WELL.
WELL MET MISTER MISTER CHAIR
THAT THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
MAKE IT MAKING MOVIE FROM. FROM
SHALL MAKE. AND LET ME JUST SAY
THAT I THAT THE SHOW. STATE FOR
WHEN STATE HARTMAN WE HAVE A
LOT OF DATA. AND IN IN IN.
COULD BE. THAT WOULD ALL THE
FOR. BOARD TO. PATIENTS HOW
CRAP FROM THE MAKE IT MAKES
SENSE FOR. NON SEVEN ONE CAN
THEN. TALK TO BUT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THE I THAT I EARN.
THAT THE FRENCH TAX BOARD HAS
READ. THERE ARE. TECH ASSIST.
AND THE REASON IS SO THEY CAN
THEY CAN DETECT AND I DO A TAX
SCHOOL FOR THAT ARE NOT THEIR
TO AND HIDING INTO CORP
STRUCTURE AND IF DIFFERENT-
ENTITIES AND IF THEY DO THAT IN
THAT AND THEY WERE ABLE BEEN
ABLE TO BRING IN NUMEROUS
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO THE
STATE COFFERS BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN ABLE TO IDENTIFY A WHEN
PEOPLE ARE HIDING RESOURCES
THEN THEY OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
FIGURE. THIS USING SAME SYSTEM
WHICH IS USING DATA THAT WE
HAVE AT THE STATE TO HELP POOR
PEOPLE THESE ARE DEFINITELY-
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO GET THE TAX. THEIR
REBATE THEY'RE ENTITLED TO SO.
I'M A LITTLE BIT AS IT IS TO
SAY THAT THEY MAY BECAUSE I
WANT THEM TO BE AS- I- WANT
THEM TO REALLY WORK AT TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THIS
RIGHT SO. ALL RIGHT I
APPRECIATE AS IN A CAREER- AND
SENATE CAREER WE'RE GONNA TABLE
IS MOMENTARILY IN ORDER TO COME
RIGHT BACK TO THIS- AND WE'RE
GONNA. COME BACK FOR THE ACTION
IN JUST A MOMENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WILL COME BACK TO THE
SECTION FOR FULL COME. IN JUST
A FEW MOMENTS BUT BUT WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO IS TURN
THIS OVER. TO THE BASED SENATOR
MORAL. BELIEVES IN TEEN I
NUMBER THREE. IN ITEM NUMBER SO.
THAT'S SB NINE. EIGHT SENATOR.
THE BILL ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN
INVESTMENTS. IN ITEMS. SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX. THAT
SENATOR MORE LOCK. IS WELL SO I
DON'T NUMBER THREE IN ITEM
NUMBER SIX MISTER VICE CHAIR.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT. WE WELCOME YOU TO AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE CENTER CAREER
TO HANG TIGHT HERE JUST A
MOMENT. AND WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH HER. SENATE CAREER OF. THE
CENTER MORE LIKE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO THE PRESENT. WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT OUT OF JUST TO FROM MY-
THAT WORKS. OKAY ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. CENTER
PARKING FLORA JURORS. AND IT
WILL NINE. EIGHT SURE THANK YOU
CALL. I HAD A TRIO OF OVERTIME
BY TWENTY SIX AGO TO FIT OUT
HOW ORANGE CAN TREASURER
COLLECTOR COULD USE MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF LEVERAGE AND NVEST
IN SPECULATIVE DERIVATIVE
INSTRUMENTS OF COURSE WHAT
ENSUED IS NOW HISTORY THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE FOR. TONIGHT
BANK MUST ALMOST ONE POINT
SEVEN DOLLARS FROM
INAPPROPRIATE. AND A SET BACK
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE
DRAMATICALLY. MASSIVE RELY
LOSSES. SHORTLY AFTER THE
STRETCH FISCAL I WAS APPOINTED
AS THE NEW TREASURER TAX
COLLECTOR FOR THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE AND TWENTY FIVE YEAR IT
WAS TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO TODAY
ON ON WHAT AND MARK SEVENTEEN
THAT WOULD APPOINTED THAT THE
GERMANS FAVORITE DAY OF THE
YEAR. SEVEN AND SO A AFTER I
BECAME TREASURER SERVICE TWELVE
YOU'RE THERE FOR TWELVE YEARS I
OFFERED NUMEROUS BILLS THE
CLEANUP IMPROVES SECTIONS FIVE
THREE SIX A ONE IN FIVE THREE
SIX THREE FIVE OF THE
INVESTMENT CODE FOR THE STATE.
IN FACT. OUR CHAIR OF THE
FORMER SUPERVISOR FOR CINEMA
COUNTY I WAS ABLE TO HIGHER
WEIGHT MY CHIEF INVESTMENT
OFFICER PAUL TALKING TO A
SIMILAR POSITION IN HIS COUNTY
AND I'M STILL BITTER ANYWAY.
WICKS THOSE WERE INTERESTING
TIMES EVERY BILL THAT DEALT
WITH INVESTING TAXPAYER DOLLARS
WHEN UNDER SEVERE SCRUTINY. OF
THE SENSITIVE DAYS ARE LONG
GONE BUT THE SIX THE SCRUTINY
SHOULD STILL BE IN PLACE. THE
INVESTMENT FIELD IS DYNAMIC IT
EBBS AND FLOWS IT SEES NEW
VEHICLES- AND WATCHES OTHERS
LEAVE THE MARKET PLACE. IT
MOVES AND THERE ARE THOSE TIMES
WHEN THE CODE SHOULD ALSO BE
MODIFIED TO ASSIST OUR
TREASURES. AND OVERSIGHT BY. SB
NINE NINE EIGHTY PROVIDES FOR
SMALL BIT MOVE. FRIENDS ARE
REGULAR UNDER THE- ANY ACT OF
NINETEEN FORTY. PARTICULARLY
UNDER RULE TO A SEVEN. WHICH I
FOLLOWED FOR DOZEN YEARS BUT IT
ALLOWS 1100% OF FUNDS TO BE
INVESTED IN COMMERCIAL PAPER.
BUT STATE CODE ALLOWS ONLY A
MAXIMUM OF 40% FOR SAN
FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES OTHER
CITIES ARE ONLY ALLOWED TO
INVEST TWENTY FIVE THEN THE
FOLIO IN COMMERCIAL PAPER SB
NOT AN EIGHT WOULD ALLOW
STUDENTS SPECIAL TRICKS
MATCHING ONE MILLION OR MORE TO
ALSO INVEST TO NOW JUST 40%
JUST LIKE LA AND SAN FRANCISCO.
LARGE PORTFOLIO HAVE TO GET A
CREDIT AND ADJOURNMENTS TOOLS
AND RESOURCES IN THE SHOULD NOT
BE AN ISSUE 40% IS THIS BILL
WILL THAN HALF OF WHAT IS FOR
IT FOR IN THE- AND WE WILL
PERSONALLY POSIT ARE. PRESERVE
SO THIS IS STILL A VERY SAFE
MODE CATION. NOW A CLOSE THE
DIVERSITY IN LIEU OF CAPPING
THE TOTAL IS FROM IS SURE TO
TEMP. AND COLLEAGUES THESE
REQUESTS WOULD PROBABLY BE
OMNIBUS BURKE MID BILL MATERIAL
OR OPPORTUNITIES BUT- THERE
REQUESTED. BY THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL TREASURES ASSOCIATION
I RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON SENATE BILL NINE NINE
EIGHT AND I DO HAVE WITNESSES.
RICHARD I BELIEVE I HAVE A
TOPPS MEDS FROM PALM DESERT ON
THE LINE. YES ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU SO MUCH AT CENTER MORE LIKE
WE PREACH THE VICE CHAIRS WORK
ON THIS AND- ALWAYS LOVE
WORKING WITH HIM. WE DO HAVE TO
ONE. AS OUR LEAD WITH HIS IN
SUPPORT THAT'S GOING TO BE TOM
NANCY'S CHAIR THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL TREASURES
ASSOCIATION. AND WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO HEAR FROM JOHN JOHNSON
TODAY ON THE PHONE LINE HE'S
THE DEPUTY TREASURER. FROM THE
OFFICE THE AUDITOR CONTROLLER
AT TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR IN
THE COUNTY OF SAN BERNADINO. SO
MISTER MODERATOR WERE LOOKING
FOR A JOHN JOHNSON IN A TOM
THAT'S WE'LL START WITH TOM
NETS MISTER MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE BOTH ON THE PHONE OR DO WE
NEED TO GET THEM IN THE QUEUE.
THEY ARE BOTH ONLINE INFO INNER
MODE AND ARE FREE TO SPEAK
THANK YOU SO MUCH SO WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A MISTER THOMAS METS
FIRST FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL TREASURES ASSOCIATION
MR MET'S YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES
THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOUR LIVE IN
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU RIGHT A
WRITER GOOD MORNING PERSON
MCGUIRE AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE GOVERNMENT AT FINANCE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TOM NETS I
AM THE LEGISLATIVE CHAIR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA MISSPOKE CHARGES
ASSOCIATION I AM HERE TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF CMJ THE
BILL'S SPONSOR. SB NINE NINE
EIGHT WILL UPDATE CLARIFYING
STRING STATE INVESTMENT COAT IT
HAS FOR PARKS AS BRYCE YOU'RE
MORE LIKE YOU SAID. THE FIRST
PART WOULD RAISE THE COMERCIAL
PAPER CONCENTRATION OF THAT.
FROM 25% 240% PRECISION SPECIAL
DISTRICTS WITH A HUNDRED
MILLION OF INVESTMENT. THE
INTENTION IS TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD BY PUTTING LARGE
CITIES AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
ON THE SAME FOOTING AS THE
COUNTY HERE'S- GETTING TO PART
TWO OF THE BILL. THAT WOULD
CORRECT EGHT. SINGLE YOUR
CONSTANT LIMIT FOR COMMERCIAL
PAPER AND THE LACK OF ONE FOR
MEDIUM TERM NOTES FOR CITIES
AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS. THE
CURRENT 10% SINGLE ISSUE OUR
CONCENTRATION LIMIT FOR
COMMERCIAL PAPERS FOUGHT
BECAUSE IT IS CALCULATED BASED
UPON INSURERS OUTSTANDING
COMMERCIAL PAPER. ONE IS MANY
THE ISSUERS ISSUE BETWEEN FIVE
BILLION TO TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS ABOUT STANDING
COMMERCIAL PAPER YEAR. SO IN MY
CITY EITHER THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PORTFOLIO IF I
BUY COMMERCIAL PAPER FROM ONE
IT ISSUES TEN BILLION A YEAR MY
SINGLE ISSUE OR LIMIT WOULD BE
ONE BILLION DOLLARS THREE TIMES
THE SIZE OF MY ENTIRE PORTFOLIO.
IN THE CASE OF THE MEDIUM TERM
NOTES THEY HAVE HIGHER CREDIT
RISK MARSHALL PAPER YOU LONGER
MATURITIES. THERE IS NO SINGLE
KISHORE CONCENTRATION LIMIT. SO
SB NINE NINE EIGHT WITH
ESTABLISH A COMBINED 10% SINGLE
ISSUE OUR CONCENTRATION MOMENT
FOR BOTH COMMERCIAL PAPER AND
MEDIUM TERM NOTES. CITIES AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS BASED UPON
AGENCIES TOTAL. ASSETS BE NINE
NINE NINE WOULD ADDRESS.
REFLECTING LANGUAGE IN THE
GOVERNMENT CODE THAT
EFFECTIVELY PRECLUDES INDIAN
TRIBES AS PUBLIC AGENCIES FROM
PARTICIPATING IN PUBLIC AGENCY
INVESTMENT POOLS. AB THREE ZERO
SEVEN NEXT SUNDAY TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN RECOGNIZED CALIFORNIA
INDIAN TRIBES PUBLIC AGENCIES
AND AUTHORIZED AND ENTER INTO
JOINT POWERS AGREEMENT WITHOUT
RESTRICTION. FORTUNATELY THIS
IS BRENDA MIND BY A JOINT
POWERS CODE LANGUAGE THAT PRE
DATES AB THREE THERE ARE SEVEN.
LANGUAGE IMPLIED ONLY PUBLIC
AGENCIES THAT ARE LOCAL
AGENCIES INVEST IN JOINT POWERS
INVESTMENT POOLS. SB NINE NINE
EIGHT WHAT- ADDRESSES WITH
CORRECTIVE LANGUAGE AND BUT
ALSO FOR THE SECTION IN THE
CODE STATING THAT INDIAN TRIBES
ARE ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE OR
INVESTING JOINT OURS. POOLS
SUBJECT TO THE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS. OF THE JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY THAT HAVE ORGANIZED
RECALLS. DURING THE PARK FOR OF
SB NINE EIGHT. AS FOR THINKING
PART OF THE BILL IT'S STRANGE
TO ANTICIPATED SITUATION THAT
IS WITHOUT HISTORICAL PRECEDENT
IN THIS COUNTRY THE POSSIBLE
ADVENT OF NEGATIVE INTEREST
RATES THIS COULD OCCUR EITHER
THROUGH CENTRAL BANK ACTION OF
MARKET FORCES. CURRENTLY TWELVE
TRILLION DOLLARS OF GLOBAL DEBT
IS AT NEGATIVE YIELDS. EUROPE
AND JAPAN AND IN MARIN AND
NEGATIVE INTEREST RATES FOR
YEARS AND CANNOT GET OUT OF.
WHAT SB NINE NINE EIGHT WOULD
DO. A LIMITED EXCEPTION TO THE
CODE AND ALLOW LOCAL AGENCIES
TO BUY AND HOLD ZERO OR
NEGATIVE INTERESTED CRUEL US
GOVERNMENT SECURITIES DURING A
PROLONGED PERIOD OF. MARKET
INTEREST RATES NOW THE
PREFERRED. STRATEGY OF MOST
LOCAL AGENCIES IN THAT. IN THAT
PERIOD OF NEGATIVE INTEREST
RATES WOULD BE TO DEPOSIT
SURPLUS CASH INTO BANKS. THEIR
STUDIO ENTRANCE THE COUNCIL
SYSTEMICALLY IMPORTANT
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS WHICH IS
FINE. BUT THERE CAN BE TWO
ISSUES WITH THAT NUMBER ONE
THE- INSTITUTIONS MIGHT NOT BE
ABLE TO ACCEPT LARGE DEPOSIT TO
THE CAPITAL RATIO CONSTRAINT.
THE OTHER PROBLEM COULD BE IN
THE PAST NEGATIVE CHARGES TO
INSTITUTIONAL. IN OTHER WORDS
IF I HAVE A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS UNDER POSSIBLE BANK OF
AMERICA AND THE BANK TO STOP IS
TO IMPOSE. SPECIAL CHARGE EXTRA
ONE PERCENT. ON THE DANISH
BANKS IN EUROPE. THAT WOULD
COST. SIX CHARGES ABOUT THIRTY
SECONDS SO THOSE. OKAY UNDER
THE CIRCUMSTANCES NECK INTEREST
SECURE MIGHT BE BETTER AT THE
PRESENT PRINCIPLE BACK INCLUDES
MY REMARKS THE REASON STATED
JUST STATED CMT URGES YOUR VOTE
I VOTE ON SB NINE NINE EIGHT I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. A FEW
MINUTES THANK YOU TO MIND YOUR
THANK YOU. YES MONEY TODAY VERY
GRATEFUL WE'RE GOING TO TURN IT
OVER NOW TO JOHN JOHNSON HE'S
CHAIR OF A DEPARTMENT THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE OF THE
AUDITOR CONTROLLER TREASURER
TAX COLLECTOR COUNTY SAN
BERNARDINO MISTER JOHNSON THE
FLOOR DOORS. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
WIRE COMMITTEE MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING AGAIN MY NAME'S JOHN
JOHNSON SHOULD THAT BE A
TRAITOR FOR THE COUNTY OF
STAMINA DINO ON BEHALF OF IN
THE MASON HONOR CONTROLLER
TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
NINETY EIGHT. I ESPECIALLY WANT
TO THANK SENATOR MORLOCK FOR
AUTHORING THE BILL AND HIS
LEADERSHIP. IN BRINGING A BILL-
FORWARD I'M GOING TO BE
SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY TO THE
NEGATIVE INTEREST RATE PROPOSAL
AND A MAN'S TO THE BILL THAT.
FOCUS ON CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT
CODE SECTION FIFTY THREE SIX OH
ONE SPOT SIX. ON THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE- AS TOM MENTIONED.
REALLY PUT US IN A PICKLE- THE
LANGUAGE WAS ADDED IN VERY
WISELY SO IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX TO PREVENT ME. PURCHASE OF
EXOTIC INSTRUMENTS OR
DERIVATIVE TYPE INSTRUMENT THAT
DON'T HAVE A NORMAL REGULAR
CASH FLOW COMPONENT- YOU KNOW
THOSE INSTRUMENTS SUMMER
SPECIFICALLY- NAMED AND-
SUBCOMMITTEE. OF THAT SECTION-
BUT HAVE NO BUSINESS IN IN
BEING PURCHASED IN A
GOVERNMENT- INVESTMENT POOL ON
OPERATING POOL. IT CAUSES A LOT
OF PROBLEMS IF WE START TO
CONTEMPLATE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IN A NEGATIVE INTEREST RATE-
SCENARIO THE COUNTY SAN MARINO
WE MANAGE A NINE MILLION DOLLAR
INVEST TOOL- WE ARE TRICKLING
RATED BY BEEN TRADING. WE HAVE
VERY STRICT GUIDELINES IN TERMS
OF DIVERSIFICATION AND WE HAVE
TO NOT ONLY MEET OUR POLICY
STANDARDS AND STATE CODE
STANDARDS WE ALSO HAVE TO
MANAGE TO VETERANS GUIDELINES
WHICH REQUIRE DIVERSIFICATION-
IF WE WERE TO HAVE NEGATIVE
INTEREST RATES WE WERE REALLY.
VERY BOB. MENTIONED YEAH. IF WE
WERE A TO BUY A SECURE THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY WOULD BE NEGATIVE
AND ONE THING TO CONSIDER IF WE
WERE TRULY IN A NEGATIVE
INTEREST RATE ENVIRONMENT AND
WORKING MY- THE BLOOMBERG
TERMINAL BY NOW. AND IN FIVE
BASIS POINTS THIS MORNING THE
FIVE YEAR U. S. TREASURY AS
TRADING AND THIRTY THREE BASIS
POINTS THAT REALLY DOESN'T GIVE
US A LOT OF ALTITUDE HERE AND-
BED POWELL- CHAIRMAN POWELL IS
SAID THAT. HE DOESN'T PLAN TO
PURSUE A NAY. STRATEGY HOWEVER
AND THE SAME. AND SAID THAT HE
WOULD. PULL OUT ALL STOPS AND
DO WHATEVER IS NECESSARY IN
ORDER TO. KEEP THE ECONOMY
UPLOADED MEET THEIR DUAL
MANDATE. SOME REAL THIS BILL
WISELY DOES. IS IT ALLOWS US TO
BUY US GOVERNMENT- SECURITIES
EITHER ISSUED OR BACKED- IN THE
IN THE EVENTS AND ONLY IN THE
VAN AND DURING THE PERIOD OF
NEGATIVE INTEREST RATES MAY
NEGATIVE. RIGHT ARE I'M SIMPLY
CANNOT MANAGE MY PORTFOLIO THAT
THE ABILITY TO BUY U.
GOVERNMENT SECURITIES AND
MAINTAIN A TRIPLE A RATING-
ABOUT- DID THE 5% OF MY
PORTFOLIO RIGHT NOW IS IN THE-
GOVERNMENT SECURITIES SO THAT
IS A- FREE WHAT. THE DAY. I.
AND IT WOULD COVER YEAH THIS SO
I IN AND HAVE SEEING THE IN AND
FOR HOWEVER SOME FOOD THOUGHT
FOR THE COMMITTEE AND THE ON.
AGAIN WE'VE- YEAH A LOT OF
RESEARCH ON WHAT WE BANKING
HAVE. AGAIN RATES FOR NEGATIVE
IN THE IN STATES AND HOW WOULD
MANY OUR POLL METER ABA. WE HAD
A AND CONFERENCES AND OTHER
COMMITTEES AS WELL AS WITH OUR
INVESTMENT ADVISORY FIRM AND
YOU KNOW JUST OUR PEERS ACROSS
THE STATE IN CALIFORNIA AND I
THINK IT WOULD BE WELCOME
HOWEVER IF IN ADDITION TO U. S.
GOVERNMENT SECURITIES. WHICH
WOULD BE AGAIN IMPERATIVE WE
HAVE TO HAVE THOSE AS TOOLS TO
MANAGE OUR PORTFOLIOS- BUT WE
WOULD ALSO HAVE THE OTHER
INSTRUMENTS- THAT ARE
ENUMERATED IN FIFTY THREE SIX
OH ONE. MEDIUM TERM HAS COME
PAPER WHICH IS ALSO IN THE BILL
MENTIONED AS WELL AS- YOU KNOW
BANK NOTES AND NEGOTIABLE- CD'S
WOULD NEED TOTAL. DO YOU THINK
THREAD IN THE A COST WE'RE
GONNA MANAGE. AND A NAY
INTEREST RATE IN THE- SO WITH
THAT I THAT YOU FOR CONSIDER.
AND I'M- I'LL ANSWER ANY
QUESTION THAT YOU MAY. THANKS.
MISTER JOHN FRAZIER TO TESTING
WERE NOW GOING TO MOVE FORWARD
ON OTHER. WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO SPEAK IN SOME OF THE BILL
WE'RE GONNA BE GOING BACK TO
THE MODERATOR MISTER MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE EIGHT.
NOT CURRENTLY BUT ALL WE WILL
RE PROMPT IF YOU'D LIKE TO. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT
FROM THE PHONE LINES IN A PRESS
ONE THEN JUST BROKE THIS TIME
HIS PLEASE PLEASE DO ONE MORE
PROMPT AT WOULD BE VERY
GRATEFUL MISTER MODERATOR. YES
I'M GONNA GO TO LINE UP FOR
THIRTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE EIGHT
ONCE AGAIN IT'S ONE THEN ZERO
TO PUT YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE
LINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE MORNING LINE THIRTY
FIVE YEAR LIVE IN COMMITTEE
FIRST AND LAST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. GOOD MORNING MR
TURN MEMBERS OF THE BAND
MEANTIMEI'LL LOOK. CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS
CERTIFICATION. I'D LIKE TO ARE
NOT ONLY REGISTER MY SUPPORT.
BUT THANK THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS FOR WORKING WITH
SPECIAL DISTRICTS. THIS IS.
VERY TIMELY. AND VERY. MODEST
AND REASONABLE. AND
RESPONSIBLE. AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR CONSIDERING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS TEN OUR
GRATEFUL TO HAVE YOU BACK LET'S
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. NO ONE
ELSE IS CUED UP AT THIS TIME
SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
TODAY SIR. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BE TURNING TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
IN SUPPORT AND ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FORWARD THOSE IN SUPPORT
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE.
TINO ONE STAND AND OR RAISE
YOUR VOICE FOR NOT GOING TO BE
GOING TO A REMOTE HEARING ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
HEARING SEEING NO ONE WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE GOING BACK TO OUR
LIVE LINES WE'RE GONNA BE
CHECKING IN WITH THE MODERATOR
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE UEUE UP. ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL NINE
NINE EIGHT MISTER MODERATOR.
CERTAINLY CHAIRPERSON IF YOU'D
LIKE TO VOTE OPPOSITION FROM
THE PHONE. NINE ONE. ZERO AT
THIS TIME THAT'S ONE BAND ZERO.
GONNA GIVE IT A FEW MOMENTS FOR
THE MODERATOR TO BE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB NINE NINE EIGHT WE
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S PATIENCE
IN WORKING WITH US TODAY. WANT
TO SAY A SPECIAL THANK YOU TO
THE TECHNICAL TEAM FROM LDC TO
NIKOLINA FIVE FOR ALL THE WORK
FROM THE CAUCUS WE ARE TRULY
APPRECIATIVE. MISTER MODERATOR
LET'S CHECK IN TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ON THE
TELEPHONE LINE. THERE'S NOT
WANTING TO AT THIS TIME SIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS THE
MODERATOR MISTER MODERATOR
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
TRANSITIONING TO IN PERSON
TESTIMONY WE'RE GOING TO SEE IF
THERE IS ANY ONE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB. NINE EIGHT IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. NINETEEN NO ONE
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GOING TO A
REMOTE HEARING ROOM ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. HEARING SEEN NO ONE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WE'RE GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
MISTER MOORLACH I UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE GONNA BE TAKING THOSE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS. YES SIR
ALRIGHTY THANK YOU SO MUCH IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
OR WOULD SOMEONE LIKE TO BE AT
A DANCE A MOTION. WE HAVE A- WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR BELL A
MOTION BY SENATOR BELT. THIS
BILL HAS A MOTION OF DO PASSED
IS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR. WE'RE
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO THE VICE
CHAIR. FOR ANY CLSING
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I WANT TO THANK TOM
METS. KNOWN MISTER MEDS FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS AS A
CONSUMMATE PROFESSIONAL. A AND
A SERIOUS TECHNICIAN IN THE
MUNICIPAL INVESTMENT TO A RENO
SO IT'S A REAL HONOR TO WORK
WITH HIM AND- ONE OF TING. JOHN
JOHNSON FROM. SANDRA DINO HAD
TO HAVE BEEN AT. YEARS OF
WONDERFUL. A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE- THE COUNTY TREASURER THAT
CAN USE WELL NEIGHBORING COUNTY
SO. IT'S A WOULD TO PARTNER
WITH THEM. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. OVERVIEW OF THE BILL-
EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS- BUT I
COULD I WANNA KINDA MAYBE.
SINCE I DIDN'T MENTION IN MY
REMARKS- THIS BILL DOES HAVE A
COMPONENT ON NEGATIVE INTEREST
RATES. WHICH WE HOPE WE NEVER
SEE. BUT BUT IT HAS A CURVED
AROUND THE GLOBE ANOTHER FIXED
INCOME MARKETS AND SO PROVIDING
THE PROVISION FOR THAT INSIDE-
THE STATE CODE IS. IS FOR SITE
IT IS ANTICIPATING- HOPEFULLY
WILL NEVER HAVE TO HAVE TO
UTILIZE IT BUT IF IT DID IT DID
OCCUR WOULD HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DO EMERGENCY LEGISLATION
TO IT TO PUT IT IN SO I WANT TO
THANK THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE SOMETHING
THAT I THINK WOULD BE A MODEL
FOR THE REST OF THE NATION. AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE MISTER AT VICE CHAIR AND I
MEAN IT'S- YOU FOCUS ON THESE
ISSUES AND YOU REALLY DIGGING
TERM YOU BRING YOUR EXPERIENCE
TO THE TABLE AND WE APPRECIATE
ALL YOUR HARD WORK SIR. THE
MOTION WAS BY SENATOR BALLOTS
TO DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
FLOOR MR NOW PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR MCGUIRE HIGH.
WIRE SENATOR MORLOCK. MORAL
OCCUPIES SENATOR BILL. BILL HI
IS SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
HURTADO HI THE TITLE HI SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HIGHS SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER HI SIX VOTES
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX YEAR
VOTE LAYS IN GENERAL COMMITTEE
WERE GONNA KEEP THAT BILL OPEN
TO ALLOW THE MAJORITY LEADER TO
ADD ON AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
THAT'S SB FOURTEEN OH NINE THAT
SENATOR COPYRIGHT. I HAD A GOOD
DISCUSSION LISTENER COPY YEAR
THERE WAS A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG DO TAXES
AND MEANT TO PREPARATION WE'RE
GOING TO CALL THE ROLL. MISTER
NOW PLEASE DO SO SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI WATER HI I SENATOR
MORLOCK. SENATOR BATTLE. ALL
EYES HERTZBERG. SENATOR HURTADO
I RICARDO ALL RIGHT SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI SENATOR
WINNER WIENER HI YEP BY BOTH
SPECIFIES YOUR VOTE WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN AND- CENTER
COME HERE AND I WILL BE GETTING
TOGETHER NEXT WEEK TO DISCUSS
FURTHER AGAIN SO OF WORKING
WITH US IN OUR COPIER AND
APPRECIATE HER HARD WORK ON
THAT REALLY CRITICAL ISSUE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE
COMMITTEE WE ARE NOW GOING TO
BE MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX
IT'S SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX AND
GUESS WHO'S BACK IT'S THE VICE
CHAIR ON SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX
WE'RE GONNA CONFIRM THAT ARE
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OUR
LEAD WITNESSES CHRISTINE
COMPTON IN JULIE MELANAU SKI IS
GOING TO WILL BE ON THE LINE
AND AGAIN I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH NIKOLINA WHO'S BEEN
OUR GO BETWEEN WITH- THE LIVE
LINE AND THEY ARE PREPPED AND
READY TO GO TO MISTER MOORE
LOCKED THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
FOR LETTING ME BE THE CLOSER OF
TODAY. RESEARCHER AND CALL.
SAYS TO. WHEN WHAT WERE WE
DON'T EVEN ABOUT THE CAR WHICH
ASSUME THAT WE HAVE AN
INSURANCE POLICY THAT COVERS
THE SITUATION MISTER CHAIR
SHOULD YOUR LOVELY HOME CATCH
FIRE AND THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
USES SEVERAL TRUCKS TO PUT IT
OUT. YOU WOULD BE SHOCKED IF
YOU'RE WATER DISTRICTS INTO A
BILL FOR THE THOUSANDS OF
GALLONS OF WATER USED TO DOUSE
THE FLAMES. YOU WOULD THINK
IT'S ALL FOR ONE. AND THAT THE
WATER WOULD BE FREE AS A MUTUAL
AID FUNCTION THAT'S WHAT
NEIGHBORS DO. AND THAT'S HOW
IT'S CURRENTLY STRUCTURED BUT
THERE IS A LITIGATION OCCURRING
IN CALIFORNIA. THEY WERE
CHARGED THE FIRE DEPARTMENT FOR
THE WATER CONSUMED FROM THE
HYDRANTS. EIGHTY ONE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
BEING SUED TO CHALLENGE THE
LONGSTANDING METHOD OF FINDING
WATER USED IN FIGHTING FIRES.
IT IS BEEN IN OUR WATER RATES
FOR DECADES WE'VE ALL BEEN ALL
THREE ONE. BULLET CATION
STIPULATES THAT INCLUDING THIS
MUTUAL BENEFIT COST THIS ALL
FOR ONE APPROACH VIOLATES PROP.
PROPOSITION TWO EIGHTEEN.
CONSEQUENTLY MANY ARE INCURRING
LEGAL EXPENSES TO DEFEND A
COMMON PRACTICE SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SIX SIMPLY CODIFIES THE
OBVIOUS AND IS DESIGNED TO
ELIMINATE THESE NUISANCE
LAWSUITS. SPECIFICALLY FIRE
HYDRANT SYSTEM CHARGES ARE IN
FACT PROPERTY RELATED AND
THEREFORE ALLOWABLE. SB THIRTY
SIX AMENDS THE IMPLEMENTING
STATUTE OF PROPOSITION TWENTY
TWO ONE EIGHT TO REFLECT A
RECENT COURT CASE ON THIS TOPIC
AND AS YOU MENTION I HAVE. TWO
VERY IMPRESSIVE I WITNESSES I'M
DELIGHTED TO HAVE KRISTIN
COMPTON OF THE IRVINE RANCH
WATER DISTRICT WHICH ALONG WITH
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT IS SPONSORING THIS
BILL AS MY FIRST KEY WITNESS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE
CHAIR LADIES IN GERMAN THERE
ARE GOING TO BE THREE WAYS THAT
YOU CAN TESTIFY ON SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SIX FIRST AND FOREMOST
BUT WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX. HIT UP
OUR TOLL FREE NUMBER THAT
NUMBER IS. 1-877-336-4441 THE
CODE IS. SIX SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
ZERO SIX NINE YOU CAN SEE THAT
NUMBER ON YOUR SCREEN NOW IF.
LEAD TO PICK UP THE TO SOME
HERE IN SOME OF SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SIX WE'RE GOING TO ASK
EACH WITNESS TO BE TO PROVIDE
THREE MINUTES OF TESTIMONY I
PROMPT IF YOU CLOSING ON THAT
THREE MINUTES WE'RE GONNA START
FIRST AND FOREMOST WITH
CHRISTINE COMPTON. IRVINE RANCH
WATER DISTRICT MISTER MODERATOR
TO WE HAVE MS COMPTON PREPARED
AND IN THE QUEUE. WE DO AN
AIRLINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING IS
CONTINUING FROM AT. YOU'RE NOW
LIVE IN COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AND THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO JOIN YOU
REMOTELY TODAY. I ARE W. D. IS
THE CO SPONSOR OF THE MEASURE
BUT THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY WATER
AUTHORITY AND I SERVED AS THE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS OFFICER
AND DEPUTY GENERAL COUNSEL FOR
THE IRVINE RANCH WATER
DISTRICT. WHERE A WATER SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO BE IN CONTROL
LEARNED COUNTY. I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A QUICK MOMENT OF YOUR
DAILY THANK COMMUTER MORE LOCK
FOR ALL THREE THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. IT MAY SOUND LIKE AN
INCONSEQUENTIAL MATTER BUT THE
DIVIDING LINE BETWEEN WATER AND
FIRE SERVICE IS AN IMPORTANT
ONE TO GO TO THE HEART OF WHO
SHOULD PAY FOR THE COST OF
DESIGNING. CONSTRUCTING AND
MAINTAINING HYDRANT. SHOULD BE
PROPERTY OWNERS THAT ARE
DIRECTLY SERVED BY AND BENEFIT
FROM THE HYDRANT OR THE FIRE
AGENCIES THAT YOU COME TO CUT
OUT PROPERTY FIRES. SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SIX PORTION BECAUSE IT
BECAUSE THAT CONFIRMS THE
LONGSTANDING AND NEARLY
UNIVERSAL DO THAT IT SHOULD BE
THE PROPERTY OWNERS THAT ARE
DIRECTLY SIR BY AND BENEFIT
FROM THE HYDRANT. THE BILL
BALADI BUT WATER AGENCY COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH OPERATING
MEANING HEY NINA FROM A HYDRANT
IN ADDITION TO THE WATER THAT
FLOWS THROUGH THEM. ARE PART OF
THE PROPERTY RELATED WATER
SERVICE. THEY PROVIDE CUSTOMERS.
EITHER EIGHTY SIX. THE CASE.
THAT LAYS OUT THE LAW AND- FOR
THAT THE TERM. CONSISTED WITH
PROPERTY EIGHTEEN AT THE CAL
CON. IT CONFIRMED A WATER
SUPPLIER CAN COULD BE COST IN A
THREE. SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX
IT'S IMPORTANT TO PROTECT FIRE
HYDRANTS THE BEST TEAM AN INCH
TO ENSURE. PUBLIC WATER
SUPPLIERS ARE ABLE TO OPERATE
EFFICIENTLY SIZED AND
PRESSURIZED WATER SYSTEM TO
SUPPLY WATER TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS. YOUR TO FIGHT FIRES.
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE REGARDING THE BILL. INTO
RESPONDED THE DISTANCE. ISSUES
RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS I HOPE
YOU CAN SUPPORT IT TODAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISS COMPTON WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY RIGHT THIS IS A
GREAT BILL WE'RE NOW GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO JULIE MOUNT
OWSKI. HE'S REPRIMAND
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION INDEED
THE FIRE DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA. IS NOT ASKING WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE YOUR
NOW LIVE YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES
IT'LL GIVE. I AND YOU. CAN CALL
HERE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEF
ASSOCIATION AND THE FIRE
DISTRICT THAT. OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT IN SB THIRTEEN SIX.
ARE A THREE THEIR VERY CAN.
ABOUT THE WILL OF LOS. THAT AND
FIVE AGAIN DOZEN OF WATER CHOIR
THROUGH. THE WITH MISSION
INCLUDE ANY. THAT FIRE HOW. TO
THERE ARE. TO RIDE WATER PROPER
THROUGHOUT CAL. TO EIGHT IN
FIRE FIGHTING. ARMONK PROPER
RELATED SERVICES PROVIDE WATER.
TO RESCUE AND BUSINESSES AND
CLOSE ONE OF THE MOST. ACCESS
TO THE- THAT THEN WHICH I DO.
AND STYLE IN ONLY MAIN BY THE
WATERS FROM. IS CRITICAL TO OUR
TO THIRD OUR COMMUNITY WITH
ADEQUATE TIRES. I LIKE TO POINT
OUT TO. I DO NOT THREE IN YOUR
CAN AND NOW. ANALYSIS DOES GO
ON TO CORRECTLY NOTE THAT THIS
WOULD NOT ONLY BE CERTAIN TO
PURSUE IT COULD HAVE ENORMOUS
IMPACT AND FIRE AGENCIES
BUDGET. AS YOU KNOW WHEN THE
BEST OF TIMES REDUCING FIRE
SERVICE BUDGET CAN RESULT IN
DEEP CUTS THE PERSONALITY
QUICKNESS BUT NOW WITH THE
ECONOMIC DEVASTATION LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND AGENCIES ARE
FACING THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CONSEQUENCES COULD BE EVEN MORE
DIRE FOR THOSE REASONS WE
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE FOR
THE MEASURE TO MAINTAIN A
RATIONAL AND REASONABLE CHARGES
CURRENTLY ALLOWED TO FUND FIRE
HYDRANT. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISS MONO SKI WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
MISTER MODERATOR WE ARE NOW
GOING TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE AND IF YOU
COULD PLEASE- PREPARE
INDIVIDUALS TO BE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF SB. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
SIX I'LL TURN IT OVER TO YOU
MISTER MODERATOR. THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE NOT ALREADY PLACED
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE YOU MAY
DO SO BY PRESSING THE ONE
ADVANTAGE HERO COMMANDS ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE ONE THEN ZERO.
WE DO HAVE. SEVERAL LINES
QUEUING UP WE'LL START WITH
LINE NUMBERS THIRTY EIGHT THREE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
MORNING YOUR LIVE IN COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST AND YOUR ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TURN
MEMBERS THIS IS DOCTOR MEMO
CALLING ON IN ON BEHALF OF
CONTRA COSTA WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY MISTER MODERATOR
LET'S TAKE OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. OUR NEXT CALLER IS
ONLINE NUMBER NINETY SIX NINE
SIX IT'LL HELP. GOOD MORNING
MISTER SHARON- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JONATHAN CLAY ON BEHALF
OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT'S YOU'RE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY SIR. WE'RE NOT GOING
TO BE TURNING IT OVER TO OUR
NEXT CALLER MISTER MODERATOR.
SB LINE NUMBER NINETY THREE
NINE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING MR
CHEN NUMBERS CHRIS ANDERSON ON
THE AFTER THE INITIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES LONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT CALLER IS
LINE SEVENTY ONE SEVEN ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GOOD MORNING. I'LL
BE THE FIRST TO WISH YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE BRIAN AND JACKING
WITH REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY
AND WE'RE AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
MEASURE. YES IN YOUR SPOT
ONLINE THE EIGHTY GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BUT MR MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. IT ONLINE NUMBER NINETY
NINE NINE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD MORNING NINE NINETY
NINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THIS IS MORE A TOP
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ANAHEIM PUBLIC UTILITIES
DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER UP. THIS A MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT CALLER
IS LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FIVE
ONE ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD MORNING ONE OH FIVE IN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR JAMIE
MINOR ON BEHALF OF THE EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
SANTA MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
MISTER MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
CALLER'S LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIX ONE ZERO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON. BUT AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTY VELMA
WITH FORTITUDE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT THAT
<c.red>S A HAT TRICK FOR BALLET TODAY</c>
SO I THANK YOU SO MUCH GREASY
WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE BACK WITH
US. MISTER MODERATOR WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT CALLER IS ON MY
NUMBER. FIVE SEVEN FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON COLOR
BY SEVENTY FIVE CAN YOU CHECK
YOUR LINE FOR ME. ALL RIGHT
MISTER NOT SPONSORED BY WILL
MOVE ALONG TO LINE THEM THIRTY
THIRTY FIVE THREE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION.
RESIGNING AMONG OTHERS BOTH
FIRE AND WATER DISTRICTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
TENET HELL. IT'S A MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. COLORS ON
LINE ONE HUNDRED ONE HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE
OFF ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA ROSA AND PASADENA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISS ROSS. MISTER
MODERATOR LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT CALLER IS ONLINE
NINETY FIVE NINE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON MELISSA ONE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH MELISSA. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
MISTER MODERATOR. NEXT CALLER
IS ON LINE ONE HUNDRED AND ONE
ONE ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS NINETY
MONTH IN ON BEHALF OF C<c.cyan></c>
AMONG THE VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
AND ONE EMPIRE Q. KHILADI
AGENCY AT THE PARK. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. MISTER MODERATOR THE
SUIT COULD CHECK HOW MANY FOLKS
DO WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE. I
STILL HAVE FIVE REMAINING AT
THIS TIME. DOING A GREAT JOB AS
THE MODERATOR LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER NINETY
SEVEN NINE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COLD WAR LIMóN
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF AUSTIN
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NICKEL. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
BE GOING TO OUR NEXT CALLER
MISTER MODERATOR. NEXT CALLER
IS ON LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND TWO ONE ZERO TO YOUR LINE
IS A- GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTERCHAIR AND
MEMBERS GLENN FOR ALL WITH THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY WATER
AUTHORITY PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
THE MEASURE WILL GREATLY
INCREASE YOU KNOW CENTER
MORLOCKS LEADERSHIP AND URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AS A MODERATOR LET'S CHECK IN
WITH OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT CALLER IS ON LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FOUR ONE ZERO FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH KANTOR DIJO GO WITH
THE CA GROUP ON BEHALF OF
THE FOR A CITY OF FRESNO AND
THE CITY OF SANTA CRUZ BOTH IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. MISTER
MODERATOR THE TRANSITION TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. NEXT CALLER IS
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND THREE ONE
ZERO THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
THIS IS DEBBIE MICHAEL ON
BEHALF OF THE EAST BAY
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT
WHERE IN THE PARK WHEN I THINK
THE AUTHOR AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MISS
MICHAEL. MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THE NEXT WAS THE
LAST- AND THEY HAVE SINCE
DROPPED OFF THE CONFERENCE ARE
Q. HAS. EXPIRED ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS A MODERATOR WERE
NOW GOING TO GO TO THOSE IN
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
CAN YOU PLEASE STAND AT THIS
TIME. HEARING SEEN NO ONE STAND
AND OR SHOUT WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
GOING TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ANYONE IN SUPPORT
HEARING SEEN NINE WERE NOW
GOING TO BE GOING BACK TO OUR
PHONE LINES. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO NOW SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION IN SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX PLEASE DIAL.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE
SIX FORTY FOUR FORTY ONE.
PLEASE ENTER THAT CODE SIX
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE ZERO SIX NINE
THAT'S ALSO ON YOUR SCREEN
MISTER MODERATOR LET'S GET
THOSE COLORS KEYED UP IF YOU
COULD PLEASE MAKE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT. THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ABOUT VISIT
GEN PRESS ONE THEN IT'S ZERO AT
THIS TIME THAT'S ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ALL RIGHT. MISTER
MODERATOR THAT'S CHECKING DO
YOU HAVE ANY COLORS IN THE
QUEUE. NO ONE IS COMING UP AT
THIS TIME SIR ALL RIGHT LET'S
DO ONE LAST- LOOK SEE AND THEN
WE'LL CALL IT A DAY MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD DO ONE
THAT'S ANNOUNCEMENT. ONE NINE
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO PLACE
YOURSELF INTO THE QUEUE. AS WE
WAIT TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY IN
THE QUEUE A CENTER HERTZBERG
WAS- COLLEGES LIKE TO MAKE.
INDEED THERE IS PLEASE. SOME
YEARS AGO WHEN I HAD THE
DISTINGUISHED PLEASURE TO
CHAIR. THIS COMMITTEE MISTER
CHAIRMAN. I INTRODUCED A BILL
LOOKING TO THE DEFINITION OF
WATER UNDER PROPOSITION TWO
EIGHTEEN. IT MET WITH A GREAT
DEAL OF OPPOSITION AS TO HOW WE
DEFINE WATER AND I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
TODAY AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THIS HELPS MY CASE
TREMENDOUSLY UNDER SB TWO
THIRTY ONE. AS WE APPLY
PRACTICAL LIMITATIONS INFORMED
BY IMPORTANT CIRCUMSTANCES TO
FURTHER EXPAND THE DEFINITION
OF WATER AS IT IMPACTS PEOPLE'S
HOMES AND THAT MIGHT OTHERWISE
AFFECT WHAT THE WORK THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS DONE AS PARTY'S
LITIGATE SO WITH THAT. I WAS
EXCITED TO SEE THIS BILL AND I
ENTHUSIASTICALLY- MOVEMENT
FIGURE HERTZBERG IT HAS MADE
THE MOTION WHICH IS DUE PASS OF
THE FLOOR WE'RE GONNA GO BACK
TO OUR CALLERS. LET'S CHECK IN
WITH THE MODERATOR MISTER
MODERATOR ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
ON THE LINE. TôI NO OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME IT'S A MODERATOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
GREAT WORK TODAY THIS IS GOING
TO BE OUR- FINAL BILL OF THE
DAY FOR TODAY'S HEARING. AND
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE WE'RE GONNA
SEE IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL. AND SEE ONE KNOWN AT THE
MICROPHONE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO A REMOTE HEARING RUMOR
GOING TO CHECK IN WITH ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. TEACHERS ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION HEARING SEEN NO
ONE WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. TO THE FLOOR. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. HEARING SEEN NINE. MISTER
MORLOCK WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO A
QUICK CLOSE PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I'D LIKE TO THINK
CHRISTINE THOMPSON FOR DOING A
GREAT JOB. OF WORKING FOR THE
INDUSTRY- TO ASSIST IN THIS SEE
VERY EXPENSIVE NEW. MAYBE MAYBE
A DIFFERENT FORM OF THE VIRUS
THAT TO AFFECTING EIGHTY ONE OF
OUR- WATER IN THIS POLL.
AGENCIES AND- CENTER HERTZBERG
THANK YOU FOR MAKING THE MOTION
CHRISTINE COMPTON WAS STAFF
ADVISER TO. MY ONE OF MY
SUPERVISOR REAL COLLEAGUES TO
YOU YOU KNOW- FORMER SOME OF
AND BILL CAMPBELL. SO KIND OF
FUN TO HAVE ALL THESE.
RELATIONSHIPS AT INTER TWINED.
ALL MISTER CHAIR JUST WANNA
DEVIATE FOR JUST A SECOND
BECAUSE YOU DO FUN STUFF AND
BECAUSE SO MANY OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THE STATE HAVE NOT
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF GOING
THROUGH A GRADUATION CEREMONY.
I WAS TOLD TODAY THAT I SHOULD
WEAR. SOMETHING THAT REFLECTS
MY COLLEGE AND SO I AM WEARING
MY LONG BEACH STATE TIE AND I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE A LITTLE
MENTION OF IT JUST FOR ALL THE
KIDS THAT. YOU KNOW JUST DIDN'T
GET TO ENJOY YOUR GRADUATING
CEREMONY FOR THANK YOU. FOR
LETTING ME- DEVIATE BUT WITH
THAT MIXTURE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST. AN AYE VOTE ON SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX AND I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE WATER
DISTRICTS. BLOCK MORE THAT EVEN
CALLED IN AND WE'RE ON OUR LIST
AND I JUST WANNA- ENCOURAGE AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
THE YEAR JUST TO GRADUATE I
BELIEVE YOUR DISTINGUISHED
ALUMNI AS WELL CORRECT I HAVE.
RECEIVED THE ONE NIGHT OF THE
YEAR AWARD IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY SPECIAL
TO ME THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
NOT THAT I CAN ADD AND YOU AND
MR SPIELBERG. THE COMPANY YEAH
VERY GO. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN
GENERAL AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
HERTZBERG GETS DO PASS OF THE
FLOOR. MISTER GRINNELL LET'S
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR MCGUIRE
AYE MCGUIRE HEISER MORLOCK I
WILL LOG ON SENATOR BILL. BILL
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG EYES
HURTADO I HELLO SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I'D SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER HI THE SEVENTH AT THE
SEVEN ZERO VOTED FOR THE
DISTINGUISHED ALUMNI THAT BILL
IS OUT RECALLS IN THE ROLE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
PLEASE HOLDFOR SIXTY SECONDS
WE'RE GONNA GET OUR PAPERWORK
TOGETHER WE'RE GOING TO CONFIRM
WHO NEED TO ADD ON AND WE'RE
GONNA GET YOU OUT HERE
MOMENTARILY THANK YOU SO MUCH
TO THE COMMITTEE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE LTC TEAM
THEY'VE BEEN DOING A FABULOUS
JOB EACH AND EVERY DAY FOR
EVERY COMMITTEE. THAT WILL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU.
BECAUSE
BACK.
NINE BUT IF. VERY FIRST.
BY THE- LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE
HAVE THREE BILLS THAT RUNNING
CATCH FOLKS UP ON WE'RE GONNA
START WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
NINE THREE FOUR BATES THIS
MOTION WAS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTED
SIX ZERO MISTER NOW PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS SENATOR
WIENER. RIGHT WIENER HI SEVEN
ZERO VOTE THAT DEAL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE IN SB
NINE THIRTY FOUR NOW MOVING ON
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB NINE NINE
EIGHT THE CURRENT VOTE IS SIX
ZERO IT'S THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR MR NOW
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. SENATORS BURKE. OKAY
AT THE SEVEN ZERO VOTE THAT
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN FINDING LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SP
FOURTEEN OH NINE. CURRENT VOTE
IS FIVE ZERO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. MR NOW PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS
SENATOR MORLOCK. SENATOR
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG
AT THE SIX ZERO HOPE THAT BILL
IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE
AGAIN COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE THANK YOU FOR
WORKING FOR- COLLABORATIVELY
WITH US. AGAIN NEXT WEEK NEXT
THURSDAY WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
AT EIGHT THIRTY PLEASE PREPARE
FOR FOUR AND A HALF HOUR
HEARING NEXT THURSDAY HI THAT
WILL BE OUR LAST HEARING FOR
SENATE BILLS. FOR THE NEXT
SEVERAL WEEKS THANK YOU SO MUCH
TO EVERYONE FOR ALL THE HARD
WORK WE'RE NOW JOINED. PAGE UP
CALLING.